Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freak Show und zwar in der 307.
Variante. Heute sieht die ganz neue Variante aus.
Die 307. Variante. Nachdem wir festgestellt haben, dass die anderen 306 alle nicht taugen.
Keine Ahnung. Irgendwie kriegen wir es nie hin. Diese Sendung wird nie fertig werden.
Wir müssen immer wieder eine neue Version raushauen und gucken,
kommt das jetzt an? passt das jetzt, war es das jetzt eigentlich?
Immer noch hat sich irgendwer beschwert im Blog.
Auf der Suche nach dem perfekten Podcast.
Ja, der wahre Podcast ist nie fertig.
Das stimmt. Genau, der Weg ist das Ziel.
Und das Kunstwerk wird einfach die ganze Zeit geschliffen und optimiert.
So sieht es nämlich aus. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Ich bin's Tim.
Zu meiner Seite ist Roddy.
Guten Abend.
Auf Platz 3 heute.
Ja, zumindest der Nummerierung deiner Mikrofone.
Genau, aber auch nur das.
Headset Nummer 9. Das ist einfach alles total verwirrend hier.
Naja, es sind einfach unterschiedliche Inventarisierungen.
Das Headset Nummer 9 steckt im Port Nummer 3.
Ich kann euch auch nach Headset oder Portnummer benennen und bist du mal die
11, ne was bist du die 10 oder die 4, Ralf? Kannst du dir überlegen.
Also ich habe die Fernbedienung, da ist eine 4 drauf. Ich bin im Port Nummer 4, das stimmt immerhin.
Auf dem Headset, das müsst ihr mir sagen, was da drauf steht.
Da steht nichts, aber auf der anderen Seite steht 10. Aber das Headset ist ja
auch nicht dem Port zugeordnet.
440.
Weil die Headsets, wie du dir sicherlich vorstellen kannst, ich habe mehr als 4.
Deswegen auch die hohen Zahlen.
Die sind frei kombinierbar.
It's a feature.
Ja, das ist.
Wenn eins mal knarzt.
Genau, also es ist ja immer mal was kaputt und dann habe ich ja noch welche
in meinem mobilen Koffer und so weiter.
Und in der Wohnung hängt noch eins und manchmal verleiht man mal welche und so weiter.
Und über die Jahre habe ich mir halt mehrere zusammen geraubt, shoppt, genau.
Immer wenn was günstig auf Ebay zu holen war, zack, bumm, hätte so eine Suche
laufen. Das hat jahrelang wunderbar funktioniert und so muss ich dann nicht
immer den vollen Preis zahlen.
Das macht sich ganz gut hier in so einem Unternehmung mit eingeschränkten Investitionsrahmen.
Anyway, ja, wie schon erwähnt, die Sendung hat angefangen und ihr seid dabei
und wir haben wieder ein paar interessante Themen für euch ausgegraben.
Aber anfangen wollen wir erstmal mit dem alten Scheiß vom letzten Mal.
Der auch nie fertig wird.
Ja, der auch irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Man macht irgendwelche Aussagen und dann
stellt sich später raus, ist gar nicht so.
Das ist euch schon mal aufgefallen.
Wobei,
Wir wurden ergänzt, wir wurden nicht überlegt.
Oder? Ach nee, nee, nee. Also ich wurde zumindest auch korrigiert.
Nicht unbedingt immer richtig korrigiert, aber korrigiert.
Schauen wir mal. Fangen wir mal an.
Möchtest du anfangen?
Ja, wobei das glaube ich keine Korrektur ist. Ich wollte nur eine Wasserstandsmeldung rausgeben.
Letzte Sendung hatte ich ja Metrovis vorgestellt. Wir hatten uns diese lustige
Visualisierung von Projektplänen in Form von U-Bahn-Fahrplänen.
Und ja, wie ich auch tate, nimmt das hübsch Traktion auf.
Wir haben 2700 Views auf der Seite. Ob die sich jetzt alle im Plan gemalt haben, unklar, aber immerhin.
Und ich war am Wochenende.
Du kannst doch nochmal kurz erklären, worüber du redest, weil es gibt ja auch
Leute, die vielleicht die letzten Saison nicht haben.
Das habe ich eigentlich getan, dachte ich. Also es ist ein Open Source Tool,
was Gantt-Charts in menschenfreundlich zeichnen lässt, sodass sie hinterher
aussehen wie knuffige, freundliche, bunte U-Bahn-Pläne.
Und nicht wie diese bedrohlichen Projektpläne, die alle... Genau.
Und man braucht kein Microsoft-Projekt dafür und kein Open-Projekt.
Und der Editor ist gleich mit drin und menschenverstehbar.
Und das Backend ist einfach nur eine JSON-Datei und in der kann man auch direkt rumeditieren.
All so ein Kram. Hört euch die letzte Sendung an.
Ja, und der Herr Gant dreht sich im Grabe um.
Ja, das ist okay. Das gehört dazu, wenn man tot ist. Damit muss man dann leben, was danach einem kommt.
Was ein Stress.
Das bringt das Leben und der Tod so mit sich.
Die Grab-Rotation, das ist ja schon so ein Faktor.
Kann man schon Kraftwerke und KI-Farmen mit...
Es gibt auch das Gerücht, dass die Rotation von Steve Jobs im Grab den Apple
Park mit Energie versorgt.
Und ich war am Wochenende in Göttingen mal wieder, den Göttinger Podcast Cluster besuchen.
Gibt es den noch?
Also Cornelis, den ich da besucht habe, Cornelis Kater vom Podcast Schöne Ecken.
Empfehlung, immer noch ein sehr feiner deutscher Podcast.
Der hält das Banner des Göttinger Podcast Clusters noch hoch.
Ich fürchte auch, er ist glaube ich der Einzige so aus der alten Truppe. Aber er macht noch.
Und der hatte eine super Idee noch für einen zusätzlichen View von Metrovis,
wo ich dann auch wieder dachte, so scheiße, es ist so dermaßen naheliegend,
warum zum Teufel bist du da wieder nicht selber drauf gekommen?
Aber das gibt es erst in der nächsten Sendung. Ich hatte seitdem jetzt keine
Zeit dazu implementieren, aber da kommt noch was Lustiges.
Cliffhanger.
Cliffhanger. Alles nie fertig. Aber das wird lustig, damit er sofort sagen,
ja okay, hätten wir auch in der Sendung schon drauf kommen können.
Also wartet mal ab, da passiert noch was.
Okay, also dann gibt es nächste...
Ah, und Erfolgsmeldung, ein erster DFG-Antrag wurde mit einer Visualisierung davon beantragt.
Ob er genehmigt worden ist, unklar, hinterher hat es an mir gelegen.
Ja, wissen Sie, der Antrag war schon ganz gut. Also, ob er diese Knubbelgrafik da ist und ne.
Das ist das eigentliche Benchmark.
Oder? Ja, wie viele DFG-Anträge kriegt man damit durch? Gucken wir mal.
Ja, das kam in den Kommentaren. Was auch in den Kommentaren kam,
war eure Hinweise zu unserer Zahlendiskussion.
Viele Hinweise.
Genau, da haben wir auf jeden Fall ordentlich auf die zwölf bekommen.
Oh nein.
Ja, offensichtlich.
Und ja, ich muss zugeben,
ich weiß nicht genau, warum ich es nicht erwähnt habe, aber wir sind jetzt tausendfach
nochmal darauf hingewiesen worden, vollkommen zu Recht, weil das hätten wir
natürlich noch machen sollen,
als wir so über warum 12 überhaupt und wo kommt denn das her und vor allem,
wie ist denn das so mit der 12 und den Händen, nicht wahr?
Also wie der Mensch so zählt und dass das Dezimalsystem irgendwie sehr naheliegend
ist für den Menschen, weil wir ja zweimal fünf Finger haben,
das kann glaube ich jeder ganz gut nachvollziehen,
aber die Zwölf...
Lässt sich ja auch an den Händen gut abzählen, weil man ja, und in manchen Ländern
ist das verbreitet, in Deutschland habe ich das ehrlich gesagt noch nie gesehen,
dass das irgendjemand tut.
Es war mir auch komplett neu, dass das geht.
Mir war es nicht neu, mir ist es bloß nicht eingefallen, in dem Moment das zu
erwähnen, aber es gibt die Technik mit dem Daumen in der Handinnenseite die Glieder abzuzählen.
Der Finger, der anderen Finger.
Der anderen Finger, genau, der man ja dann so drei Gelenke hat und das heißt
immer, wenn du dann so auf die Ritze zeigst, die sich da bildet,
dann kannst du eben mit dem Daumen mal eben zwölf abzählen. Vielen Dank.
Oder die fleischigen Stellen zwischen den Ritzen. Das kann man halten,
wie man will. Das sind so oder so drei pro Finger.
Und weil der Daumen zählt, hat man nur vier Finger übrig.
Genau. Ich habe mich dann gefragt, dahinter steckt dann ja auch noch wieder
so ein lustiges Kulturding.
Ich halte jetzt mal links die ganze Hand hoch und rechts zwei Finger.
Jeder hier im Studio weiß sofort, welche Zahl ich jetzt hier anzeige.
Ja, weil unser Gehirn einfach so trainiert ist.
Auch die jetzt zuhören, wissen, welche Zeit du anzeigst.
Selbst die.
Ausnahmsweise muss man mal nicht zugucken hier in dem Podcast.
So und jetzt nehme ich den Daumen nach dem eben gelernten Verfahren und tue
den in die Mittelposition des Ringfingers.
So welche Zahl habe ich jetzt gerade angezeigt?
Na jetzt die Frage, zählst du vom kleinen Finger aus?
Ich glaube, die Konvention ist, glaube ich, dass man vom Zeigefinger aus.
Aber schon, dass du überhaupt nachfragst, ist ja schon quasi Co-Idee.
Ja, weil ich so nicht zähle.
Eben. Also sprich, so vom Instinkt her denkt man erstmal, ja klar,
damit kommst du irgendwie bis zwölf, aber du musst dann ja irgendwie doch so
diese eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht, eine acht habe ich angezeigt.
So, wenn ich erst nachzählen muss, wo ist dann der Gag? Aber ich glaube halt
in Kulturen, die das einfach den ganzen Tag so machen,
die denken da eben nicht drüber nach, sondern denen erschließt sich einfach
aus dem Bild heraus sofort, welche Zahl das ist, weil die das einfach so gelernt
haben, wie wir halt diese zwei Finger mit zwei Hände mit zehn.
Also zählen und zahlen ausdrücken, sondern auch mal zwei unterschiedliche Anwendungsfälle.
Also das Zählen ist ja nur, dass man selber zählt,
Eine Zahl bildet sozusagen oder eine Summe. Du kannst das ja selber machen und
fühlen, ob das dann auch gleich taugt, um eine Zahl anzuzeigen.
Das spricht dann wiederum mehr für die Dezimalvariante.
Aber um dein Argument sofort zu zerlegen, guck mal auf deine Uhr.
Da stehen auch keine Zahlen und du weißt genau, welche Uhrzeit sie anzeigt,
obwohl da Zeiger in irgendwelche Richtungen zeigen.
Das ist ja mein Argument, sowas musst du halt lernen. Also sprich,
wenn du in einer Kultur unterwegs bist, die nur bis zwölf mit den Fingern zählen kann,
die müssen dann halt wahrscheinlich nachzählen, wenn jemand einfach die ganzen
Hände mit seinen Zehnfingern in die Hände hält, weil es einfach nicht Erlerntes
ist, sondern halt kulturell überformt.
Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das eine Kulturtechnik dann.
Genau.
Genau, außerdem handelt es sich bei der Zwölf um eine sogenannte superhoch zusammengesetzte Zahl.
Da ist aber viel Superlativ dabei.
Nicht wahr? Also das ist nicht nur, es gibt auch hoch zusammengesetzte Zahlen,
aber es gibt super hoch zusammengesetzte Zahlen.
Und eine super hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl ist also wirklich ein Ding.
Und das gilt halt für die Zwölf.
und es gibt auch andere Zahlen, die halt, also es gibt also die ersten 15 super
hoch zusammengesetzten Zahlen jetzt bei den natürlichen Zahlen,
sind laut der Tabelle in der Wikipedia die 2, die 6, die 12, die 60, die 120,
die 360 und dann wird es immer mehr.
Wie ist denn das definiert? Das musst du jetzt verraten.
Na, die Definition ist erstmal eine hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl.
Weil das 2 eine hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl ist?
Eine hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl ist halt eine Zahl, die mehr Teiler hat als
jede kleinere positive ganze Zahl.
Also du meinst, die 12 hat mehr Teile als alle Zahlen, die kleiner sind als die 12?
Die 9 hat nur die 3 als Teiler, die 8 hat die 2 und die 4 als Teiler,
die 7 ist Prim, es sind sowieso relativ viele Prim dabei.
Und eine super hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl ist eine hoch zusammengesetzte Zahl,
die in einem, ich zitiere das hier nur, ich habe es nicht gesagt, ihr habt es verstanden,
die in einem strengen Rahmen mehr Teiler als andere Zahlen derselben Größenordnung hat.
Solch eine Zahl eignet sich dadurch besonders gut als Basis für einen vollen
Satz, wie zum Beispiel in der Zeitmessung, 60 Minuten, 60 Sekunden oder bei
Winkeln 360 Grad als Vollwinkel.
Dass die 60 relativ viele Teile hat, darüber hatten wir aber gesprochen.
Ja, ja, aber diesen Begriff, der kam dann auch nochmal auf und den kannte ich so noch nicht.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Und ich greife jetzt übrigens, entschuldige mich, dass ich jetzt mir nicht alles
nur, es waren so viele Leute, die sich zu diesem Thema geäußert haben,
dass ich mir jetzt die Namen nicht alle aufgeschrieben habe,
aber ihr findet das alles in den Kommentaren.
Auf jeden Fall gab es dann noch den Hinweis zu Recht, dass wenn man jetzt in
einem Kreis den Radius dieses Kreises am Rand abträgt, dann erhält man genau sechs Punkte.
Also hast du sozusagen ein Sechseck und dann durch eine weitere Halbierung kommst
du halt eben auch auf zwölf und damit ist diese zwölf im Kreis,
die wir bei der Uhr haben,
das Zwölfstundensystem auch schnell gefunden und die zwölf Monate komme ich
gleich noch drauf, zwölf Stunden,
zwölf Tierkreiszeichen, das Dutzend etc.
Also die zwölf ist halt nicht nur super hoch zusammengesetzt,
sondern einfach auch super hoch praktisch.
Dann wurde auch sehr viel verwiesen auf das babylonische Zahlensystem,
was wir glaube ich auch irgendwie erwähnt haben, aber nicht wirklich groß besprochen
haben, das sogenannte 6er-Gesimal-System,
also das auf Basis 60 arbeitet und was mir selber nicht so ganz klar war,
ist wie die das eigentlich geschrieben haben.
Die hatten da tatsächlich ein relativ komplexes Keilschriftsystem tatsächlich,
genau mit im Wesentlichen nur so zwei Symbolen, so einem Haken und so einem Winkel.
und aber was das System jetzt so besonders macht, ist, dass sie eigentlich das
erste Zahlensystem waren, die also jetzt wirklich mit einem Stellenwert gearbeitet haben.
Also du hast auf einer Stelle erstmal bis 60 hochgezählt.
Machen das aber ähnlich wie die Römer so ein bisschen, indem sie quasi,
sie haben halt immer ein Einzelzeichen, das heißt sie zählen erstmal unnäher.
Also sie machen wirklich für eine Neun,
neun Symbole in so einer 3x3 Matrix und dann haben sie ein Zeichen für 10 und
dann fangen sie wieder unnäher mit an und gruppieren das aber in dieser einen Stelle zusammen.
Das heißt eine 11 ist dann halt Winkelhaken so und das geht dann bis 60 oder
beziehungsweise bis 59 und dann mit der 60 beginnen sie die nächste Stelle.
Würde man jetzt natürlich vermuten, oha, super, haben die ja voll verstanden,
dann müssen sie ja auch eine Null haben, aber das...
Das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen.
Hatten sie wohl anfangs nicht und haben das dann später aber irgendwie nachgeführt.
Also ihnen ist dann irgendwann auch mal klar geworden, dass ihr System eigentlich
ganz geil ist, aber erst dann wirklich einen Sinn ergibt, wenn man eben noch
eine Null macht und dafür gab es dann später noch ein Zeichen,
was ich jetzt gerade vergessen habe.
Aber du weißt, dass es eigentlich zwei Nullen gibt.
Die, die du gerade beschrieben hast, ist die Platzhalter Null.
Also auf dieser Dezimalstelle oder sonstigen Stelle ist nichts.
Das ist die Platzhalter Null. Und dann gibt es aber auch die Null für 1 minus 1 ist gleich Null.
Ich würde das unterscheiden in Ziffern und Zahlen.
Naja, das eine ist halt, wie gesagt, die Platzhalter Null und das andere ist,
der Wert von Nichts ist Null.
Das hat relativ lange gedauert, bis diese Wert Nullzahl überhaupt eingeführt
wurde, benutzt wurde, weswegen es ja kein Jahr Null gibt.
Also weil die Null für, es gibt nichts da, quasi noch nicht erfunden war.
Ja, die Null verwirrt alle.
Die Null verwirrt alle.
Ist einfach so.
Genau, und dann gibt es die Besserwisser, die sagen, das dritte Jahrtausend
hat erst 2001 angefangen. Aber egal.
Das sind so die Diskussionen auf Partys, mit denen sich die Leute irgendwie,
sagen wir mal, ihren Datingscore schnell zerschießen.
Ja, ja.
So, aber dieser ganze 60er Spaß der Babylonier der hat also ganz gut gehalten,
korrespondiert ja auch super mit der 12,
und so haben wir dann diese 60er auch heute noch eben in der Zeitmessung und
in der Winkelmessung vor allem also da ist es dann eben auch wohl schon damals
zur Anwendung gekommen und tatsächlich kann man mit dieser,
Handzählmethode, die wir gerade besprochen haben, also ich zähle mit der Hand
bis zwölf, kann man dann unter Zuhilfenahme,
der anderen Hand auch schnell 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 das Ganze noch auf 60 bringen.
Also man kann damit schnell bis 60 zählen, indem du halt links einfach mit den
Fingern einfach nachzählst, wie oft du jetzt schon bis zwölf gezählt hast.
Und rein theoretisch kannst du natürlich auch bis 144 zählen,
wobei ich keine Ahnung habe, ob das irgendjemand gemacht hat.
Auf jeden Fall geht es und in der Besserwisser-Abteilung wurde natürlich auch
darauf hingewiesen, dass man theoretisch damit natürlich auch binär zählen kann und dann weißt du,
klar, man kann das total, also gehen tut das.
In dem Zusammenhang, wo du das jetzt auch gerade nochmal mit der Null so sagst,
also ich finde ja diese Unterscheidung.
Oder sagen wir mal, diese Begrifflichkeit durchaus nicht nur wichtig,
sondern ich finde, also für mich persönlich war das auch so ein Schlüsselerlebnis
oder so ein Schlüsselwissen, Schlüsselwissensitem.
Gibt es da einen Namen für?
Schlüsselwissensitem. Ein bestimmter Fakt, so eine bestimmte Wissenseinheit,
so ein Ding, wenn man das begreift und das ist so, das eröffnet einem sozusagen einen weiteren Kosmos.
Habe ich gleich ein Beispiel.
Aber ein Wort hast du dafür auch nicht. Was ich hier aber meine ist,
dass wenn man mal den Unterschied zwischen Zahlen und Ziffern sich vergegenwärtigt,
dann geht es auch mit den Computern Schnell einfacher.
Also Zahlen, System, Ziffern und Zahlen, also Zahlen im Sinne von etwas,
was konkret eine Menge ausdrückt, Ziffern im Sinne von,
was an einer Stelle, an einer Zahlenstelle steht und woraus ja dann sozusagen
auch der entsprechende Ziffern-Wortschatz bedient wird.
Also du hast in unserem Dezimalsystem eben zehn verschiedene Ziffern pro Stelle
und lustigerweise hatten halt die Babylonier eigentlich nur zwei verschiedene Ziffern, Ziffern,
die sie aber irgendwie mit Kombinatorik dann zu einer Wirkmächtigkeit von 60
verschiedenen Ziffern gemacht haben.
Das war natürlich total ineffizient, aber andererseits 60 verschiedene Ziffern
will man jetzt irgendwie auch nicht haben.
Also das kann ja keiner mehr auseinanderhalten, also Chinesen vielleicht noch.
Ja, aber diese Momente, diese magischen Computerversteh-Elemente,
die finde ich schon immer schön, wenn man die auch irgendwie vernünftig in seinem
Herzen speichert und bei Bedarf irgendwie so rausholt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das schon mal erzählt habt, mit dieser Butterfahrt,
auf der ich als Kind mal war.
Da war ich irgendwie so gerade knapp auf dem Gymnasium und meine Eltern waren
mit dem von einem guten Freund von mir zusammen, sind wir auf irgendwie so einer
olle, kennt ihr aber Butterfahrten?
Ja, ja, wo man alles kaufen muss und so.
Genau, dann werden da so Bettdecken mit Magneten drin verkauft und so.
Magneten?
Kamelhaar dachte ich oder Lama-Decken?
Also damals war Magnete das Ding. So Streifen, damit dein Körper durchmagnetisiert wird im Schlaf.
Ach so, so Schwurbelkrab.
Schon ein wilder Schwurbelkrab. Und für Kinder total langweilig.
Und wie alt war ich da, weiß nicht, wie zehn oder sowas ungefähr.
Wir hatten gerade C64er irgendwie zu Hause. Aber nichts gemacht außer Daddeln
und irgendwie fertige Spiele spielen.
Und der Freund von mir, der mit war, Marco...
Hat dann plötzlich angefangen auf einem karierten Blatt, weil er sich auch so
gelangweilt hat, so ein Feld 8x8 abzudingsen und dann da plötzlich einzelne
Felder auszumalen und andere weiß zu lassen und dann hat er mystische Zahlen daneben geschrieben.
und was hat er gemacht? Er hat quasi ein Pixel, ein Sprite definiert,
also Sprites damals in den Spielen waren halt,
nicht eine Spielfigur, die du dann halt mit wenigen Pixeln irgendwie malen musstest,
das war auch diese Pixelart, damals hatten wir nichts anderes und keine Vektoren und sowas,
gab es alles nicht und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, was er denn da macht und dann
erzählte er mir dann halt das Binärsystem, also dann eben,
jede dieser Zeilen halt mit einer Zahl und 0 und 1 Und das war so ein Moment,
wo in meinem Gehirn wirklich Dinge explodiert sind, weil alle hatten diese Erkenntnis,
oh mein Gott, ist das schlau, ist das clever, da hat sich irgendjemand ja total
Gedanken gemacht drüber,
wie du aus einer doofen Limitierung irgendwie trotzdem drumherum arbeiten kannst.
Das war vielleicht wirklich die totale Geburtsstunde meinen Computer- und Programmierwesens.
Sonst wäre mein Leben, glaube ich, ohne diese Butterfahrt anders gelaufen.
War dann wirklich Challenge accepted und zwei Tage später habe ich ihm dann
mein erstes animiertes Sprite gezeigt mit einer Figur, die dann eben läuft,
weil ich einfach drei Phasen hintereinander geschoben habe und immer in Rotation.
Das fand er dann wiederum total cool.
Und dann nahm das Schicksal seinen Lauf.
Okay, und bis zu welcher Zahl kannst du die 2 multiplizieren,
ohne ins Stocken zu kommen.
2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64, 128, 256, 512, 1024,
2048, 4096. So, und dann wird's wackelig.
8192, 16384, 32768 und 65536.
Und danach kostet drei mehr als ich.
Naja, ich meine, 16-Bit irgendwie, das finde ich, ist so die Kür,
die muss man schaffen und alles danach ist Bonus.
Zum Binärsystem habe ich aber auch noch eine Story. Ich hatte nämlich in der
Grundschule, war die zweite Klasse oder die dritte Klasse? Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Unser Grundschullehrer, das ist heute wahrscheinlich immer noch so,
Grundschullehrer lehren ja alle Fächer.
Und unser Grundschullehrer war dann der Meinung, er müsse uns Binärzahlen beibringen.
Wow.
In der zweiten Klasse.
Geil.
Und dann haben wir angefangen.
Zweite Klasse, Binärsystem, dritte Klasse.
Niemand hat verstanden, warum das sinnvoll sein soll, aber der hat echt Weitsicht bezeichnet.
Das war vor allen Dingen in einer Zeit, als halt so mit Rechnern eigentlich
noch gar nichts passierte.
Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit mehrere Sprachen früh lernen.
Wenn man erstmal verstanden hat, dass man eine Zahl auf unterschiedliche Arten
und Weisen darstellen kann, je nachdem in welchem System man das tut,
das öffnet irgendwie den Kopf, finde ich so.
Ja, der Unterschied zwischen Information und Repräsentation.
Das ist so, wenn man dann später Informatik, der Professor einem das nochmal
erklärt, dann benutzt er die Begriffe.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist es das halt.
Da hast du dann gesagt, ja, Grundschule. Grundschulekram, nervt nicht.
Nee, aber ich hatte dann auf dem C64 auch Spreiz gemacht, so ist es ja nicht.
Na gut, aber es gibt natürlich noch Dinge, wo ich falsch lag.
Wojtek kommentiert noch mal zu den Zahlwörtern.
Tim meinte ja, dass die Zahlen bis zwölf im Deutschen einsilbig sind,
abgesehen davon, dass das für die sieben nicht gilt. Du schießt.
Strike.
Sie war gar nicht mal so weit hinten.
Gilt es auch für 11 und 12 erst im Neuhochdeutschen.
11 und 12 waren im Althochdeutschen zum Beispiel noch die zweisimmigen Ein-Liff und Zwe-Liff.
Liff steht dabei für den Rest, das heißt das, was übrig bleibt,
wenn man den 10er voll hat.
Alter, ich hab den 10er voll.
Aber sowas von.
Ja, okay, gut Nehme ich mal so zur Kenntnis Stimmt natürlich Und das mit der
7, ich meine, wer sagt denn 7?
7 ist das 7 Naja gut.
Es wohnen nicht alle in Berlin.
Sagt man das nur in Berlin? 5, 6, 7 7 mal 7, was macht das?
Feiner Sand.
Ja, genau.
Ich komme ja aus dem Pott, wo viel verschludert wird, aber selbst da sagen wir sieben, fürchte ich.
Sicher?
Gib mal sieben Bier. Mach mal sieben Bier.
Ja, versteht jeder.
Sieben Bier.
Und dann SimCity war eigentlich auch...
Da waren sie eigentlich sieben Städte.
Da waren sechs Versionen vorher noch.
Oh Gott. Ja, Dinge werden jetzt langsam klar.
Gut, weitere Dinge, wo ich Quatsch erzählt habe. Gibt noch ein bisschen.
Monate, ja hab ich ja behauptet, ja Mond und so, 28 Tage und dann ist der irgendwie
rum im Wesentlichen Wenn.
Ich das nicht behauptet habe aber ja, kann sein.
Ne, ich hab das glaube ich behauptet und das ist totaler Quatsch Es sind natürlich
nur 29,53 Tage und Robert hat auch noch seinen Talk,
gepostet, wo er irgendwie da sehr ausführlich alles wiedergegeben hat,
was da ist, aber diese Aussage ist natürlich so nicht zu tragen gewesen und
auch nicht zu ertragen gewesen und von daher musste sie unbedingt korrigiert werden.
Mit anderen Worten, macht schon irgendwie alles Sinn mit den zwölf Monaten.
Es wird auch noch auf Stonehenge verwiesen und ein kleines Doku-Video,
das ja angeblich dieses Stonehenge-Rätsel jetzt auch komplett gelöst wurde.
Also man hat wohl herausgefunden, was diese Steinanreihungen alles so gemacht
haben und da waren dann Tage, Wochen dann teilweise mit acht und teilweise mit
sechs Tagen im Verlauf des Jahres abgetragen in diesen Steinen,
wodurch sich das dann halt alles ausgeglichen hat.
Ganz interessant.
In dem Zusammenhang fand ich interessant, habe ich neulich auch gesehen,
da hatte jemand einen Bericht gemacht, dass die Steine für Stonehenge tatsächlich
so über 200, 300 Kilometer weit transportiert wurden an den Ort.
Die sind nicht von vor Ort, sondern die sind aus einem Steinbruch von sonst wo.
Was auch völlig absurd ist, wenn man sich die anguckt, wie groß die sind.
Ja, wie groß die sind und was hast du gesagt, wie alt ist das, 2400 Jahre?
Dazu habe ich nichts gesagt. Ich sagte nur, dass die Steine von weit weg sind.
Ja, okay, vielleicht habe ich das gerade noch in Erinnerung oder vielleicht
stimmt das auch einfach gar nicht. Ich gucke mal kurz, ob das überhaupt… Aber sie sind.
Glaube ich, so Pyramiden oder älter, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Also, es wurde ab wenigstens 3000 vor Christus
in mehreren nach und nach aufeinanderfolgenden Versionen errichtet.
Mit anderen Worten, 5000 Jahre alt.
Ja, also älter als die Pyramiden.
Das auf jeden Fall. Wow.
Hm.
Aha. Seither wurde sie stark beschädigt. Ja, genau.
Ich packe den Link da nochmal mit rein.
Das ist alles ganz interessant.
In Sachsen, glaube ich, war das, hatten sie ja auch so einen ähnlichen Kreis ausgebuddelt,
allerdings halt aus Holzpfählen, sodass man im Prinzip nur noch quasi über so
magnetische Bodensonden und so nachvollziehen kann, wie die Anlage tatsächlich war.
Aber die ist halt auch relativ ähnlich, Kalender anhand von Sonnenständen und
so weiter, das war wohl das Ding damals.
Genau und diese Logik ist wohl auch in dieser Sonnenscheibe von Bebra und diesen
ganzen anderen Kalendern zu finden.
Ja, der Sonnenscheibe von Bebra, da habe ich gehört, dass das eine Sternkonstellationen
sollen die Plejaden sein.
Und wenn der Mond in einer bestimmten Phase nahe den Plejaden ist,
dann ist der und der Teil des Jahres. Und dann sollte man mal anfangen zu ernten
oder zu säen. Eins von beiden, das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Und Erich von Däniken ist tot und nicht von den Aliens abgeholt.
Ja, leider.
Der ist doch gestorben dieses Jahr.
Ja, ja. Dieses Jahr erst.
Also Aliens haben die Sonnenscheibe von Nebra nicht, oder Himmelsscheibe von Nebra nicht gebaut.
Da wo die gefunden wurde, haben die übrigens so ein Informationszentrum hingebaut.
baut. Wenn man in der Nähe vorbeikommt, kann man sich das mal angucken.
Extra deswegen hinfahren würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht.
Aber jetzt hier Stonehenge, also Sonnenuhr gut und schön, aber hätte man das
nicht auch in kleiner bauen können?
Also ich meine, warum dieser Aufwand, warum diese Größe?
Von der Physik her wird es doch in jedem Maßstab funktionieren oder liege ich da falsch?
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt wahrscheinlich das kultische und das,
wissenschaftliche und Götter hier und Geister dort noch nicht so klar voneinander
getrennt waren und dass das vielleicht auch irgendwo Herrschaftswissen war und
weiß ich nicht, vielleicht gab es da auch noch irgendwas anderes außenrum,
dass das gemeine Volk nicht gucken durfte oder so und nur der Oberpriester konnte
dann sagen, ah, hier, die Sonne, jetzt geht es los.
Damals gab es halt noch keine Incentification, da wurde noch für tausende von
Jahren gebaut. So nämlich.
Das war doch Qualität.
Zumindest das, was...
Ich meine, das funktioniert 5000 Jahre später noch. Also es wurde ja dann auch
wieder von irgendjemandem zerstört, dem wahrscheinlich diese Gottesanbetung nicht gefallen hat.
Bis sie dann gecheckt haben, dass das Ding eigentlich ganz praktisch gewesen wäre. Naja.
So ist es nun mal. Tant, Tant ist das Gebilde von Menschenhand.
So, dann habe ich mich nur ein bisschen verplappert,
als ich gesagt habe dass der Choke in dem Auto in den 70er und 80er Jahren dafür da war,
dass der Diesel irgendwie an Start kommt weil der muss ja irgendwie vorbereitet
werden, damit der ordentlich verbrennt,
und da es wurde,
Zurecht erstmal korrigiert, weil der Choke war nicht für Diesel.
Das hatte ich aber auch gesagt.
Der Benziner, aber ich habe dir im Zweifelsfall nochmal widersprochen und es
besser gewusst, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie auch immer, ist richtig.
Also der Choke war für die Benziner, die Benziner brauchten mehr Luft,
also sozusagen eine andere, eine fettere Mischung.
Fettere Mischung heißt mehr Benzin pro Luft.
Genau.
Und damit er überhaupt erstmal in Fallung kommt und wenn eine gewisse Temperatur erreicht wird.
Heute haben wir natürlich alles elektronisch geregelt und Pipapo und Heizelemente und so weiter.
Das gleiche gilt auch für den Diesel.
Insofern, also nein, nicht das gleiche gilt für den Diesel, sondern für den
Diesel ist was anderes erforderlich.
Da musst du halt richtig vorglühen. Da musst du dann überhaupt erstmal eine
Temperatur herstellen in dem System,
weil der dieselleher ein Selbstzünder ist, also nur durch die Kompression zündet
und nicht durch die Zündkerze, die der Benziner hat.
Genau.
Aber, also korrekte Begriffe, Vorglühanlage und der Choke heißt eigentlich Starterklappe.
Okay, auf Deutsch oder was?
Ja, das ist, sagen wir mal so, der Begriff und das ist das auch,
was da mechanisch letzten Endes stattgefunden hat.
Ich habe Starterklappe noch nie gehört. Für mich war Joke der Ausdruck.
Ja, das hat jeder gesagt, aber du weißt ja.
Beziehungsweise, ich weiß noch, dass damals, also ja war ich ja noch Kind,
aber da haben alle mal Schock gesagt statt Joke.
Also Joke kommt wirklich vom Englischen. Der Würger ist das.
Obwohl er in gewisser Hinsicht eigentlich genau das Gegenteil gemacht hat.
Er hat entwirkt, dass du den Wagen nicht mehr abwürgst.
Ich habe auch immer das Choke gesagt, war auch falsch.
Aber es gab auch so eine Art Diesel-Choke in manchen Fahrzeugen.
Und damit konnte man auch so ein gewisses, das war quasi so ein Handgas.
Also damit hast du je nach Fahrzeug die Menge gesteuert.
an Sprit, die da reingeht und auch so den Zündpunkt so ein bisschen versetzen
können und irgendwie halt die Kraftstoffmenge irgendwie damit im Wesentlichen geregelt.
Jetzt muss ich aber mal nachfragen, Verstellung des Zündpunkts ist doch ein
Selbstzünder. Was willst du denn da verstellen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Also klar, man verändert Motor, kennen Werte, damit er in Kalt auch läuft.
Also am Ende ist es das, was du tust.
Ja, okay, vergiss das mit dem Zündpunkt. Auf jeden Fall gab es in einzelnen
Dieselfahrzeugen auch so einen Handgas,
mit dem du irgendwie dem mehr Power gibst, damit er irgendwie in der ersten Phase besser läuft.
Anyway, auf jeden Fall, Joke, Benziner, Vorglühtaste war, beziehungsweise entweder
war es eine Taste, bei manchen Fahrzeugen ist es so eine Vorglühtaste gewesen.
Ja, so ähnlich wie der Zigarettenanzünder.
Man drückt die rein und irgendwann macht es so klack und sie kommt wieder raus.
So war es. Oder dann ging eine Lampe an und später war das dann so,
dass du das in der Schlüsselbewegung mit hattest.
Das heißt, du hast erstmal den Schlüssel in die erste Stellung gebracht.
Das war dann quasi die Vorglühstellung.
Und wenn die Lampe ausging, dann konntest du den dann anwerfen.
Genau, da renne ich mich auch dran.
Ja,
gut, genau. Dann weiterhin habe ich noch Unsinn erzählt, als ich gesagt habe, dass die Orion,
also das Modul, mit dem die Astronauten jetzt in der Artemis-Mission zum Mond
und wieder zurückgeflogen sind,
dass das ja die ESA gemacht hat.
war natürlich auch nicht ganz richtig.
Das Systemoran besteht im Kern aus zwei Bereichen, nämlich dem Crewmodul und
dem sogenannten Servicemodul.
Also das Servicemodul ist für so Luftversorgung, Lebenserhaltungssysteme und
den Antrieb zuständig und Crewmodul ist halt da, wo die Astronauten drin sind.
Da hatte ja die ESA auch gar keine Erfahrung.
Also die ESA hat ja noch nie selber,
Astronautentechnik gebaut in dem Sinne.
Columbus-Modul?
Ja, auf der Raumstation meinst du jetzt. Ja, aber um ins All zu kommen sozusagen. Für Raketen.
Keine echte Kapsel.
Genau, also ich würde nicht sagen, dass sie das nicht können.
Ich sage nur, das haben sie bisher noch nicht gemacht. Das ist nicht so die
Expertise bisher gewesen.
Da sollten sie allerdings bald mal ein bisschen nachlegen, finde ich.
und das wurde zurecht moniert und das wird hiermit dann für immer richtig gestellt,
ja und dann gab es die alte Diskussion ob Steve Jobs also es wurde sozusagen
nochmal in Frage gestellt ob Steve Jobs ein Heiliger ist,
und da kann ich nur sagen.
Ich bin Atheist, da kann ich mir nicht zu äußern.
Ja, nee, also ich ja nicht. Ja, also das ist ja Gotteslässigung.
Blasphemie.
Genau, Blasphemie. Ja, also es wurde vor allem auf diese Geschichte mit Xerox
und den anderen, also wir hatten ja diese Mutter aller Demos,
hast du die mal angeschaut?
Nee, die habe ich noch auf meiner Peile of Shame, aber die gucke ich noch.
Ah, ja.
Ich habe das irgendwann mal gesehen und ich erinnere mich daran, dass das sehr zäh ist.
Also es ist interessant, weil man da sehr, sehr viele Dinge das erste Mal sieht.
Ja, ja.
Aber das Demo selber ist, da muss man ein bisschen...
Abstriche machen.
Du redest jetzt wie so ein Gen-Zilla, der irgendwie seine Jump-Cuts vermisst. Bitte nicht.
Nein, ich brauche keine Jump-Cuts, aber es ist trotzdem zäh.
Zäh, das ist einfach ein Zeitdokument.
Es ist ein zähes Zeitdokument.
Ja, auch die Mondlandung ist ein zähes Dokument.
Ja, ich glaube, wenn man sich das in Realtime angucken würde,
wäre es wahrscheinlich auch zäh.
Aber es gibt ja dieses ganz lange Interview mit Steve Jobs, wo er davon erzählt,
dieses Demo gesehen zu haben.
Das bei Xerox meinst du jetzt?
Das bei Xerox und meint, da wären eigentlich drei Sachen gezeigt worden,
Und er hätte eine der Sachen nicht verstanden und deswegen nicht mitgenommen.
Networking.
Networking, genau. Also insofern sicherlich Standing on the Shoulders of Giants,
wie man so schön sagt. Also da ist sicherlich was dran.
Also Steve ist kein super Genie oder wenn er eine geniale Art hatte,
dann zu erkennen, dass jemand bei irgendwas,
an irgendwas dran ist und es gnadenlos einzupacken und mitzunehmen.
Also das ist so.
Ja, also vielleicht sollte man in dem Zusammenhang mal ein anderes Genie noch
nennen, was ja auch sehr eng mit Apple verflochten ist. Das ist Alan Kay.
Alan Kay war einer der Leute, die bei Xerox PARC da mitentwickelt haben und
der hat ja auch dieses Konzept des Dynabooks eins hervorgebracht,
wenn du dir das heute anschaust.
Das sieht aus wie so ein iPad mit Tastatur. Ja, also das war auch schon so ein
frühes Konzept, was er gemacht hat.
Alan Kay ist auch bei diesen User Interfaces
halt mit dabei gewesen und hat also sehr viel erdacht und ist auch einer der
Mitentwickler von der Smalltalk-Programmiersprache und hat damals halt das missverstandenste
Konzept in der Programmierung.
sie sprachlich geprägt, weil er halt bei Smalltalk von Object Orientation gesprochen
hat, was dann von allen komplett missverstanden wurde, was das eigentlich bedeutet
und dann was ganz anderes umgesetzt haben.
Aber das war halt auch sehr bahnbrechend.
Ich hatte das hier auch schon mal erwähnt, als wir oder als ich zumindest über
Elixir gesprochen habe und warum ich der Meinung bin, dass das sozusagen...
Nach wie vor die coolste und geilste und am meisten in die Zukunft gerichtete
Programmiersprache ist von allen und der Rest kann sich mal gehackt legen.
Alan Kay war auch dann später bei Apple also der hat da von,
84 oder so sogar bis 97 war er da noch so Apple Fellow und hat da weiter geforscht
der gehörte zu dieser Advanced Technology Group die dann leider,
von Steve Jobs aufgelöst wurde als er dann wieder zurück in die Firma kam weil
sie ja, erstmal andere Prioritäten hatten.
Die mussten erstmal richtig Geld sparen.
Erstmal überleben und so, genau. Aber, ähm, das ist auch, sagen wir mal, eine Szene und diese,
es gibt so diese Sichtweise mit,
ja, Xerox hat das ja alles erfunden und Apple hat es ja nur geklaut und,
Gates hat natürlich auch mal einen ähnlichen Kommentar gebracht,
so nach dem Motto, ja, wir haben das ja beide nur geklaut, aber als ich da eingebrochen
bin, habe ich gesehen, dass schon vorher jemand da war.
sie haben sich verschiedene Ideen, nämlich das mit diesen Windows und mit der
Maus und so weiter schon dort abgeguckt, aber natürlich macOS oder auch vorher
das Lisa-Betriebssystem,
Ist ja viel, viel, viel weitergegangen. Also diese ganze Direct Manipulation und so weiter.
Du hattest bei diesem Xerox-Teil, bei dem Star, da hattest du sozusagen für
die ganzen Befehle hattest du noch eigene Tasten auf der Tastatur.
So kopieren, Propartie und so weiter.
Also dass das alles wirklich mit der Maus gemacht wurde, das war dann tatsächlich
die Innovation, die Apple da mit reingetragen hat.
Es ist immer ein bisschen müßig zu sagen, mit wer hat es erfunden.
Ich meine, abgesehen davon,
dass es eh alles in der Schweiz erfunden wurde, Offenbar ist diese ganze Welt
ein einziges Copy-Paste und ist immer sehr schwierig zu sagen,
mit ja hier, da ist eine originäre Idee aus dem Nichts geboren worden,
die keinerlei Vorlage hatte. Das ist ja Quatsch.
Das gibt es ja nicht so.
Und feiern kann man natürlich auch immer nur das, wo es dann auch wirklich mal
ordentlich umgesetzt wurde, wo man sieht, okay, we've got it working und jetzt
tut es auch mal wirklich was und das ist nicht nur so irgendein Konzept.
Ähnlich war das ja auch mit Multitouch. Es gab, bevor das iPhone rauskam,
so ein Jahr vorher oder so ein Video rum,
wo so eine Forschergruppe so diese Multitouch-Ideen alle schon mal irgendwie demonstriert hat.
Und vielleicht nicht ein Jahr, vielleicht waren es auch zwei,
aber es war so nicht sehr viel weit vorher so ging das so rum.
Und Apple hat es dann halt erstmalig mit dem iPhone wirklich auch umgesetzt.
Und dann war es eben auch wirklich mal als Produkt zu kaufen.
Ja, aber da muss man aber Fairness halber sagen, wenn du erstmal die Technologie
Multitouch hast, dann sind viele der Gesten, die du damit auslösen kannst, ja offensichtlich.
Ja, aber das Offensichtliche ist ja immer auch erst offensichtlich, wenn es da ist.
Naja, klar. Aber ich glaube, dass der ...
Der eigentliche Sprung ist, ein Eingabegerät zu haben, das Multitouch kann.
Nicht, was ich dann damit mache.
Ja, das würde ich so nicht sagen.
Aber gut.
Also nur weil du es kannst, heißt du noch lange nicht, dass du so Pinch to Zoom
und diese ganzen Sachen.
Also jetzt kommt uns das selbstverständlich vor, weil wir es nie anders erlebt haben.
Da gibt es ein gutes Beispiel von Microsoft. Da gab es auch mal diesen komischen
Tisch, den die da gebaut haben.
Surface.
Surface. Und was die da meiner Meinung nach, das konnte man im ersten Demo sehen,
falsch gemacht haben, war, dass das Pinch-to-Zoom auch gleichzeitig den Winkel
der beiden Finger mitgenommen hat.
Und die haben bei der Demo Probleme gehabt, alles irgendwie halbwegs gerade
zu halten, weil alles krumm und schief wurde beim Zoomen.
Also, Roddy, ich würde dir da auch widersprechen, dass das dann alles ganz offensichtlich ist.
Was ich immer wieder predige, was das erste iPhone schon nahezu perfekt umgesetzt
hat und wo dann Android gefühlt noch Jahre später mit gestrauchelt hat,
ist halt wirklich diese Fluptizität bei Multitouch, dass du eben,
wenn du jetzt die Finger auseinanderziehst,
keinerlei Latenz wahrnimmst zu dem, was du unten drunter manipulierst.
Dass es eben nicht ruckelt.
Dass auch wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine Sache rauf und runter mit dem Finger
schiebst oder anschubst.
Das ist aber kein Design-Ding.
Ja, aber dieses Zusammenspiel von Technologie, die schnell genug ist,
dass es jemand wichtig ist, dass dieses Matching hergestellt wird.
Nee, aber das ist ja kein Design-Ding, sondern das Problem ist,
dass Android auf einer ganz anderen technischen Basis gestartet ist.
Also gerne mal mit schlechteren Prozessoren und dann mit einem Java als Unterbau.
Und bekanntermaßen immer sehr, sehr viel RAM verbraucht, sodass du viel schneller
in diesen Moment kommst, wo irgendwie Java seine Garbage Collection los schicken
muss und dann ist mit Fluid und Scrollen und so weiter halt vorbei.
Du brauchst halt auch einen Product Manager, der einfach mal ins Team rein hämmert.
So, der Mauszeiger muss sich flüssig bedienen.
Ja, ja, das ist richtig.
So, was hatten wir auch in der letzten Sendung. Egal was passiert,
der Mauszeiger darf niemals ruckeln, sonst was. Der muss immer Priority 100 haben.
Genauso muss das bei der iPhone-Entwicklung gewesen sein, was immer passiert.
Die Oberfläche muss instantan auf alle Touch-Geschichten reagieren.
Ansonsten nehmen die Leute es nicht als organisch und gottgegeben an.
Ah, das ist jetzt die neue Art sowas zu bedienen hier. Wenn es geruckelt hätte,
hätte es nicht so einen Erfolg gehabt.
Aber da muss man der Fairness halber sagen, das allererste iPhone hat so seine Ruckler gehabt.
Also das ist nicht so, als wäre das jetzt so perfekt gewesen, wie du das jetzt.
Das Internet war scheiße langsam, aber die eigentliche GUI war schnell.
Ich kann das nicht, ich erinnere es nicht, dass es irgendwann danach ein iPhone
gibt, wo ich dachte so, oh, das ist ja irre flüssiger jetzt plötzlich, als es vorher war.
Sowas wie Fotos beispielsweise, das war immer, oder Maps, das war instantan.
Es hat gedauert, bis es nachgeladen hat dann immer, bis irgendwo Informationen da waren.
Aber dieses Platzhalter schon mal richtig mit skalieren und dann wird die höhere
Auflösung nachgeladen und ähnliches.
Das ist ja auch alles Teil dieses Dogmas, nichts darf ruckeln.
Also was sicherlich eine geniale Erfindung war.
das wird, glaube ich, auch von den meisten Leuten zu wenig gewürdigt,
ist beim Scrollen am Ende der Bounce-Effekt.
Ja, haben wir auch schon ein paar Mal.
Besonders, wenn du mit dem Finger weiterziehst. Und ich meine,
scheinbar hatte sich das Apple patentieren lassen,
weil Google musste ja dann in Android so merkwürdige Dinge nachrüsten,
die das wenigstens so halbwegs so aussehen lassen, als wäre das was mit so Schatten,
die dann so runterkommen und so.
Also das fand ich, das ist aber auch sowas, was man am Anfang einem nicht auffällt,
was für ein geiler Effekt das eigentlich ist.
Und die sehr spezielle Zeigerbeschleunigung der Trackpads, wir sprachen in letzter
Sendung davon, wir werden heute nochmal darüber sprechen.
Das sind alles solche Geschichten, die merkst du erst, wie geil sie sind,
wenn du sie woanders plötzlich nicht hast und dann merkst du,
okay, das ist doch kaputt hier.
Warum ist das hier gerade so anders?
Also immer so locker flockig sagen, so ja, dann hat sich das da alles so ganz
automagisch draus ergeben.
Multi-Touch war ja dann irgendwie war ja dann sofort auserzählt.
Ja, es ist erstaunlich, dass sie es in der ersten Version so auf den Punkt gesetzt haben.
Obwohl es wohl ein sehr schmerzhafter Prozess war, das überhaupt so aus dem,
Nichts zusammenzuklöppeln hinzukriegen.
Aber da ist auch so ein bisschen der Unterschied zwischen eine geniale Idee
haben oder sagen wir mal eine offensichtliche Idee haben und zu verstehen,
wie wichtig diese Idee im Zusammenspiel ist, damit, dass es ein rundes Paket ergibt.
Attention to detail, so wichtig.
Ideen sind billig, aber das dann auch richtig zu machen?
Genau und deswegen ist Steve Jobs so eine coole Sau gewesen und ja.
Ja, dem war sowas wichtig. Und ich glaube, er war ein ziemlicher Arsch als Chef,
aber der hat halt solche Dinge nicht durch die Tür gehen lassen,
wenn er es bei ihm im Gehirn nicht Klick gemacht hat, so muss es sich jetzt anfühlen.
Ich hatte das ja vor Jahren schon mal erzählt, wie ich bei Apple gearbeitet habe, das halbe Jahr.
Und da kam ab und zu mal der Spruch, boah, wie sieht denn das aus, wenn Steve das sieht.
Das war wirklich ein Standardspruch, wenn Steve das sieht.
Und da hast du so einen vorauseilenden Gehorsam, dass wirklich auch auf die
kleinsten Dinge geachtet werden, damit Steve das nicht sieht.
Wenn Steve das auffällt, dann ist schon zu spät, dann ist schon viel schief
gegangen irgendwie. Die hatten wirklich alle Angst.
Ja, aber schau, wo wir jetzt heute gelandet sind. Also ich baue mal was in den
Chat rein hier. Wir hatten es ja auch letzte Sendung. So, was ist aus diesem?
Ja, ja, die Eckenradien. Ich will nicht nochmal drüber reden.
Ja, es ist, das ist, nee, jetzt pass mal auf, was jetzt hier in den Chat landet.
Das ist von vor drei Tagen ein Screenshot, den ich gemacht habe,
aus dem ICE. Ich werde noch darüber berichten.
Oh.
So, ungesichertes Netzwerk.
Blablabla, blablabla. das letzte Wort Netzwerk ist zur Hälfte durchgeschnitten,
weil die Textbox nicht groß genug ist.
Weil die Textbox nicht, du hast ja wirklich einen...
Sofort den Tester feuern.
MacOS Tahoe, das ist nicht so, dass da nicht genug Platz gewesen wäre jetzt in dieser Infobox.
Da ist also gefühlt die Hälfte nach unten Whitespace.
So nicht. So geht's echt nicht.
Kann man nicht, kann man nicht schön reden.
Da kann ich auch gleich Linux nehmen.
Wir kommen noch dazu.
Der muss jetzt nicht sein.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Na gut.
Naja, mit dem Angriff der nächsten Mac OS Version wird das alles wieder in Ordnung kommen.
Ja, das hoffe ich doch schwer.
Naja, wir werden uns auskotzen, wenn nicht, oder?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Genau, wo wir schon bei Apple sind, dann hast du ja noch
gesagt, Jill Amelio hat den iMac erfunden.
Naja, ganz so habe ich es nicht gesagt, aber er hat zumindest ein Projekt angestoßen.
Und was ich dazu gesagt habe, das hat er in seinem Buch behauptet,
weil ich glaube, ich hatte das letzte Mal nicht gesagt, dass ich das Buch von ihm mal gelesen hatte.
Will ich jetzt nicht empfehlen, weil so doll ist es nicht, aber damals war es spannend, halbwegs.
Am Ende auch egal irgendwo, aber dem war wohl so, dass er zumindest in seiner
kurzen Amtszeit schon so ein Projekt gestartet hat, aber damit ist ja noch nicht
klar, dass das Ding nur USB hat und ein durchsichtigeres Plastik.
Das sind natürlich so die ganzen Aspekte, die dann Jobs mit durchgebracht hat,
weil das hätte sich damals halt keiner getraut.
Und dass sie das Kettenlaufwerk weggelassen haben.
Wie gesagt, in der Revision 1 der Platine war da sogar noch Lötpunkte für den
Stecker, für den Anschluss.
Wann kam der raus? 98? 99?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau, aber ich weiß, das war diese schwierige Zeit,
wo plötzlich alles Plastik durchsichtig sein musste.
Und ich fand das echt nicht schön.
98.
Also der iMac selber war schön, aber dieses ganze durchsichtige Plastik,
das hätten wir uns mal echt alle knemmen können.
Ich fand das nicht so schlecht.
Ich fand das auch nicht so schlecht.
Mit diesen leichten Milchglaseffekten auch so. Ich fand das auch schon ganz
schlecht. Dieser erste iMac finde ich, das sieht mir doch geil aus.
Nein, du verstehst mich falsch. Der iMac sah gut aus.
Aber?
Dass alle das dann nachmachen mussten.
Die anderen Nachmittler, die mit dem billigen, durchsichtigen Plastik haben, das war wirklich...
Ja, wo dann so jeder USB-Hub irgendwie durchsichtig sein musste.
Aber naja, so ist das halt nun mal mit dem Style.
Ich meine, das haben wir ja jetzt ja auch gehabt mit Liquid Glass.
Was wurde darauf rumgemeckert?
Aber irgendwie alle haben ja sofort angefangen, ihre User-Interfaces entsprechend,
umzubauen und jetzt ist das halt einfach der Trend, den du überall siehst.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, so ein, wenn du in der Apple-Weltentwickler bist,
dann ist das so ein Reflex.
Also Apple gibt die Richtung vor und dann ziehst du halt nach.
Nee, auch die anderen, die nicht auf Apple sind, bauen das dann sozusagen nach. Webseiten.
Obwohl, ich habe so das Gefühl, dass so diese Transparenz immer so in Wellen
kommt. Hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon. Erst Aqua, dann kam was war das?
Windows 7? War das 7?
War das 8? Keine Ahnung. Also irgendwie gab es da so ein Windows,
was fürchterlich durchsichtig war und alle so mäh.
Und dann hat Apple wieder ausgebaut, hat es Windows wieder ausgebaut, dann weiß ich nicht.
Und jetzt haben sie es wieder eingebaut, wahrscheinlich kommt Windows als nächstes
wieder mit. Durchsichtig um die Ecke.
Ja, es ist Mode. Es ist mit wie sind die Jeans geschnitten gerade.
Oh, durchsichtig trägt man dieses Jahr so.
Translucent.
Ja, Computerkauf, also.
Ganz schlechtes Thema momentan.
Oder? Ja, ist wirklich schwierig Also ich hatte ja mir eigentlich vorgenommen,
dieses Jahr einen Upgrade zu machen von meinem Mac Mini, den ich noch benutze.
Einfach, weil ich den gerne frei hätte für andere Experimente.
Ich hätte gerne mal so einen Computer mal über.
Und da dachte ich mir so ein Mac Mini, fünf Jahre alt.
Ist doch eigentlich genau die richtige Maschine, wenn man mal irgendwo einen Computer braucht.
so für irgendwelche Installationen oder temporären Einsatz, den kann man sich
wirklich mal ins Regal legen oder so nebenbei noch betreiben und wenn man dann halt wirklich mal,
Computerbedarf hat, dann kann man sagen, so ja kein Problem,
ich hab hier noch einen Mac Mini, der ist frei, aber dann muss ich den halt
durch irgendwas ersetzen und bin halt schwer davon ausgegangen,
dass jetzt irgendwie Mac Mini M5, Mac Studio,
M5 Pro Max, hast du nicht gesehen,
kommt und irgendwie, die, ich bitte nicht, stattdessen gibt es die ganzen,
gar nicht mehr, gehen jetzt hier alle weg.
Den Mac Mini gibt es nicht mehr zum Einsteigspreis, mit dem er so gehypt wurde.
Es gibt die ganzen großen Ausbaustufen mit 512 Gigabyte RAM für den Mac Studio.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ist die Grenze gerade?
Nicht, dass ich mir jetzt so einen kaufen wollte.
Aber,
950 Euro ist momentan der Basispreis.
Genau, und wo ist das Ding eingestiegen? Bei 700?
Nee, bei 600. 700?
Nee, 600 nicht, oder?
In Deutschland wahrscheinlich mit Umsatzsteuer dann 700.
Also ich weiß, dass ich so ein Basisding dann einfach gekauft habe.
Und habe es auch nicht bereut.
Achso, und was machst du damit? Liegt der rum?
Normadies und das. Er liegt eigentlich rum, weil alle anderen Mac Minis,
die ich hatte, jetzt so alt sind, dass man halt auch mit Biegen und Brechen
kein aktuelles Betriebssystem mehr drauf hat.
Sondern das ist halt einfach der Rechner, der aktuell genug ist,
dass man da auch mal eine Beta-Version draufschmeißen kann oder so.
Naja, liegt halt rockenhellig.
Okay, verstehe. Also du hast im Prinzip so ein Mac Mini, wie ich ihn nicht habe.
Ja.
Genau. Okay. Und gerne hätte. Ja, also ab 949 und kann man ihn dann aufrüsten.
Wenn man hier den Pro-Chip macht, dann kannst du da maximal wie viel RAM reinstecken?
48 GB. Ich weiß nicht, ob das auch vorher das Maximum war. Ich vermute mal ja.
weil mehr kann ich mir nicht vorstellen aber beim Mac Studio ging das ja bis 512,
allerdings auch nur wenn man jetzt den großen Ultra Tralala nimmt mit dem Nicht-Ultra-Chip
wird jetzt hier maximal 96 angeboten und mit dem,
M3 Ultra,
im Vollausbau auch nur 96 also mehr als 96 geht derzeit gar nicht das ist ja crazy.
Ach den gibt es aber auch nur ach M4 Max oder.
M3 Ultra M3 Ultra genau.
Ja ok dass es den M4 nicht als Ultra.
Gab das war mir ja bekannt mich hätte eh nur der M4 interessiert und das Maximum
ist auch hier 96 Gigabyte interessant,
Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, warum?
Also, kriegen sie nichts?
Oder ist es ihnen, ich meine, bei den Margen, die sie auf Speicher genommen
haben, gerade für diese Erweiterung.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Dass das Geld das Problem ist.
Kleine Sache noch, wenn du wirklich den Speichervollausbau hast,
dann wollen sie dich von einem M4 Max auf einen M3 Ultra rumswitchen.
Ja.
Achso, genau. Christian M4 Max gibt es nur mit 64. Okay, verstehe. Ja, ja, genau.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ja, irre, ne?
Tja, man weiß es halt nicht so genau. Also bisher war ja immer die These,
dass Apple so lange Verträge hat mit den Zulieferern, dass die problemlos jetzt
halt erstmal diese Speicherkrise ausgelöst durch die ganzen KI-Rechenzentren abfedern können.
Aber jetzt ging es doch relativ zackig, finde ich, mit der Reaktion.
Ja, also das kann nur was mit Verfügbarkeit zu tun haben eigentlich.
Der Preis, glaube ich, ist es nicht.
Andererseits, also man weiß ja nicht, wie ihre Verträge dann aussehen.
Kann durchaus sein, dass sie jetzt nicht für, dass ihre Garantien irgendwann
enden und sie möchten lieber mehr Computer verkaufen mit dem RAM, den sie kriegen.
Aber ich meine, wie viele Rechner verkaufen die mit 512 Gigabyte RAM?
Wahrscheinlich wegen des LLM-Wahnsinns war da die Nachfrage auch nicht schlecht.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du jetzt, wenn du dir so ein Mac Studio gekauft hast mit
mehr als 128 oder ab 128 Gigabyte RAM, gehen wahrscheinlich die Preise auf dem
Schwarzmarkt durch die Decke.
Manche investieren in Gold, manche investieren in Mac Studios.
Einer meiner oberen Chefs kam irgendwie vor ein paar Wochen auf mich zu und
meinte so, ja, also ich habe ja gesehen dieser Mac Studio mit 512 Gig,
der kostet ja gar nicht so viel.
Vielleicht sollten wir uns einfach mal einen hinstellen, dann können wir diese
ganzen Modelle hier lokal abfeiern.
Ja, und?
Na, hat er nicht gemacht.
Hätte er mal machen sollen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht. Also vielleicht war da auch die Begeisterung größer
als der Need, aber er fand das zumindest sehr faszinierend, dass Apple zu den,
wie er fand, niedrigen Preisen ...
Chad sagt, mit dem Mac Mini, mit M4 Pro hätte man 64 Gigabyte haben können vorher.
Und jetzt ist halt bei 48 Schluss. Der 512er ist schon länger aus dem Programm,
das stimmt, das war das Erste, was sie gekillt haben, aber mittlerweile,
killen sie halt jetzt auch die ganzen anderen Optionen und das ist natürlich
jetzt schon wirklich schavierig.
Was aber interessant ist, der Mac Mini, den gibt es halt nicht mehr in der Basisvariante
mit den nur 8 GB speichern.
Genau, das ist die billige Option, die Sie jetzt gekillt haben,
deswegen geht es jetzt bei 960 los.
Die, die ich gezogen hatte, ob das jetzt sinnvoll ist oder nicht,
das steht auf einem anderen Blatt, aber ich habe es halt gemacht.
Ja, also alles gar nicht so einfach.
Und ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ich machen soll, um ehrlich zu sein.
Also ich habe die Hoffnung,
dass sie jetzt doch noch irgendwas ankündigen und dass das Ganze jetzt nur ist,
damit sie voll loslegen können, wenn sie die nächste Generation auf M5-Basis rausbringen.
Aber richtig sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Also ich habe ja auch schon Mac Minis bei Rebuy gekauft,
Aber irgendwie waren die Preise da auch nicht immer so dass man jetzt denkt,
okay das ist ja voll der Stil Aber du kannst da natürlich trotzdem mal gucken Ja.
Ich will aber keine gebrauchten Computer kaufen Ja.
Aber bei einem Mac Mini ist das glaube ich nicht so wild,
Also ich würde keinen Laptop-Gebrauch kaufen, außer ich kenne die Leute oder so.
Ich wollte ja eigentlich nicht, ja, keine Ahnung, du meinst,
man kriegt ein 64 GB Mini, der ist ja trotzdem zu teuer.
Das kann ich dir so nicht sagen, also zumindest gibt es die Filteroptionen hier nicht.
Die haben doch jetzt auch bestimmt ihre Preise angepasst.
Ja, ja, wenn ich mir die Preise angucke, dann sind die jetzt auch nicht so geil,
aber es ist zumindest eine Idee, mal nachzugucken, ob da was ist, was einen anlacht.
Also wenn du jetzt wirklich quasi vor, ich brauche jetzt einen neuen Mac,
schon am Schreibtisch dich festhalten musst, weil du so zitterst.
Ja, so ist es jetzt auch nicht. Aber ich dachte einfach so nach fünf Jahren.
Kann man mal.
Ich kaufe ja nun nicht so oft neue Computer, weil ich ja auch immer so picky
bin. und ich hatte mich jetzt so mental eigentlich voll darauf eingefahren,
dass jetzt diese M5, so von M1 auf M5 gehen.
Das merkt man dann schon.
Da merkt man was, da ist die Investition was wert und dann kaufe ich auch gerne
so ein bisschen im rechts unten Bereich, weil,
sollte man diese Geräte dann tatsächlich mal verkaufen, was ich jetzt mit dem
alten Mac Mini jetzt nicht vorhabe,
dann kriegt man halt auch noch ordentlich was dafür. Weiß ja, wie es ist.
Ja, also jetzt neu müsste man hier auch schon in der Konfiguration,
wie ich mir das vorstelle, na, äh,
Ach Gott, das ist viel zu teuer.
Ja, also ich glaube, wenn man nicht wirklich unbedingt was braucht,
weißt du, der alte Rechner ist einem aus dem Auto geklaut worden,
dann würde ich jetzt keinen Rechner kaufen.
Nee, es ist zu teuer einfach. Es ist mir zu teuer.
Es gäbe ja noch einen anderen Weg.
Welchen denn? PC kaufen oder was?
Also.
Die sind aber auch nicht billig momentan.
Sind auch nicht billig, nee. Ihr erinnert euch an die letzte Sendung,
da hatten wir ja 50 Jahre Apple.
Ja.
Und da sind wir auch so magische Keynote-Momente, haben wir da so ein bisschen angesprochen.
Und wir machen jetzt mal ein Reenactment einer solchen Keynote und sagt mir,
welche das ist. Ich greife jetzt hier mal in meinen Rucksack.
Wie die Hörer jetzt deutlich sehen können.
Genau, darum beschreibe ich auch, was ich tue. Ich hole etwas raus.
So, das sind erstmal komische Papiere.
Langsam wird das zum Hörspiel hier.
Ich weiß es, ich weiß es.
So, was habe ich jetzt hier rausgeholt?
Einen braunen Versandumschlag. Allerdings nicht so einer mit so einer Kordel dran.
Nicht mit einer Kordel dran, genau. Die fehlt hier. Die wollte ich jetzt,
da es ja ein Audio-Podcast ist.
Also so DIN A4 beziehungsweise ein Umschlag, wo DIN A4 reinpasst.
Okay, also wissen jetzt sowieso alle, was jetzt kommt. Was ist der Twist?
So, da drin ist also der tollste Computer.
Der je hergestellt wurde. Ein MacBook Air Keilform.
Ein MacBook Air Keilform.
Also ein sumerisches MacBook.
Ein M1.
Ja, was ich hier stehen habe.
Das, was du hier stehen hast. So, und jetzt klappe ich mal das Display auf.
Das macht Lärm.
Das macht etwas Lärm. Und was haben wir hier drauf?
Lunix.
Ein generisches Linux. auf Apple Silicon.
Okay, und?
Das ist neu.
Wie neu ist das jetzt? Also was ist daran jetzt neu?
Naja, also, wenn wir uns mal erinnern, meine ganzen bisherigen Linux-Experimente
waren ja alle ganz erfreulich, aber ich habe mich ja schon immer doch mit großen
Schmerzen daran abgearbeitet,
so die Tastatur ist irgendwie scheiße und das Dreckbett ist scheiße und dieses und jenes.
Und hier hat man einfach mal geile Hardware, die total oversized ist,
wo die 8 GB überhaupt keine Limitierung darstellen.
Das ist also jetzt hier 8 GB, 256er Platte und ein sogenanntes Aschari Linux drauf.
Aschari oder Asahi?
Das japanische für Sondenaufgang.
Asahi war glaube ich indisch, aber ist egal.
Mal gucken, also die Alvis Neumülde hat gesagt, es sei japanisch.
Morgensonne oder aufgehende Sonne. Asahi.
Genau, und das ist also so eine Truppe, ein Projekt von Verrückten,
die schon seit 2022 haben sie ihre erste Release gemacht.
Genau, mach mal da den Screenshot mal aus.
Kann man da mal drauf gucken.
Die also Apple Silicon Hardware reverse engineeren und unter Linux lauffähig machen.
Mit eben dem Ziel, so diese ganzen Rechner, die jetzt so langsam eben insbesondere
halt M1 und M2, die jetzt so langsam aus dem noch mit aktuellen Betriebssystemen
fluffig laufend rausfallen.
Da kann man doch im Sinne der Nachhaltigkeit mal was Vernünftiges mitmachen
und noch ein Linux draufgeben.
Du kannst ja mal oben auf Blog gehen. Das ist wirklich schön zu lesen.
Oben mal auf Blog auf der Seite.
So und da kann man mal gucken, wie die dann also so einzelne Bausteine dann
versuchen halt in den Griff zu kriegen. Nehmen wir ruhig das oberste hier, Linux 7.
Da haben sie dann beispielsweise einen schönen Abschnitt, wo sie mal darstellen,
wie der Helligkeit, etwas weiter unten, how do you over-engineer a light sensor, genau.
Wo sie mal ein bisschen transparent machen, wie funktioniert eigentlich dieser
Umgebungslichtsensor in so einem MacBook drin.
Das ist nämlich nicht einfach nur, es ist helle oder es ist dunkel,
sondern es wird gleichzeitig gemessen, kommt jetzt gerade eigentlich eher rotes
Licht oder habe ich so eine ganz kalte Neonröhre, damit dieses True Tone auch
entsprechend gegengesteuert werden kann.
Dann haben sie herausgefunden, dass natürlich das Display von dem MacBook selber
auch strahlt. Das wird auch rausgerechnet von diesem Sensor.
Und dass du also ganz viele Parameter auf diesem Chip hast, die,
wenn man das Ganze nachbauen möchte unter Linux, entsprechend halt auch irgendwie gegensteuern muss.
Und so machen sie das halt Komponente für Komponente für Komponente.
und wenn du nochmal auf die Eingangsseite gehst, genau, also das Energiemanagement,
wie sie das also Stückchen für Stückchen nachbauen, was ja auch wirklich sehr
diffizil ist bei den Apple-Geräten.
Was meinst du jetzt mit Eingangsseite von dem Blog oder was?
Ja, genau. Nee, wieder auf die Hauptseite von Masai. So, und jetzt ein bisschen
runterscrollen. Read the Announcement. Ein bisschen hoch.
Hoch, hoch, hoch. Hoch da, genau.
Und da jetzt wiederum nach unten, da sieht man, wie weit sie schon gekommen sind.
Also darunter liegt ein Fedora Linux 44 mit einem KDE Plasma Desktop.
Scroll nochmal ganz nach unten auf die Seite.
Ganz nach unten auf der Seite. So, und da sieht man jetzt, was sie alles supporten
für welche Apple-Geräte.
Das heißt also, jetzt hier bei dem MacBook Air haben sie drin die M1 und die
M2 und sie machen das Display.
Sie haben Keyboard mit Backlight, was beispielsweise ja das neue Neo noch nichtmals hat.
Und das kannst du schön steuern hier über das Linux.
Das Trackpad natürlich, den Kopfhörer, die Speaker, Mikrofon,
Kamera, MagSafe, USB-C, WiFi, Bluetooth. So, was sie noch nicht haben, ist Touch-ID.
Da sind sie aber wohl relativ weit, meinen sie.
Thunderbolt habe ich jetzt noch nicht reingelesen, wie das aussieht.
USB-C-Display meinten sie, seien sie auch relativ weit.
So, und dann kannst du halt noch gucken, okay, bei MacBook Pro hast du dann
auch die ganzen Pro-Chips, wenn du davon irgendwo einen rumzustehen hast.
Und auch dein alter Mac Mini, den du nicht verkaufen willst,
taucht hier auf und da könntest du das also mal drauf bringen.
Ja, aber warum sollte ich das tun?
Damit du mal ein geiles Betriebssystem...
Ich hab da ein geiles Betriebssystem drauf.
Naja, ich hab jetzt, das war jetzt für mich insofern auch nochmal,
also erstmal, das hab ich wieder von Max rübergeworfen bekommen, hier Mobile Max,
der hat das irgendwo mal gepostet, dass er das bei sich ausprobiert hat und
dann bin ich schwach geworden und hab's dann bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen mir gebraucht,
hier geholt für 350 Euro.
Das Gerät jetzt.
Dieses Gerät hier. Das ist die Hälfte von dem, was ein Neo kostet. Die Hälfte.
Und habe das ausprobiert und raufgebracht. Und der Installationsprozess war
da schon noch so ein bisschen fruckelig.
Das war aber glaube ich drei oder vier Tage, bevor sie den in der neuen Version
rausgebracht haben. Das müsste ich dann jetzt auch nochmal schauen.
Und da ist jetzt ein KDE drauf. Und bei meinen bisherigen Tests hatte ich eher
so den Eindruck, so KDE ist schon alles sehr sperrig, bin jetzt aber nach ein
paar Tagen, bin ich da etwas aufgeschlossener,
weil das scheint mir insgesamt ein Desktop zu sein, wo viel,
so Liebe in Detail-Lösungen reinfließt. Mal ein Beispiel. Ich habe halt im ICE gesessen.
So, WLAN, Capture Portal.
Kennen wir alle. So, es ist mir in den zwei Stunden von Berlin nach Göttingen
nicht gelungen, mein Tahoe MacBook Pro in das WiFi des Zuges reinzukriegen.
So, weil er halt einfach diese Capture-Seite nicht startet.
So, und ich kenne die ganzen Tricks mit neverssl.com, damit er eine HTTP-Verbindung
aufbaut und neu starten und so. Es funktioniert einfach nicht.
Kein Problem auf dem iPhone. Das ist ein klassischer Fall.
Und das habe ich ständig mit meinem Laptop. Ich komme wirklich in diese Capture-WLANs
echt richtig schwer rein.
Selbe Situation, dann hier mit dem KDE ausprobiert. Da kriegst du dann dieses WLAN angezeigt.
Und schon sobald du auf Verbinden gehst, sagt er dir im Verbinden,
in der Verbinden-Gui, Achtung, dieses WLAN braucht einen Capture,
soll ich das mal für dich öffnen?
Ja, danke, gut, dass du es erkannt hast, öffnen wir das doch mal.
Und dann drückst du auf den Öffnen-Button, der da genau an der Stelle ist,
wo man ihn haben möchte bei dem WLAN-Dialog und dann öffnet er das Capture und
man kann sich in den Zug einloggen. So, und dann steht die Verbindung.
Wieso brauchst du einen Capture, um ins Wi-Fi zu kommen?
Vom IC. Dieses IC... Das ist doch kein Capture.
Du musst doch nicht beweisen.
Dass es ein Human ist. Du musst, nein, Capture, du musst, wie heißen diese Seiten,
wo du sagen musst, ja, ich akzeptiere die Nutzungsbedingungen.
Ja, ja, diese Pop-Up-Seite.
Genau. Okay, gut.
Nee, stimmt, die heißen nicht Capture, also eh nicht. Wie heißen die?
Captive Portals.
Captive Portals, das ist der Begriff, genau.
Genau, Captive Portals, ja.
So, und dann druckst du da drauf und dann bist du im WLAN. So, und dann...
Wenn du mit dem WLAN verbunden bist und dann dir die bestehende Verbindung anzeigst,
dann schiebt sich plötzlich dieser WLAN-Dialog auf und du bekommst gleich einen
schönen Graphen mit dem gemessenen Durchsatz.
So Input, Output und sowas.
Und du denkst so, oh wie schön, ich muss nicht ToolX-Subsan dafür installieren
und es sieht auch noch nett aus und funktioniert.
Ich bin jetzt ja gar nicht im WLAN, aber das ist jetzt also hier die Meta-Ebene
und du schießt sie auf und dann wählt also hier drei gleich in der GUI der Graph,
wo du sehen kannst, wie viel Input und wie viel Output hast du.
Und egal in welcher Ecke man so guckt beim KDE, man hat ständig so Detaillösungen,
wo man so denkt, da haben Leute nachgedacht und sich irgendwie Gedanken gemacht,
was sich bei Apple halt irgendwie seit Jahren einfordert, sodass ich jetzt sage, hm.
Das gucke ich mir jetzt nochmal ein bisschen länger an mit diesem KDE.
Also ich würde noch keine finale Kaufempfehlung geben, aber du kriegst halt
genau dieses Modell, 8 GB, 256 Festplatte.
M1 Apple Silicon kriegst du auf Kleinanzeigen für 350 bis 370 Euro.
Das ist so der Preisrange.
Und anders als du, wo du gesagt hast, ich würde mir jetzt kein gebrauchtes Laptop holen.
Ich habe jetzt ja, das ist jetzt mein viertes in kurzer Zeit,
keinen einzigen Reinfall gehabt bisher.
Klar, der Akku ist jetzt nur auf 80 Prozent Lebensdauer, was ich aber jetzt
für ein sechs Jahre altes Gerät jetzt auch noch echt irgendwie okayisch finde.
Und es ist mal einfach so die fucking Hälfte des Preises,
was ich für Neo auch nur bezahlen würde, geschweige denn jetzt ein aktuelles
Air kostet irgendwie 1200 Euro und auch im Gesichtspunkt so Nachhaltigkeit und
alten Geräten noch irgendwie eine sinnvolle Verwendung zuführen,
wenn sich das bei mir im Alltag weiter so bewährt, glaube ich ist das der Startschuss
für eine Bewegung die ich dann starten würde und die hat natürlich schon ein
klares Hashtag Das sagt sich ja von selbst.
Das ist natürlich dann Linux on Air.
Was?
Ja, weil du löst einfach ein Zoo an Linux-Problemen auf einen Schlag.
Du hast ein geiles Display. Hier, KDE, null Probleme mit Scaling.
Okay, also jetzt aus der Linux-Perspektive löst du das Problem,
weil du auf einmal ordentliche Hardware hast.
Du hast einfach mal geile Hardware, die wirklich gut unterstützt wird.
Okay, außer jetzt PCI, aber Aber ja, okay, gut, also das ist in der Tat.
Naja, gut, PCI, ich meine, mal ganz ehrlich, wenn du ein Mac Pro mit einem M-Chip
hast, was für Karten steckst du da rein?
Die Frage konnte mir noch keiner beantworten, was man da für PCI-Karten reinsteckt.
Nicht PCI-Karten, Thunderbolt ist ja PCI.
Achso, Thunderbolt, ja, das wäre natürlich schon ganz schick.
Ja, wobei es jetzt nicht das Wichtigste, also festplatten willst du irgendwie
mit Thunderbolt betreiben, aber geht auch ohne.
Ja, da gibt es ein interessantes Detail.
Also keine Ahnung, es ist vielleicht jetzt für das Linux nicht so wichtig,
aber wenn du eine SSD hast und die ist in einem Thunderbolt-Gehäuse,
dann schaltet macOS dieses, wie heißt denn das, Blöcke freigeben im Hintergrund
an dieses Smart, das heißt irgendwie anders.
Blöcke freigeben, auf der Festplatte freigeben.
Also du hast ja bei einer SSD hast du ja das Problem, dass die SSD selber ja
dieses Wear-Leveling macht.
Also du willst, dass die verschiedenen Zellen, die verwendet werden,
die verschiedenen Speicherblöcke, dass die gleichmäßig beschrieben werden.
Genau. Und deswegen führt die SSD an sich Buch, welcher Blog wie oft beschrieben wurde.
Kann eigentlich ein Blog erst dann als frei markieren, wenn das Betriebssystem
ihm sagt, schreib da mal was ganz anderes drauf und kann das stattdessen auf einen anderen Blog.
Aber es gibt dieses, wie heißt das denn, weiß auch im Chat scheinbar keiner,
es gibt auch dieses Ding, dass das Betriebssystem von sich aus sagen kann,
okay, den Block benutze ich nicht mehr, der ist jetzt wieder frei,
den kannst du in deinem Wear-Leveling-Verwaltung verwenden.
SSDs können das alle,
macOS schaltet es aber nur über Thunderbolt frei und nicht über USB.
Und warum? Warum?
Das ist eine Frage, die du nicht mir stellen darfst. Also ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist so.
Ich habe es ausprobiert, wenn du eine SSD in einem USB-Gehäuse hast,
also so diese typischen M1-Dings da, dann ist die am Anfang sehr schnell und
wenn du die eine Weile verwendest, wird die immer langsamer.
und jetzt wirklich ist wirklich unglaublich habe die gleiche ssd dann in ein
thunderbolt gehäuse gemacht und nach kurzer zeit wurde die wieder richtig schnell
weil dieses blöcke freigeben halt dann funktioniert hat okay ich meinte trim ok.
Also um auf das im 1 noch mal hier mit dem linux zurückzukommen,
Also für Festplatten, das ist der eine Punkt, das andere, was ja nicht supportet
war, was damit zusammenhängt, ist halt Displays über USB-C anschließen,
das ist natürlich durchaus ein Feature.
Wenn man vor allem keinen HDMI-Port hat.
Aber wofür es in der Tat ganz cool sein könnte, da frage ich mich,
ob das irgendwie explizit vorgesehen ist, das ist sozusagen Betrieb im geschlossenen Zustand.
Das kannst du alles konfigurieren, ja, das Screen aus ist, aber Rechner anbleibt.
Ja, dann ist es so ganz cool so als mobiler Server sozusagen,
dass man irgendwie zuklappt, irgendwo ins Regal legen,
Strom ran, Ethernet ran und dann läuft da irgendeine Software drauf,
das ist dann auch eine interessante Alternative zu so einem Mac Mini.
Wobei ich könnte mir auch einfach nochmal so einen alten Mac Mini kaufen,
dann hätte ich halt einen alten Mac Mini als,
habe ich zwei alte Mac Mini, aber kann ich auch nicht genug von haben. Ich gucke mal.
Ja, also woran ich jetzt noch bastle, ist die Mauszeigersteuerung,
weil die ist schon mal sehr, sehr viel besser als auf meinen ganzen Geräten,
die ich da von den Thinkpads hatte, was ja wirklich ein Grauen ist.
Aber diese Übersetzung der Acceleration ist noch nicht perfekt. So, das heißt also.
Das werden sie nie hinbekommen, dass es ordentlich ist.
Tim, es ist Software.
Das ist ja jetzt schon seit 30 Jahren.
Ja, einer muss den Job halt machen. Also mein Setup ist nämlich folgendes.
Ich habe jetzt auf einem und demselben Gerät, habe ich jetzt ein macOS und ich habe einen Linux drauf.
Und du kannst die Messwerte aus dem Trackpad auslesen.
Und ich plane jetzt also eine vollautomatisierte Testumgebung,
in der man einfach in vorgegebenen Geschwindigkeiten einem Pfeil nachfolgt und
so weiter und dann im Hintergrund gemessen wird, okay,
bei welcher Geschwindigkeit der Fingerbewegung wird welcher Akzeleration eigentlich
dann im Hintergrund gestartet.
Und diese Mapping-Übersetzungstabelle, die werde ich dann hier in KDE implementieren.
Ich habe das schon durchgepromptet, es sollte funktionieren.
Ich hatte auch schon den ersten Prototyp, aber das dauert noch ein bisschen, bis es fertig ist.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass du eine Wurst an deinen 3D-Drucker gafferst,
damit du irgendwie definierte Bewegungen auf dem Trackpad machen kannst.
Nee, ich glaube, das braucht es nicht an der Stelle. Du musst letztendlich nur
genug Werte haben, wo klar ist.
Da würde ich aber den Hut abnehmen, den ich nicht aufhabe.
Ja, gucken wir mal. Also ich bin da zuversichtlich, da habe ich jetzt also Ambitionen
der Welt, nochmal eine vernünftige Trackpad-Übersetzung zu schenken.
Ich glaube, das geht, dass man da dran kommt.
So, und dann ist da nicht mehr viel, was mich noch stören würde.
Das fühlt sich leider sehr geil an auf dieser Hardware. Und die ist halt,
die 8 GB sind einfach da unter Linux überhaupt kein Thema.
So, es ist irreflüssig von den ganzen UX-Elementen her, weil halt die Grafikkarte
wirklich gut unterstützt wird.
Das heißt also, was immer du irgendwie hier scrollst und machst und tust und
Transparenz und Schatten, es ist einfach alles instantan und geil und nichts ruckelt.
brauchst du.
Nur noch Apps dafür.
Brauchst du nur noch Apps dafür, genau das ist auch noch so eine Flanke,
du brauchst natürlich ARM-Apps, das heißt mit Intel oder.
Überhaupt erstmal welche naja aber.
Merkst du Tim.
Wir verlieren Ralf.
Der wird das schon noch merken, also ich meine der ganze Installationsspaß mag
ja man kann das natürlich jetzt feiern, dass es überhaupt läuft aber das ist
ja dann erst der Anfang also am Ende willst du ja dann auch,
eine Experience haben und steht dann halt mit Software.
Ja, aber so mein Stack ist schon klar, aber mein Stack ist dann eben nicht so
generisch, dass ich nicht 80 Prozent der Sachen damit machen kann.
Du hast immer noch ein Dual-Boot drauf.
Das heißt, du kommst auch immer noch ins macOS rüber, wenn du unbedingt möchtest.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, ein frisch installiertes macOS, auch auf so einem alten
Gerät, ist auch sehr, sehr fluffig. Also da muss man dann schon auch Äpfel mit Äpfeln vergleichen.
Also das ist jetzt auch ein blöder Spruch an der Stelle, aber du weißt, was ich meine.
Ja, schon, aber sobald du dann irgendwie dann doch ein Chrome auf hast mit irgendwie
30 Tabs oder so, dann wird die Sache dann glaube ich schon wieder ein bisschen wackeliger.
Naja, ein Chrome.
Ich sage euch, das Jahr des Linux als Desktop. Ihr werdet es nicht verhindern
können, die Bewegung, die wir hier starten.
Vorher geht das erste Fusionskraftwerk ans Netz.
Andere versprechen Superbatterien, hier wird geliefert.
Tja, ich beobachte jetzt mal hier so ein Mac Mini. Mal gucken.
Was dabei rauskommt. Ich bin gespannt, welche Preise jetzt hier so geboten werden.
Was hast du bezahlt? 350?
350.
War das jetzt eine Auktion?
Nee, das war direkt kaufen, hier kleine Anzeigen, hier um die Ecke. Ein Kilometer von hier.
Verstehe.
Und ich hätte jetzt in Berlin, klar Berlin ist dann immer etwas speziell,
hätte ich also exakt dieses Modell, hätte ich vier oder fünf abholen können am selben Tag.
Das heißt also, die sind jetzt einfach mal am Markt. Und ich bin verstört.
Guckt euch mal, in was für einem Zustand das ist.
Wie pfleglich manche Leute ihre Laptops behandeln. Da ist also keine Macker.
Kein gar nichts dran. Ja, nehmen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Ja, schon. Das ist mir leider nicht gegeben, muss ich offen gestehen.
Meine Laptops sehen anders aus, trotz Case drumherum.
Ja, und vor allem, ich meine, MacBook Air M1 kann man nicht genug haben.
Also es ist halt einfach der geilste Computer, den Apple, glaube ich, je gemacht hat.
Da stimmt einfach alles an diesem Gerät.
Du kannst das halt auch mit dem M2 machen, aber die sind dann halt schon wieder
so 150 Euro teurer. Und dann ist es schon wieder aus dieser Spaßzone raus.
Ja, der M2 hat ja auch diesen ganzen anderen Unsinn.
Ist nicht mehr mit Wetsch auch, ne?
Ja, ja.
Tja, mal gucken. Alright. Wo waren wir denn stehen geblieben?
Achso, ja vielleicht MacBook Air, wo wir es gerade haben, gibt es eigentlich
gar nichts für zu erzählen.
Aber ich habe jetzt mal mein Apple Care gewinnbringend eingesetzt.
Ich zahle das ja so regelmäßig für meine Computer auf dieser Monatsbasis.
Macht nicht jeder. Ich mache das, weil das sind für mich wichtige,
Produktionsdinger und wenn da wirklich mal was ist und selbst wenn ich es mal
irgendwann verkaufen will, dann kann man sich, also wenn da irgendwas mit ist,
dann kriegst du halt mehr oder weniger kostenlos hin.
Ja und jetzt nach 5 Jahren war jetzt die Batterie dann endlich von 80% auf 79
runter und dann gibt dir Apple die Batterie ja kostenlos.
Bei 79? Okay.
Also wenn du Apple Care hast, sozusagen.
Und die gehen auch bei dem M1R lassen die sich, das macht dann aber Apple selber
oder irgendeine zertifizierte Buden.
Ja, es geht wahrscheinlich auch über zertifizierten Buden, weil du da auch AppleCare
zum Einsatz bringen kannst.
Aber ich habe ja hier den Luxus eines Apple Stores in Berlin,
da bin ich halt hingeladet, habe mir einen Termin geklickt, dann machen die
da so einmal Diagnose auf dem Apparat,
und dann gibst du den da ab,
Das habe ich auch mal geklärt, warum
sie wollen, dass du das Apple Wo Ist ausschaltest auf diesen Devices.
Damit du nicht weißt, wo deren Werkstatt ist, oder?
Das dachte ich auch immer, dass sie irgendwie Angst haben, gefunden zu werden.
Ne, meinte er, also der Grund wäre einfach, dass das der Weg ist,
mit dem du beweist, dass du da auch full Control hast über dieses Gerät.
Ah, okay, macht Sinn.
Nicht, dass man das nicht auch anders machen könnte, aber na gut.
Naja, aber es ist am glaubwürdigsten oder am unauffälligsten.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall habe ich eine neue Batterie bekommen.
Das ging auch relativ schnell und jetzt habe ich eine neue Batterie und jetzt
kann ich das Gerät noch weitere fünf Jahre benutzen.
Und so wie Apple derzeit so seine Laptops ausrichtet, dauert es auch wahrscheinlich
noch mal fünf Jahre, bis ich bereit bin, in ein neues Gerät hier zu investieren.
Es sei denn, Apple Hört ihr zu?
Ihr wisst, was kommen muss? Wir sagen es alle nochmal.
Cellular, Cellular, alle Kinder wollen Cellular. Ich will, dass da 5G reinkommt.
Also Herr Törnus, wenn Sie hier zuhören, sicherlich tun Sie das, dann bitte mal machen.
Speak English, Zen.
Also hier in dem letzten ATP wurde ja, hast du sicher gehört,
spekuliert, was jetzt noch alles für Ultramodelle irgendwie rauskommen, ja, the age of ultra.
Vielleicht rauskommen.
Vielleicht rauskommen und das MacBook Ultra mit Cellular und Touch-Display und
was hatten sie noch, OLED-Display, das waren glaube ich die drei Punkte,
die da jetzt ins Paket...
Das ist so der aktuelle Rumormill, also das ist ja angeblich dieses Jahr oder
je nachdem, wenn sich jetzt alles verzögert, dann vielleicht erst Anfang nächsten
Jahres es ein M6 MacBook geben soll und,
wie immer, man weiß ja nichts Genaues, also, dass man quasi so ein neues Rechts-Unten-Modell
hat, so ein Ultra-Modell vielleicht.
Was dann OLED hat, also was dann teure Komponenten hat, wo es durchaus ja Leute
gibt, die das dann auch haben wollen, was aber jetzt kein Neo ist, sondern die Idee ist,
also vorher hatten sie ja über dieses Neo-All-The-Things und dann quasi,
in die andere Richtung Ultra-All-The-Things gesprochen, also was,
woraus kann man sozusagen noch eine billige Variante machen,
die jetzt im Markt auch einen großen Erfolg haben könnte und woraus könnte man noch,
so eine Ultra-Variante machen.
Ich denke, im Ultra-Bereich ist da sehr viel mehr Potenzial,
weil Neo Laptop, das ist halt wirklich das, was alle haben wollen.
Es verkauft sich, was man so hört, auch recht gut.
Es verkauft sich wohl phänomenal, aber du könntest das jetzt nicht mit jedem
Produkt, mit jeder Produktlinie machen bei Apple.
Man könnte argumentieren, beim iPad gibt es das schon, weil du ja immer so dieses
Billo-Einsteiger-iPad schon immer hattest,
aber für die anderen, also so ein Mac Mini Neo würde jetzt so nicht auf dasselbe Interesse stoßen.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wie letztes Mal schon ausgeführt, war der Mac Mini ja
das Neo der Macs, also die Billigvariante eigentlich.
Mal so vorgesehen, als Steve den vorgestellt hat, war hier, hier 500 Dollar
und ihr bekommt ein Mac und bla und zu dem Preis und ja, bring your own mouse
and keyboard. Aber also das war schon...
Was sie auf keinen Fall tun werden, aber was ich eigentlich ganz geil fände,
gerade so für diesen, ich brauche mal ein Mac, um mal irgendwo mal ein Mac hinzustellen,
wenn man mal den Apple TV mit macOS ausstatten könnte.
Weil da ist ja eigentlich auch nur so ein iPhone-Chip drin.
Also wenn sie jetzt so ein Apple TV mit A18 oder A19 ausstatten,
was ja jetzt eigentlich mal ansteht, was fehlt denn dann da noch?
Ja, also okay, ist die Frage, wie viel RAM hat das Teil?
Das weiß ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nicht. Weiß man das überhaupt,
wie viel RAM Apple TV hat?
Weiß man, aber ich hab's nicht im Kopf. Alle tippen in ihre Geräte.
Was sagt der Mac Tracker?
Was sagt der Mac Tracker, genau. Also, Apple TV,
Apple TV Third Generation Den gibt es jetzt seit November 22.
Ist auch schon ganz schön alt.
Das Ding ist dreieinhalb Jahre alt, das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Also, angeblich steckt hier ein A15 Bionic drin in dem aktuellen Teil.
A15 Bionic?
Ja, wie hieß das damals? 4 GB RAM?
4 GB, ja. Büschen Lüt.
Na, für Linux wird es ja reichen.
Das wird auch für Mac OS reichen. Aber, sagen wir mal so, würden sie das jetzt
mit einem A18 oder mit einem A19 ausstatten, da 8 oder 12 Gigabyte RAM reinstecken?
Was hat das Ding noch? USB?
Es hat einen Ethernet-Anschluss, die größere Variante. Die würde man natürlich
dann nehmen. Bluetooth hat es.
Ja.
Ja, hat Bluetooth, hat WLAN, hat HDMI, fertig ist die Luzi.
Also er bräuchte noch so einen generischen USB-C oder zwei, vielleicht so zwei Ports wäre ganz gut.
Also mein Apple TV hat sogar einen Ethernet-Anschluss. Der hat nur das Problem,
dass man sich entscheiden muss, ob man WLAN oder Ethernet benutzen will,
weil er aus irgendeinem Grund nicht beides gleichzeitig macht.
Ja, weil einfach...
Ja, so mit automatischem Umschalten.
Hatte das nicht sogar auch schon so einen USB-Service-Anschluss hinten,
oder erinnere ich das falsch?
Nein, das erinnerst du richtig. Das ist aber auch wirklich nur,
also du kannst beim Apple TV keine Devices anschließen.
Ich sage ja auch nur, es wäre möglich, so etwas zu bauen, ja,
in so einem Plastikgehäuse.
Ich glaube, den hat es nicht mehr aktuell. Den hat es mal.
Nee, hat es nicht mehr.
Also auf den Bildern sehe ich es nicht mehr.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, das war am Anfang auch die Methode, wie man da ein Software-Update gemacht hat.
Aber es wäre jetzt nicht das Problem, in diesem Gehäuse noch einen USB-C-Port beizubringen.
Würde ich auf jeden Fall nehmen, wenn es den noch günstiger gibt,
aber müsste dann halt auch wirklich günstiger sein.
Das glaube ich nicht. Also Apple ist nicht die Company, die sich selbst den Markt kaputt macht.
Wieso den Markt kaputt?
Naja, wenn du sagst, unser billigstes Gerät ist für, ich nenne mal eine Zahl 300 zu haben,
dann wird es da sicherlich die Leute geben, die sagen, ja, aber warum sollen
die Leute denn was Teures kaufen, wenn sie für 300 ihren Apple TV Mac bekommen?
Ja, ich sage ja nur, ich sehe das auch nicht, dass sie das tun werden.
Es ist nur so, es gibt schon ein Gerät, was zeigt, dass es theoretisch ginge.
Ja, und man müsste auch Aufwand reinstecken, also besonders auf der Softwareseite
müsstest du den Scheiß natürlich portieren, dass es passt.
Also, ja, Ne, da sind wir uns einig, das wird nischt.
Nun gut.
Dann,
Können wir den Computerkaufbereich auch abschließen. Ich habe halt noch keinen.
Mal gucken, was ich mache. Eilt jetzt nicht so.
Du hattest hier Neo als Punkt mit aufgenommen, aber Neo ist jetzt nichts für dich.
Nein. Neo ist nichts für mich.
Okay. Ja, das war ja nur mal.
Nee, ich wollte damit nicht sagen, dass ich einen kaufen würde.
Das ist nichts für mich.
Für mich auch nicht, deswegen. Aber okay. So,
soll ich mal, bevor wir später vielleicht noch in anderer Art und Weise drauf
kommen, über Batterien und Autos sprechen?
Go ahead.
Also ich habe ja im November, im November war das, ja im November,
habe ich ja dieses doch recht große Auto von Volkswagen gekauft,
einen ID.Bus, also nicht direkt von denen, doch von denen, aber gebraucht.
Und da hat mich vor einigen Wochen ein Brief aus Wolfsburg erreicht,
also genau genommen aus Braunschweig, aber ist ja egal.
Ich zitiere. Für ihr Fahrzeug mit der oben genannten Fahrzeuge genannten Fahrzeugidentifizierungsnummer
wurde festgestellt, dass es von der sicherheitsrelevanten Rückrufmaßnahme 93MI betroffen ist.
Bei Fahrzeugen der ID-Baureihe aus einem begrenzten Fertigungszeitraum haben wir festgestellt,
dass ein Modul in der Hochvoltbatterie möglicherweise nicht unseren hohen Qualitätsstandards
entspricht. Und jetzt geht's los.
Dadurch kann es zu einem spürbaren Reichweitenverlust, zum Aufleuchten einer
gelben Warnlampe oder zu einer thermischen Überlastung innerhalb der Hochvoltbatterie kommen.
Eine thermische Überlastung kann zu einem Fahrzeugbrand führen,
mit dem Risiko von schweren oder tödlichen Verletzungen für die Fahrzeuginsassen.
Okay, das finde ich jetzt bemerkenswert. Entweder eine Lampe wird gelb oder das Auto explodiert.
Oder das Auto brennt ab. Ein Fahrzeugbrand kann bei geringem Abstand auf andere
Fahrzeuge oder Gebäude überspringen.
Also wenn du sowas in der Post hast, dann ist das nett, oder?
Grundsätzlich weisen wir darauf hin, dass falls ein Fahrzeugbrand auftreten
sollte, Sie Ihr Fahrzeug bitte sofort anhalten, es im Freien abstellen,
die Fahrbereitschaft beenden und das Fahrzeug verlassen müssen.
Müssen.
Müssen. Um jegliches Risiko auszuschließen,
möchten wir an Ihrem Fahrzeug folgende Arbeiten durchführen.
Installation einer aktualisierten Software, damit das Fahrzeug mögliche Fehler
in den Batteriemodulen künftig selbst erkennen kann.
Umfassende Prüfung der Hochvoltbatterie, um deren Zustand und Funktion zu bewerten.
Und als letztes Austausch einzelner
Module, falls bei der Prüfung Auffälligkeiten festgestellt werden.
So und blablabla, nach Werkstatttermin.
Und dann zum Schluss steht dann noch, bis zur Überprüfung und Reparatur Ihres
Fahrzeugs ist es zwingend erforderlich, dass Sie Ihr Fahrzeug mit nur maximal
80 Prozent und im freien laden.
Das Fahrzeug kann unter Beachtung dieser Hinweise weiterhin genutzt werden.
Ganz normal, gehen Sie weiter, es gibt nichts zu sehen.
Ja, okay.
Gut, habe ich also rumtelefoniert und tatsächlich,
nachdem ich erwähnt habe, dass es um den Rick-Ruf ging, dann doch relativ flott
einen Termin bekommen, obwohl irgendwie vorher behauptet wurde,
dass über Wochen alles ausgebucht ist,
habe das Auto dann dort abgeworfen und...
Bei dieser Eingangsprüfung, also die gucken das Auto ja vorher an,
in welchem Zustand ist das, bevor sie sie annehmen, Fahrzeugannahme oder wie
sich das nennt, fiel dann auf, dass mit den Reifen was nicht stimmt.
Also dein Wagen ist gebraucht gekauft.
Ja, ja. Und wohlgemerkt, ich habe das da, wo ich ihn gekauft habe,
halt dann auch zur Werkstatt gegeben, bei einem Berliner VW-Händler,
also VW Berlin oder wie auch immer die heißen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall war das so, ich habe das im November gekauft, das Auto.
Und die hatten halt gesagt, sie montieren mir umsonst noch die Winterräder drauf,
weil ich könnte ja jetzt nicht mit Sommerreifen losfahren.
So, da habe ich halt dann Winterräder besorgt, habe die da hinschicken lassen.
Dann haben die die montiert und haben mir die Sommerräder eingepackt im Kofferraum mitgegeben.
Und dann habe ich die in die Garage abgeworfen und habe die eine Woche,
bevor es dann zu diesem Rückruftermin kam, bei meinem Schrauber wechseln lassen auf die Sommerräder.
Ich komme also mit den Sommerrädern da an und der Typ, der die Aufnahme macht,
sagen sie mal, was haben sie denn da für Reifen? So können sie doch gar nicht fahren.
Und dann so, ja und hier, sie sind ja abgefahren und der eine Reifen ist ein
ganz anderer Reifen und ich so, es tut mir leid, die habe ich so bei ihnen gekauft
und dann guckt er mich so an.
So schlecht waren die jetzt doch.
War dann so, Das wusste er dann auch nicht, was er dazu noch sagen soll und
dann stellt sich also heraus,
das waren tatsächlich drei Sommerreifen und ein Allwetterreifen,
ein Allganzjahresreifen.
Ah, den sie dir als Sommerreifen verkauft haben.
Den sie mir da quasi mitverkauft haben. Das war mir halt nicht aufgefallen.
Gut, das nächste Mal gucke ich vielleicht auch an der Stelle genauer hin.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich da einen bösen Brief geschrieben,
so nach der Art, ich sehe das als Mangel an, den ich hiermit anzeigen würde
und mangelhafter Kaufgegenstand, bla bla bla und so weiter. und Sie sollten
sich doch bitte schön mal dazu äußern.
So und dann kam dann auch ein paar Tage später der Rückruf, ja und hier und
so weiter und da müssten Sie mal vorbeikommen und dann würden wir da eine Fahrzeugbewertung machen.
Und dann bin ich ja so hin, irgendein anderer Kollege, also der ein Anruf war
von dem Verkäufer, der mir ursprünglich das Auto verkauft hat.
Irgend so ein Kollege von ihm hat sich das Ding dann so angeguckt und meinte,
ja, diese Räder sind ja noch ganz okay, aber das ist hier vorne,
ja, das ist tatsächlich ein Ganzjahresreifen.
Ja, da muss ich mal gucken, ob das so überhaupt zulässig ist.
Und dann dachte ich schon so, oh ja, okay, also die E-Mail hatte ich ja an den
gesamten Dings da, Info-Ad, der gesamte Laden geschickt.
Und scheinbar ging das da irgendwie dann durch die Hierarchien durch.
Und dann hat der Verkäufer scheinbar von oben eins auf den Dez gekriegt,
so nach der, das geht so nicht, den müssen wir mal ranholen und es mal angucken.
Ja und jetzt habe ich vor zwei Tagen oder so, also kurz vorm Wochenende den
Rückruf bekommen, ja sie würden mir jetzt zwei neue Reifen für die Vorderachse
bestellen und sie dann auch montieren.
Und was ist jetzt mit der Batterie?
Achso, mit der Batterie, ja nix, die ist so in Ordnung.
Achso, die haben sie jetzt gar nicht getauscht, die haben nur gecheckt, ob sie tauschen müssen.
Der Punkt ist, dass ich habe ja, als ich den Brief bekommen habe,
habe ich es mir auch näher angeguckt und es ging auch so ein bisschen durch die Presse.
Der Punkt war, dass Volkswagen wohl von einem Zulieferer Module bekommen hat,
die nicht in der Speck waren und sich deswegen beim Laden ein bisschen anders
verhalten und halt zu Abnormalitäten führen können.
Und da sie zwar wissen, in welchem Zeitraum sie die geliefert bekommen haben,
aber nicht genau nachvollziehen könnten, in welchen Packs die verbaut worden sind,
haben sie halt alle Autos zurückgerufen, die Packs bekommen haben in dem Zeitraum.
Und ich glaube, es ist nicht bekannt, wie viele Packs sie tatsächlich getauscht
haben oder in welchen Packs sie Module getauscht haben.
Bei mir war laut deren Aussage jetzt kein Problem.
Sie haben dann also tatsächlich eine neue Software installiert.
Sie haben auch von der insgesamten Software nochmal eine Version upgedatet,
die es so over the air nicht gab.
Ist auch ganz lustig, in der Rechnung zu 0 Euro stand dann auch die Arbeitsschritte drin.
Da hat er es also normal versucht und dann hat er es nochmal auf eine spezielle
Art und Weise versucht und dann hat er es ganz per Hand gemacht irgendwie.
Es war auch ganz lustig, dass man an den Posten sehen konnte,
wie der immer verzweifelter wurde, das Software-Update zu installieren.
Also ehrlich gesagt, mich wundert das sehr, dass die nicht wissen,
in welchem Auto welches Modul verbaut ist.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist, glaube ich, dass der Zulieferer selber Module halt hatte,
die rausgefallen sind und der Zulieferer wahrscheinlich möglicherweise auch
gar nicht genau weiß, welche Module tatsächlich fehlerhaft sind.
Weswegen dann Volkswagen hinterher auch nicht weiß, wo sind denn die Module, die sie verbaut haben.
Aber sie müssen es ja an irgendwas erkannt haben.
Ja, da gibt es so unterschiedliche Storys von tatsächlich abgebrannten Fahrzeugen.
Nee, ich meine ...
Modul, ist das jetzt etwas, was sich elektronisch in irgendeiner Form ansprechen
lässt, dieses Modul, was da betroffen war?
Ist das eine intelligente, in Anführungsstrichen intelligente Einheit oder reden
wir hier nur von irgendeinem analogen Elektrik?
Ja, also normalerweise ist es so, dass ein Batterie-Management-System,
nein nicht normalerweise, ich weiß, dass ein Batterie-Management-System auf
Modulebene Spannungen messen kann.
Also da gibt es auch Prüfsoftware von Drittherstellern, die das ausliest und
an dessen eine Qualitätsbeurteilung des gesamten Packs macht.
So und scheinbar war die Software von VW bisher nicht in der Lage,
das genau nachzuvollziehen beziehungsweise sie kannten wohl das genaue Fehlverhalten
nicht und kennen das jetzt und können das jetzt diagnostizieren.
Aber prinzipiell ist es so, dass verschiedene Zellen in einem Pack,
sich unterschiedlich verhalten. Je besser das Pack ist, desto gleicher verhalten die sich.
Aber du hast immer welche, die ein bisschen langsamer laden und welche, die schneller laden.
Und das führt dazu, dass du bei einem bestimmten Ladezustand verschiedene Spannungen
an verschiedenen Zellen hast.
Und das kannst du messen. Das kann auch das Batteriemanagement messen,
System messen. Aber dazu muss die Software das halt auch tun.
Und ich glaube, das ist das, was sie nachgerüstet haben.
Okay, aber dieses fehlerhafte Modul, was in irgendwelche Fahrzeuge eingebaut wurde,
ist kein Modul, was jetzt sich auf einem digitalen Bus meldet mit,
hallo, hier bin ich mit Seriennummer, Bauinformation, tralala,
das ist das, was ich wissen wollte.
Da stellst du eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann.
Okay, gut, naja, weil sowas würde man ja heutzutage eigentlich fast erwarten.
Es sei denn, es geht jetzt in reine Chemie, Zellchemie-Geschichte,
also in so einem analogen Bereich, wo nichts digital ist.
Naja, die Frage ist, hast du ein Batterie-Management-System mit ganz vielen
Input-Ports, wo du halt ein Kabel zu jedem Modul hast, um dort zu messen?
Oder hat jedes Modul nochmal eine eigene kleine Elektronik, die das vorhält?
Keine Ahnung, kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ist so. Andere Frage, welche Kapazität hat dein Pack?
Ab Werk 77. Aha, weißt du, dass du dann illegible bist für ein neues Programm von VW?
Ja, dieses Vehicle-to-Grid oder was das ist.
Genau.
Ja, das ist ja Quatsch.
Wieso ist das Quatsch?
Naja, weil sie dir relativ wenig Geld dafür geben, dass sie deine Batterie...
600 Euro im Jahr.
Ja, sag ich ja. Dass sie deine Batterie gewinnbringend einsetzen können. Also...
Ich sag ja nur, also...
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Wenn man einen dynamischen Stromtarif hat, das ist das Erste.
Das heißt, man braucht noch so einen Smart-Mieter, was nicht jeder hat und dann
braucht man noch eine Wallbox, die bidirektional ist.
Weiß ich nicht, ob du das hättest alles?
Nein, ich habe keine Wallbox, die bidirektional ist.
Und ich habe keinen dynamischen Stromtarif.
Und außerdem habe ich eine große Solaranlage auf dem Dach und auch noch einen Akku im Keller.
Also das Gesamtsystem so zu steuern, dass dann tatsächlich hinterher was bei
rumkommt, ist eh schon nicht ganz einfach. Und da würde ich jetzt nicht auch
noch das Auto mit reinpacken in die Rechnung.
Also ja, ich weiß, dass es dieses Angebot gibt, aber du kannst davon ausgehen,
dass wenn dir eine Firma sowas verkauft, dass die den Reibach machen und dir das Trinkgeld geben.
Ja, gut. Also grundsätzlich finde ich das nicht falsch, dass es solche Programme gibt.
Die Konditionen können sich ja auch noch ändern und es ist auch klar,
also wer hat jetzt schon sowohl einen batteriebetriebenen VW mit mindestens
77 Kilowattstunden, das ist nämlich die Grenze, also mit kleineren Akkus machen
sie es nicht aus unklaren Gründen.
dann brauchst du eben die anderen Bedingungen, die ich gerade genannt hatte.
Also du brauchst eine Wallbox, die bidirektional kann, du brauchst so einen
Smart Meter und du brauchst halt dann auch den entsprechenden Stromtarif,
den du dann wahrscheinlich auch hast, wenn du dir den ganzen Kram schon zulegst.
Aber ich finde es grundsätzlich interessant, dass jetzt sozusagen Fahrzeuge,
die in einem Eigenheim stehen oder wo auch immer stehen, auch in der Tiefgarage
und die mit so einer Technik angeschlossen sind,
dann eben quasi als Kraftwerk mit benutzt werden können.
Und wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
also du kriegst vor allem nicht Geld für den gelieferten Strom,
sondern du kriegst Geld für jede Stunde, die du dranhängst.
Du wirst für die Bereitschaft bezahlt und nicht für die tatsächliche das Strom hin und her.
Ja, trotzdem ist es natürlich so, dass du durch die ganze Sache natürlich Zyklen
auf den Akku machst, was den Akku einfach mal verbraucht.
Das weiß ich nicht, ob dem wirklich so ist, weil eigentlich moderne Akkus… Doch.
Immer wenn du lädst und endlädst, ja, man kann ja drüber streiten,
wie groß der Effekt ist, aber der Effekt ist da und… Na.
Da habe ich ja unterschiedliche Sachen gehört.
Und ist der Effekt ...
Ist der Wertverlust durch das Zyklen des Akkus tatsächlich aufgewogen durch
das, was sie dir jährlich zahlen, ist halt etwas, das kann man ihnen glauben,
aber das kann man halt auch anzweifeln.
Also ich würde es nicht machen.
Ich glaube, die Skepsis ist, also ich bin da kein Experte, aber was ich bisher
gehört habe, ist es so, sie entladen ja nicht und sie machen dich nicht auf
100 Prozent und sie machen dich nicht auf 0 Prozent.
Ja, das ist klar.
Es ist eine Bewegung des Akkus, sagen wir mal, im Bereich zwischen 20 und 80
Prozent vielleicht sogar ist es noch weniger.
Es ist bestimmt deutlich weniger, weil du kannst ja sowas sagen wie,
ich habe immer eine Restmenge im Akku, wenn ich losfahren will und deswegen
werden sie sicherlich eher zwischen 80 und 60 Prozent oder so machen.
Die Frage ist natürlich auch, was wollen die damit erreichen?
Ist es Netzstabilität zum Beispiel?
Das ist ja ein ganz anderes Ding, als jetzt tatsächlich Strom,
um Strom zu haben, einzuspeisen.
Also wenn du sagen kannst, es ist zu viel Strom im Netz, ich ziehe mal eben
mit einer halben Million Autos einen Megawatt aus dem Netz raus.
Das kann ja auch eine Leistung sein, die sinnvoll ist.
Ja, also die Annahme, dass das dem Akku schadet, ich glaube, die stimmt nicht.
Ich kann jetzt nicht auf Studien verweisen, sondern ich glaube, dass die ist,
also ich glaube, ich habe das bisher so rausgehört aus all dem,
was ich mir zu dem Thema angehört habe und angelesen habe, Also dass es eigentlich eher jetzt so ist,
dass so ein Akku dadurch potenziell, also dass es ihm einerseits nicht schadet
oder andererseits sogar nützt, weil das quasi so ein Training ist,
wenn du in dem Bereich bist,
dass das Laden und Entladen dem Akku eher gut tut, weil du sozusagen die Dinge im Flow behältst.
Also ich würde eher andere Leute das mal ausprobieren lassen und mal gucken.
Was passiert. Ja genau, also wenn ihr diese Bedingungen erfüllt und da nicht
so skeptisch seid wie, gut.
Ich meine 600 Euro im Jahr ist jetzt auch… Das sind ja 50.
Euro im Monat.
Das ist halt auch nicht so viel. Naja, ich meine das sind 600 Euro im Jahr.
Ja, klar.
Ich habe jetzt für mein Moped, für mein Elektromotorrad...
Plus dem Vorgänger, was ich hatte, die ein, zwei Jahre noch parallel liefen.
Aber sagen wir mal, ich hätte das jetzt nur dieses Motorrad die ganze Zeit gehabt,
habe ich über diese VHG-Quote, nee, nicht VH, sondern V, wie heißt es?
Die, ja, diese Zahl.
THG-Quote, nicht V. THG-Quote, also Treibhaus, Gas, Emissions,
Payback. Das kennt auch nicht jeder.
Wenn ihr ein Elektrofahrzeug habt, ihr könnt euch da anmelden und ihr kriegt
dann einfach Geld überwiesen, ohne irgendeine Gegenleistung.
Nur dafür, dass man ein Elektrofahrzeug besitzt, erhält man Geld derzeit noch.
Man muss sich nur dafür anmelden.
Man verkauft seine CO2-Zertifikate.
Genau, man erhält Geld.
An sich.
Und es gibt halt Portale, wo man das irgendwie machen kann.
Und ich habe jetzt sozusagen über die Lifetime des Besitzes von elektrischen
Zweirädern 1000 Euro eingenommen.
Okay.
1000 Euro bezahlt mir sehr, sehr, sehr viele Kilometer, die ich mit diesem Fahrzeug gefahren bin.
Ja, gut.
Also ich zahle, was zahle ich jetzt, wenn ich jetzt hier lade für eine Akkuladung?
Gehen wir mal von, also ich habe einen Verbrauch von 7,5 Kilowattstunden für 100.
Ja, es ist sehr wenig, aber es ist ja auch ein Motorrad.
Für ein Motorrad ist es schon, finde ich.
Ist es eher viel? Okay, meinetwegen.
Ja, kann man so sehen. Also 100 Kilometer bringen 7,5, das heißt das kostet
mich ungefähr 33 Cent, so 2,50.
Für 2,50 Euro, wenn ich jetzt hier lade, kriege ich irgendwie 100 Kilometer Fahrspaß.
Klar, da hast du 4.000 Kilometer gekriegt oder so. Habe ich das jetzt richtig überschlagen?
25 Euro sind dann 1.000 Kilometer.
Ja, dann sind...
Und wenn ich halt die 1.000...
Ja, okay, dann sind es 10.000.
Ja, dann habe ich also 40...
40.000 Kilometer.
Ja, ja, okay. Ja, klar.
Ich bin aber nur 25.000 Kilometer gefahren mit dem Teil.
Ja, gut, aber du hattest natürlich auch Wertverlust. Also das musst du natürlich mitrechnen.
Wertverlust?
Naja, du rechnest den Kilometer, also wenn du so mit einem spitzen Bleistift
rechnest, musst du natürlich den Wertverlust des Fahrzeuges mit in die Kilometer reinrechnen.
Nein, den Wertverlust hatte ich ja sowieso. Aber ich habe sozusagen einfach
nochmal 40.000 Kilometer fahren dazubekommen, bin aber nur 25.000 gefahren.
Das heißt, ich habe bisher für keinen Kilometer Geld bezahlt.
Ich fahre dieses Fahrzeug, seit ich es gekauft habe, quasi for free.
Okay, ja, so kann man es natürlich sehen. Nee, aber THG-Quote,
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jemand ein Elektrofahrzeug besitzt und das nicht kennt.
Ich kenne Leute, die sich jetzt gerade nicht kaufen und die wissen das nicht.
Weil das so absurd viel beworben wurde in seiner Anfangszeit.
Ja, in der Bubble halt, ne?
Ja, ja, gut, aber trotzdem, es gab ja tausende Anbieter.
Ich packe euch mal einen ganz frechen Link in unsere Show nutzen,
könnt ihr dann klick so an, dann habe ich da auch noch was von.
Ich mache ja sonst hier kein Affiliate-Klimbim.
So, so.
So, so, genau. Dann habt ihr auch Geld kostenlos.
Gut, also das war mein kleines Abenteuer mit, ich fahre mal eben in die Werkstatt
und jetzt war ich schon zweimal dort und muss noch einmal hin.
Ja, okay. Und dann ist wieder alles gut.
Ja, ich hoffe. Also es ist ganz lustig, weil ich habe versucht natürlich rauszufinden,
ist es überhaupt zulässig, auf der gleichen Achse einen Reifen mit einem Sommerreifen
und einem Ganzjahresreifen zu fahren?
Und siehe da, das war zumindest die Sprachmodelle der Wahl, die LLMs der Wahl,
haben zwar gesagt, nein, also das geht überhaupt gar nicht.
Aber wenn man sie dann festnagelt, so, ja, ist es denn verboten?
Ja, zeigt mir das Gesetz, wo das steht.
Ja, dann habe ich jetzt so nicht gefunden, aber das geht nicht.
Und da denkst du so, naja, toll, es wäre jetzt vielleicht doch auch mal schön gewesen, aber egal.
Ich kriege jetzt neue Reifen und damit ist mir das Thema dann auch zu Ende.
Wo wir gerade bei dem Thema Elektromotorrad sind, kannst du ja auch nochmal
das Donut-Thema ansprechen.
Ja, was soll man sagen? Also es spaltet nach wie vor die Leute,
wobei die Anhänger der Donut-Batterie, glaube ich, deutlich weniger geworden sind.
nachdem sehr, sehr viele Experten gesagt haben, Leute, Donat,
ihr müsst mal ein paar echte Fakten auf den Tisch legen und nicht so halbgare,
wir pumpen da Strom rein und es passiert irgendwas,
Dinger.
Also sie haben halt nie wirklich einen Zyklus getestet.
Sie haben nie wirklich eine...
Also eine Ladungshaltefähigkeit getestet.
So nach der Art, wenn ich die dreimal so schnell lade, wie viel Ladung hält sie danach immer noch?
Oder habe ich jetzt irgendwie angefangen, die Batterie zu zerlegen?
Solche Sachen, also es bleibt dabei, dass die Behauptungen von Donut halt Behauptungen
sind. Untermauern konnten sie sie nicht.
Gut, ob die jetzt so stimmen und ob man ihnen jetzt glaubt, das muss jeder für
sich wissen. Aber so richtig ...
Es ist unklar. Ich verstehe vor allem Ihre Strategie nicht.
Am Anfang war das ja ganz lustig, dass Sie so ein bisschen hinterm Berg gehalten
haben und gesagt haben, ihr werdet schon sehen.
Nur hat dann halt keiner gesehen.
Und sie hatten ja ursprünglich ein Auslieferziel für März, sind aber derzeit
noch nicht mal in der Lage Testfahrten anzubieten.
Ich habe jetzt gerade an einer Testfahrt teilgenommen, da waren dann aber noch
die alten Modelle am Start.
Was auch ganz interessant war,
kann ich gleich dazu sagen, ich wollte das unbedingt mal ausprobieren.
Ich bin zwar schon mal so ganz langsam in der Tiefgarage damit rumgeguckt,
aber das ist ja irgendwie nur die halbe Miete.
Jetzt war ich mal so eine Stunde unterwegs mit dem Teil, also mit dem Vorläufer,
Modell, was sie ja jetzt schon seit zwei Jahren verkaufen. Und kann ich nur sagen.
Das ist schon, also so stelle ich mir das in etwa vor.
Ich hatte da im Detail einiges zu meckern, aber das sind alles so Punkte,
von denen sie ja auch gesagt haben, das wissen sie auch und das ist ja genau
das, was sie mit der neuen Generation besser machen wollen.
es gibt auch so noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten, die ich nicht verstehe warum das
Ding nicht einfach einen Rückwärtsgang hat,
zum Beispiel weil finde ich ist irgendwie gerade bei einem Elektrofahrzeug ist
das so ein No-Brainer irgendwie also da musst du echt nicht mehr machen als
den Strom irgendwie anders rumfließen lassen und dann war es das,
aber Leute, also diese Beschleunigung ist einfach so irre es ist so crazy krass, das ist so geil,
und leise und mega,
also ich will das eigentlich haben.
Aber um zurück auf die Batterie zu kommen ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass sie eine gute Batterie haben, aber ich glaube sie haben wirklich den Mund
zu voll genommen und versuchen jetzt irgendwie aus der Nummer rauszukommen,
ob sie ein gutes Motorrad bauen oder nicht, kann ich nicht beurteilen,
bin kein Motorradfahrer, aber auch das glaube ich ihnen, dass die Möhre schon was kann.
Aber diese Wunderbatterie, die wird es so, glaube ich, nicht geben.
Also das kann ich mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Dass sie eine gute Batterie machen, ja, warum auch nicht.
Also auch in kleinen Stückzahlen, Elektromotorräder werden insgesamt nicht in
großen Stückzahlen gebaut.
Dass sie da eine außergewöhnliche Batterie haben, ja, aber nicht die Zahlen,
die sie behauptet haben.
Da würde ich fast wetten. Ihre Videos sind insofern etwas enttäuschend,
als dass sie eben zu viele Zweifel offen lassen.
Also wir haben ja auch dieses Video hier, das letzte von dem Tom Böttcher verlinkt,
der das Ganze ja aus dieser Perspektive eines Batterieforschers bewertet und da ist wirklich...
Nichts bewiesen. Und auf der anderen Seite zeigen sie halt ihr Fahrzeug beim Laden.
Und da muss man sich halt schon fragen, okay, ist das jetzt komplett gelogen?
Also zeigen sie mir jetzt gerade wirklich ein Video, was es so gar nicht geben kann oder stimmt es?
Und dadurch, dass sie das eben nicht durch Third-Party-Testing bestätigen können
oder nicht tun, vielleicht könnten sie es, aber sie tun es halt derzeit nicht.
Und wo ich wo bei mir selber auch so ein bisschen, also ich habe ihnen bisher
immer so Benefit of the Doubt gegeben.
Ich dachte immer so, ja, okay, ich gebe euch jetzt noch ein paar Monate,
ihr habt ja gesagt, ihr braucht noch ein paar Monate, supi.
Und ihr wollt jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Welle machen, meinetwegen.
Und iDonut Believe Webseite, sehr lustig, haha, haben wir alle schön gelacht,
da werden dann sicherlich auch irgendwie mal substanzielle Videos kommen. Die kamen dann nicht.
Der Gipfel war dann, dass sie sich dann auch noch entblödet haben,
ein 1. April-Video auch noch da drauf zu stellen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast. Das war dann schon so stark im Fremdschämen-Bereich,
wo ich mir dachte, so Leute, das hätte es jetzt echt nicht gebraucht.
Also das ist so, fand ich, für.
Potenzielle Kunden schon fast eine Beleidigung, weil sie dann halt so,
ja, es gibt ja auch schon eine zweite Version von der Batterie, die ist ja noch toller.
Hö, hö, nee, das war jetzt alles nur Spaß und es ging die ganze Zeit hin und
her und am Ende wusste man überhaupt nicht, woran man ist das mehr so.
Ihr verbraucht jetzt hier meine Zeit für nix und ihr schadet euch nur.
Ja, okay, und dann zeigen sie halt ein Video mit ihrem Motorrad,
wie das halt an dieser Ladesäule lädt und dann erstmal so bis 50% mit 100 Kilowatt lädt.
Ja, wenn es das gibt, dann Butterbeierfische, dann zeig doch den Scheiß.
Das Problem ist natürlich, du kannst deinem Batteriemanagement sagen,
lade diese Batterie mal mit diesen Werten.
Die Frage ist, wie oft kannst du die dann laden?
Wahrscheinlich nicht allzu oft. Zumindest dann, wenn es eine herkömmliche Batterie ist.
Genauso wie du einen, weiß ich nicht, Traktormotor auf 800 PS bringst und der
überlebt dann eine Runde auf dem Nürburgring, aber danach kannst du den Motor
halt direkt ins Altmetall tun.
Wie wir glaube ich vorletzte Sendung dann schon mal gesagt hatten,
wenn man halt irgendwie so diese 4, 5 Kennwerte hast, dann kannst du halt eine
Batterie auf 2, vielleicht noch 3 optimieren, aber 2 fallen hinten runter.
Und ihr Claim war ja von Anfang an, nein, wir sind in sämtlichen Dimensionen,
Weltspitze und weit far beyond.
Wir sind in sämtlichen Dimensionen deutlich besser als alle anderen und das
Das ist für mich ein bisschen sehr überzogene Behauptung.
Ich sage nicht, das stimmt nicht, aber ich sage gleichzeitig auch,
da will ich aber auch mehr Beweise sehen als ein Höhö-April-April-Video.
Das ist schon schwierig.
Also, tja, keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, dass sie mit der Batterie in den Videos Dinge tun,
die man mit einer handelsüblichen Batterie nicht machen kann oder halt nur ein Dutzend Mal.
Das bestreite ich ja nicht. Das sieht man, dass sie das tun.
Die Frage ist nur, ich glaube nicht, dass das Auslieferungszustand ist.
Das ist nicht eine Art, wie du die Batterie lädst und hinterher 100.000 Kilometer damit fährst.
Die Frage ist, is this good for the company?
Dazu bin ich zu wenig CEO und ich weiß auch gar nicht.
Ob ich einer sein möchte. Das war ein Zitat. Das war eine Kulturreferenz,
die du jetzt nicht verstanden hast.
Das mag sein, ja. Ist gut. Keine Ahnung.
Offer Space.
Ah, okay. Nö, also wie gesagt, so gesehen ist eigentlich alles noch offen.
Gut, dann wollen wir auch nicht
weiter spekulieren, weil es gibt ja quasi keine Daten zu spekulieren.
Alright, next. Haben wir uns schon über Mythos unterhalten?
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Und ich nehme mal an, du meinst nicht das griechische Bier.
Es gibt ein griechisches Bier, das Mythos heißt?
Ja, das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht. Gar nicht so schlecht, man kann es trinken.
Stimmt, Mythos.
Das ist jetzt nichts, wo ich jetzt extra für nach Griechenland fahren würde.
Aber wenn es das beim Griechen gibt, dann kann man es schon trinken.
Gehört zu den wichtigsten Biermarken des Landes. Also gemeint ist Griechenland.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Einführung der Biermarke 97 hieß die Brauerei Mythos Brewery Limited.
Nach mehreren Eigentümerwechseln gehört die heutige Olympic Brewery zur dänischen Carlsberg Gruppe.
Oh Gott, dafür ist es ganz gut.
Helles Lagerbier nach Pilsener Brauart.
Ne, also das meinte ich nicht.
Dachte ich mir.
Sondern ich meinte den Hype um das neue Modell von Anthropic,
AI-Modell, von dem sie ja ganz windig bekannt gegeben haben,
dass das ja so toll sei, dass man das mal nicht einfach mal jetzt so eben auf
die Welt loslassen kann, weil dann fällt die ganze Software um.
Zumindest die ganze Open-Source-Software, da ihre Software in der Lage ist,
nicht nur Sicherheitslücken in Open-Source zu finden,
sondern die auch noch so miteinander zu verflechten,
dass du aus einer Kaskade von Ausnutzungen von Sicherheitslücken eben auch konkrete
Exploits generieren kannst, mit dem man dann eben in diesem System für entweder Privilege Escalation,
also die Akquirierung von höheren Benutzerrechten sorgen kann oder eben für
Denial-of-Service-Attacken.
Remote-Code-Execution wird auch immer gern genommen.
Ja, die ja dann auch letzten Endes eine von den beiden Folgen hat.
Also die Frage ist ja, was kommt am Ende bei raus?
Also kannst du da sozusagen, also Code exekutieren hilft dir ja jetzt erstmal
nicht, sondern du willst ja dann auch deinen eigenen Code sozusagen exekutieren.
Ja, aber das ist ja das, was das meint. Also du kannst remotely deinen Code,
den du exekutieren willst, exekutieren.
Dann hast du noch eine Privilege Escalation und dann gehört dir der Rechner.
Genau und das ist natürlich die hohe Kunst so im Hackerbereich.
Sicherheitslücken finden ist so das eine, aber die dann eben auch so geschickt
anzuwenden und gegebenenfalls miteinander zu kombinieren, dass dann eben dein
echtes Ziel auch erreicht wird.
Das sei also nun das neue Ding und weil halt Mythos so toll ist und so gefährlich
ist, dürften das auch nur ausgewählte Individuen und Organisationen auf diesem Planeten anfassen.
TIA.
Also man baut seinen Mythos um Mythos.
Man baut den Mythos um Mythos, das haben sie ganz gut hinbekommen.
Also es gibt da so ein Project Glasswing,
wie sie das nennen und da sind dann halt die großen Hersteller,
Apple, Microsoft und ich weiß nicht, man weiß nicht so recht wer.
Es hieß halt, alle populären Plattformen.
Das dürfte meiner Meinung nach halt in irgendeiner Form auch so die Linux-Community sein,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass Mythos dann halt irgendwo zum Download bereitsteht,
sondern es wird eben ausgewählten Personen zur Verfügung gestellt und das gilt
dann wohl auch für Browser etc.
Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass da im Hintergrund schon so einige dran arbeiten.
Jetzt kann man das natürlich jetzt so nehmen. Es gibt auch mittlerweile Behauptungen,
dass auch Gemini 5.5 und so auch schon in diesem Range drin ist.
Aber die eigentliche Frage, die ja dahinter steht, ist, was macht das jetzt
mit Software und mit Sicherheit ab?
An sich und läutet das jetzt sozusagen die nächste Ebene in diesem ganzen AI-Wahnsinn ein?
Antwort ist ja. Nächstes Thema?
Ich würde das noch eine Umdrehung verschärfen.
Dieses Wegschließen ist total absurd. Also gut, das ist jetzt irgendwie so tun und machen,
aber der Gedanke, dass im AI-Bereich irgendwo jemand einen Vorsprung hat,
der länger als ein halbes Jahr gegenüber allen anderen hält, ist glaube ich falsch.
Und sprich, das was jetzt Entropic dort mit großem PR-Bohai glaubt,
einmalig in die Welt gesetzt zu haben, werden wir in einem Vierteljahr,
in einem halben Jahr genauso von OpenAI und von Google sehen.
Von daher muss man sich jetzt schon mal auf eine Welt einstellen,
wo das der Status Quo ist.
Also ich erinnere an die Sendung, ich glaube im Dezember, wo ich meine Pipeline
vorgestellt hatte, wo Gemini 3.1 erstmalig meine Handschrift lesen konnte.
Wo ich dieses Tool hatte, diesen Promptaufbau zur Transkription von beliebigen
Metaplanwänden nach Markdown.
Das war wirklich ein Moment, wo ich dachte, okay, da hat Google jetzt auch mal
ganz schön einen rausgehauen.
Das habe ich nicht ansatzweise von Anthropic gesehen oder von OpenAI.
Anthropic macht aber auch andere Dinge.
Stand heute, sechs Monate später, können das alle.
So, inklusive jetzt schon ein offenes Modell, was irgendwie auf Apple Silicon Hardware läuft.
Ich glaube, dass du aber das Problem von der falschen Seite aussiehst,
weil wenn Anthropic tatsächlich damit, sagen wir mal, eine Klasse besser ist als alle Follower?
Noch, ja.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, ich rede über den jetzigen Zeitpunkt,
zu sagen, wir machen eine Responsible
Disclosure, sprich dieses Tool bekommen erstmal die in die Hand,
die jetzt am wichtigsten erstmal die Lücken, die dieses Ding findet, fixen müssen,
bevor wir verantwortungsvoll das Ding dann in alle Hände geben,
halte ich für eigentlich die richtige Herangehensweise.
Das habe ich gar nicht in Frage gestellt. Sorry, Missverständnis.
Nein, nein, das ist schon total richtig, was die machen.
Nur die Welt, TM, soll jetzt mal nicht glauben, dass damit jetzt irgendein Problem
für uns gelöst ist. Das war so ein bisschen Tims Frage.
Du meinst, weil sie es nicht öffentlich machen.
Genau.
So hatte ich die Frage nicht verstanden.
Weil irgendeiner wird es machen innerhalb der nächsten zwölf Monate.
Nicht dieses, aber vergleichbare Ansätze. Ja, im Zweifelsfall die Chinesen. So Klischee, aber ne.
Ja, aber so hatte ich die Frage nicht verstanden.
Die Frage ist ja mehr, wir tauchen jetzt in eine Welt ein, wo ein AI-Modell
tatsächlich in der Lage ist, automatisiert solche Sicherheitsüberprüfungen zu tun.
Und die Folge ist natürlich, dass Sicherheitslücken gefunden werden.
Und die Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass die Firmen, die diese Sicherheitslücken
in ihrer Software haben, die schnell fixen.
Die andere Frage ist natürlich, was passiert denn mit der ganzen Abandoned Wear da draußen?
Also all diese Kraftwerke, die mit NT4, Surface Pack 1 laufen oder weiß ich nicht was.
Windows 95.
Windows 95 oder hast du nicht gesehen? Also da draußen sind ja Maschinen,
die wichtige Dinge tun und trotzdem auf extrem tönernden Füßen stehen.
Was passiert mit denen eigentlich, weil manche Systeme, da kannst du halt auch
realistischerweise kein Update machen.
Ja, also ich meine, das sind ja jetzt keine Open-Source-Systeme.
Im Kontext von Mythos geht es ja jetzt konkret erstmal um Source-Code-Analyse.
Nicht um von außen anklopfen.
Solche Systeme wird es auch geben. Da sitzen bestimmt Leute dran,
die halt mit existierenden Modellen in irgendeiner Form fuzzing und versuchen
sozusagen von außen ranzuklopfen.
Aber hier geht es jetzt erstmal um Open Source.
Das betrifft jetzt Windows NT in dem Sinne erstmal noch nicht so richtig.
Aber du kannst aus einem Binary immer wieder Source Code machen.
Das ist richtig. Inwiefern das auf demselben Level ist, dass man durch eine
Binäranalyse das machen kann.
Andererseits… Naja, es gibt ja die Compiler. Also ich glaube,
du siehst den Ansatz, ich habe nur ein kompiliertes Binary, also bin ich vor dem Tool sicher.
Das würde ich mal hochgradig infrage stellen.
Ich sage nur, Mythos, die Ankündigung und das, worüber wir jetzt reden,
geht explizit auf Source-Code.
Ja, ja, schon klar. Deswegen kriegen es ja auch erstmal die Firmen,
die jetzt die Sicherheitslücken fixen dürfen, nehme ich mal an.
Also zumindest dann, wenn die großen Hersteller jetzt mal so richtig heftige
Updates rausballern mit tausenden von, wie heißen die Nummern, egal,
also mit tausenden von gefixten Sicherheitslücken, dann weißt du,
okay, das Tool hat seine Arbeit getan.
ne also das ist so und.
Interessante Information es gab ja den wie heißt der Daniel Stenberg der Autor
von Lip Curl von dieser Library die halt so,
HTTP macht. Und mit viel Tamtam hat er ja vor einigen Monaten, Anfang dieses Jahres,
seine Bug-Bounty-Prämie zurückgezogen und gesagt, ich kriege jetzt hier nur
noch so AI-Slop und das ist irgendwie alles die Arbeit nicht mehr wert.
Mittlerweile hat er ein neues Statement rausgebracht, wo er sagt,
mittlerweile kriegt er überhaupt gar keinen Slop mehr, sondern er kriegt extrem
akkurate Ergebnisse tatsächlich.
Also die AI ist jetzt innerhalb von den sechs, sieben, acht Monaten von dem Zeitraum,
sagen wir mal im Jahr, so viel besser geworden, dass jetzt mittlerweile also
wirklich richtig korrekte Fehler geliefert werden und nicht mehr diese ganzen Fake-Fehler.
also auch da zack wieder mal so eine Qualitäts Hürde genommen ähm.
Jetzt weiß ich nicht ganz genau, ob das jetzt wieder dafür zuführt,
dass er den Bugbau die aussetzt.
Wahrscheinlich erstmal nicht. Aber das zeigt, dass hier einiges passiert.
Und die Frage ist ja eher, wie geht jetzt das Rennen aus? Also wenn wir diese
Analyse-Sachen haben, dann wird es ja auch bedeuten und es wird sehr viel Code erzeugt derzeit.
Also man sieht das bei GitHub, gehen die Commit-Zahlen durch die Decke,
das Dreifache, was normalerweise reinkommt, wird mittlerweile an Code abgeworfen,
da ist vollkommen klar, was da der Grund ist.
und ich war ja gerade da in Malaga auf der Elixier-Conf und da gab es dann ganz
zum Schluss auch nochmal die Frage in den Raum, so, wer von euch benutzt denn
irgendwie AI-Tools, um Code zu erzeugen?
Alle Hände oben, ja, und dann ging das so hoch, ja, wer macht 20% seines Codes damit so, ne.
30, 40, 50, ich sagte ja auch, bei 80% war immer noch ein ziemlicher Wald im
Raum und auch wenn das irgendwie ein bisschen merkwürdig wirkte.
Es gab viel Diskussionen darüber und es wurde viel darüber geredet und so fast
in jedem Vortrag wurde irgendwie so Claude, mein Freund, erwähnt sozusagen.
Ja, dann habe ich mich mal mit Claude unterhalten und all diese ganzen Sachen.
Und das ist, das kann man jetzt irgendwie als scary ansehen.
Auf der anderen Seite, es ist jetzt halt einfach auch.
Das Programmieren ändert sich. Wir haben jetzt die Fähigkeit in den Computern,
dieses reine Codeschreiben zu automatisieren und du konzentrierst dich auf dein Design.
Und das bedeutet natürlich auch, dass in zunehmendem Maße diese Fähigkeiten,
Sicherheitslücken zu erkennen, bedeutet ja auch, es gibt die Fähigkeit,
diese Sicherheitslücken zu vermeiden.
Ja.
Und das könnte bedeuten, dass besserer Code entsteht, der halt safer ist.
Das habe ich...
Ich sag mal Wettrüsten.
Also da hatte ich ein, fand ich, sehr surreales Erlebnis hier bei Metrovis,
was ich ja jetzt echt vor ein paar Wochen erst gebaut habe. Auf dem aktuellsten
Gemini 3.1 Querstrich ChatGPT 5.5 Modell.
Also schon die beiden besten, die es derzeit gab.
Ja, genau. JTBD ist bei 5.5. Ich habe vorhin Gemini 5.5 gesagt.
No, nee, Gemini 3.1 soll jetzt wohl zur Google-Konferenz des 3.2er kommen.
Was wieder alles wahnsinnig episch.
Und das war ja ein ziemlicher One-Shot, hatte ich ja erzählt.
Also lange Planung reingegeben.
Das heißt also, man investiert jetzt in die Planungsphase und das eigentlich
implementieren geht dann ziemlich One-Shot-mäßig.
So, und als das Ganze dann so einigermaßen rund war, habe ich dann mal den Prompt abgesetzt.
So, jetzt mach doch mal so einen Security-Audit. such doch mal so die zehngängigsten
Security-Floors, die da so drin sind und Angriffsvektoren, wenn ich das Ganze
jetzt mal einfach so auf GitHub ablade. Ja, mache ich sofort. Gucken wir mal.
Oh mein Gott, das ist ja offen wie ein Scheunentor.
Jeder kann mit einer modifizierten URL direkt JavaScript im Browser aus.
Das geht so gar nicht, Ralf.
Ey, du Arsch, wer hat das gecodet?
So, und dann habe ich in der Tat, kann man sich den Code angucken in den Commits.
Eine Stunde investiert auch mit verschiedenen Modellen, das finde ich dann auch
hilfreich, nacheinander verschiedene Modelle drauf zu werfen,
so guck mal ob denn das jetzt wirklich alles Sound ist.
Um das denn dann auch mal alles einigermaßen wasserdicht hinzubekommen,
trotz eigentlich ja keinem Schreibzugriff, aber Abhängigkeiten bestehen.
Aber dass das nicht out of the box jetzt im April 2026 schon auch beispielsweise
in Cursor implementiert ist, die ja viel mit Metapromps im Hintergrund irgendwie
arbeiten, ist mir völlig schleierhaft.
Das heißt also, dass dann eben wirklich noch, obwohl ich schon einen vernünftigen
Softwareplan, da hatte ich jetzt nicht reingeschrieben und berücksichtige bloß
alle gängigen Sicherheitsstandards, also würde ich ab jetzt in der Tat auch
in den Plan reinschreiben,
aber dass die Systeme noch nicht so schlau in Anführungszeichen sind,
dort überhaupt schon mal eine Grundebene von Security reinzugeben,
finde ich schon schrill.
Und das klingen wirklich super basale Geschichten wie Inputfelder,
die keine Sanitization irgendwie hatten, sondern du konntest da halt sonst was
irgendwie reinkloppen.
Also ja gut, aber da weiß man halt auch so, was so die völlig idiotischen Einfallstore sind.
Sanitization immer bei der Ausgabe.
Ja, ich glaube es ist jetzt sowohl ein als auch Ausgabe.
Weil erst wenn du weißt, in welchem Kontext der Content tatsächlich ausgespielt
wird, kannst du auch so sanitisen, dass er nicht zu Problemen führt.
Ja, aber ich war ein bisschen ratlos.
Also wir müssen glaube ich mal Michi mal einladen, da habe ich mich schon viel drüber unterhalten.
Also mittlerweile erlauben ja die Tools auch sowas wie Sub-Agents,
die man definieren kann und zu einer guten Code-Planung gehört dann eben auch dazu,
dass man so ein Code-Review-Stage drin hat.
so dieses reine Code erzeugen ist halt nicht alles.
Refactoring kann man später machen, aber erstmal geht es ja darum,
das Code wird zwar erzeugt, aber da ist nicht unbedingt alles berücksichtigt,
sondern man muss dann halt einfach eine nachgelagerte Stufe haben,
die dann sagt so, ja okay, neuer Code, schön und gut, aber da wollen wir nochmal
folgendes sicherstellen.
Das ist ja nicht nur Security, das ist ja dann auch Coding-Style,
sonstige Rahmenbedingungen, die hier vielleicht gelten, Beschränkungen in Bezug
auf Performance, Beschränkungen in Bezug auf Speicherbedarf oder was auch immer.
Also da gibt es so viele Bedingungen, die kannst du unmöglich alle in das Modell stecken.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass wir in einem schon an diesem Wundermodus angekommen sind mit.
Erzeuge nicht nur Code, sondern erzeuge Code, der direkt vom Himmel herabsteigt sozusagen.
Und die reine puritanische Maximalität darstellt.
So rein, wie nur irgendwas ist. Keine Fehler im Ablauf, keine Fehler im Punkt auf Security.
Sieht auch noch wunderbar aus und ist in jeder Hinsicht perfekt.
Da sind wir noch nicht, da werden wir vielleicht nochmal hinkommen,
aber ich glaube, es ist trotzdem schon noch eine ganze Menge Prompt-Engineering,
da ist das Wort wieder erforderlich, um so ein System zusammenzubauen.
Es ist nicht nur das Formulieren, was hätte ich denn gerne, sondern es ist eben
schon auch so die Awareness mit, was ist die richtige Architektur,
in welchem Kontext laufen wir und so weiter.
Ja, vor allen Dingen dieser Effekt, wenn, ja, das ist fast genauso,
wie ich es haben will, aber mach mal das noch anders und dann dreht er sich
um und reißt meinem Arsch alles ein.
Und dann denkst du so, boah, ey, das weiß jetzt wirklich nicht, was ich haben wollte.
Ja, also wenn ich jetzt Cursor wäre, würde ich Security da schon so ein bisschen höher.
Die haben jetzt vor ein paar Tagen, ich weiß nicht, ob du auch dieses Pop-Up
hattest, haben die irgendwie so ein Security-Layer plötzlich bei sich irgendwie
announced, dass man quasi wieder so einen neuen Agent, der auf Security optimiert
ist, irgendwie mit dazuschalten könnte.
Innerhalb von Cursor, ist das so eine dieser Cursor-Info-Pop-Ups hochgekommen.
Habe ich mir auch nicht im Detail angeguckt.
Also ich muss sagen, bei Curler komme ich mittlerweile nicht mehr mit,
mit den ganzen Changes. Also da...
Dass die von Musk gekauft werden, hatten wir das eigentlich schon besprochen?
Nein, aber also bei jedem dritten...
Update, stellen sie mir wieder irgendeine ganz generelle und jetzt kannst du
auch noch das machen und alles ist anders und jetzt hast du hier irgendwie nochmal
ein super Agent Overview und dann mach auch noch alles in der Cloud und Multistage
und maximal parallel und schmeiß dein Geld in unsere Richtung.
Ja, also umso mehr Tokens du verbrauchst, umso ein besserer Mensch bist du.
Ja, das ist, also man hat das Gefühl, das beschleunigt sich alles immer weiter.
Wir gehen auf die Singularity immer schneller hin, die da heißt Platzen der AID-Blase.
Also Ja, aber jetzt können so Menschen wie Ralf und ich,
die keine Lust haben hauptamtliche Programmierer zu sein und die sozusagen unter
industriellen Bedingungen Code erzeugen sondern die eigentlich immer nur so Ideen haben mit,
ach das wäre mal schön wenn es das gäbe, so das baut mir nie einer,
weder freiwillig noch könnte ich das Geld dafür aufbringen dass man jetzt mit einem sehr,
vertretbaren finanziellen Aufwand da sehr schnell zu sehr guten Ergebnissen
kommt und das finde ich eigentlich toll.
Ja, unter industriellen Bedingungen Codeschreiben ist eine schöne Art und Weise,
die das ausdrückt, wie das tatsächlich
abläuft, wenn man sowas hauptberuflich tut und vor allen Dingen,
Also in dem Team, in dem ich arbeite, also es ist ja nicht wirklich ein Team,
sondern nur ein Chapter, wie man heutzutage so schön sagt.
Ein Chapter.
Ja, das nennt sich Matrix-Organisation. Es ist also ohne zu weit in die Tiefe zu gehen.
Stell dir vor, Teams sind Spalten und ein Team besteht immer aus einer Produktperson
und einem Backend-Entwickler und einem
Frontend-Entwickler und einem Android-Entwickler, einem iOS-Entwickler,
einem Analysten und noch einem Grafikdesigner oder UX-Spezialisten oder wie
auch immer, wenn das ein Team ist.
Die kümmern sich für ein Feature oder einen Bereich.
Dann hast du in der Waagerechten, in der Zeile hast du dann zum Beispiel alle iOS-Entwickler.
Und diese Waagerechte nennt man Chapter in diesem Aufbau.
Also du bist sowohl in einem Chapter als auch in einem Team.
Genau. Und das ist so, du bist dann ein singulärer Schnittpunkt von diesen,
naja nicht unbedingt, aber also unser Chapter iOS hat halt 14 Leute oder so,
14, 15 Leute, ich kann es jetzt nicht genau sagen.
und in dem Team, wo es sowieso schon schwierig genug ist, weil Feature-Teams
versuchen, ihre Feature möglichst reibungsfrei in die App reinzukriegen,
ohne auf Widerstände zu laufen.
Und dann gibt es natürlich unterschiedliche
Kenntnis-, Wissens- und Fähigkeitsstandards und so weiter.
Da macht das mit diesem ... Und jetzt sind die Leute, die am wenigsten wissen,
was sie tun und die wenigsten Hemmungen haben,
möglichst viel Code mit AI zu erzeugen, halt auch die meisten Probleme,
wenn ich mal so sagen darf.
Also wenn du Code erzeugst und keine Ahnung hast, ob bei was taugt oder nicht,
dann ist es schon schwierig.
Irgendwie, wenn du alle zwei Wochen releast und irgendwie...
Eine Million User oder was wir da haben, davon abhängig sind,
dass das Teil nicht beim Starten abraucht.
Das ist schon ein anderes Play-in-Field, als wenn ich mich halt hobbymäßig abends
hinsetze und ein paar Zeilen Codes mir ausspucken lasse.
Insofern gibt es da halt viele, die da sehr mit Sorgen drauf gucken,
dass wie ich bereits meinte, Also je weniger Erfahrung die Leute haben,
desto mehr Code scheinen sie mitzuschreiben mit KI.
Und das ist einfach mal nicht nachhaltig, weil gerade wenn du halt sowas wie
Pull-Request-Reviews machst, also sprich jede Änderung, die eingepflegt werden
soll, sollen halt Leute drüber gucken.
Und die AI hat so diese...
Diese Eigenart, Code zu schreiben, der unheimlich sauber aussieht,
aber dann teilweise trotzdem Unsinn tut.
Und man hat so nicht mehr diese wahren Dinge wie, was tut der da?
Wieso schreibt er diesen Code? Sondern auch, das sieht ja eigentlich alles ganz
gut aus. Ganz manierlich aus. Und plötzlich hast du komische Fehler.
Also das ist so, wir sind da noch nicht, wo wir sein wollen, sag ich mal.
Komische Fehler, aber mal einen schönen Live-Moment produzieren.
Ich habe jetzt hier in den Chat reingeworfen, das was ich eben gesagt habe,
dieses neue Cursor-Modul für Sicherheitsprüfung und Security vom 30.04.
und direkt als erstes ist da ein Link Cursor-Sicherheitsprüfung mit weiteren
Informationen. Klickt doch mal diesen Link an.
This page could not be found.
Kommen Sie auf eine 404-Seite.
Sehr schön.
Die Seite ist zum Thema Security und Stabilität und Vulnerability und ist mal
gerade irgendwie zwei Wochen alt.
Naja, es ist aber Security, es ist nicht Functionality.
Ja, es schmerzt.
Eine Seite, die nicht lädt, ist relativ sicher.
Ja, also wie war die Geschichte? Elon Musk hat sich irgendwie Aktienanteile
an Cursor gesichert und Optionen, die verkaufen für wie viel?
400 Milliarden, keine Ahnung, absurde Summe.
Genau, Sie haben sich die Option erkauft...
Cursor zu kaufen. Und ich weiß nicht, was das soll.
Also warum kaufen sie sie nicht einfach? Also warum kauft man sich eine Option zu kaufen?
Und warum lässt sich Cursor von denen kaufen?
Also ausgerechnet von denen, die einzigen sind, die irgendwie mit dem ganzen
AI-Scheiß nix auf die Kette kriegen?
Da ist your answer.
Ja gut, aber ich meine Cursor ist ja schon eher so ein Juwel eigentlich.
Also es hat ja, gut, ihre eigenen Modelle sind gar nicht schlecht.
Die sie auch gebaut haben, ob Maske hinter denen her ist, keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber du verkaufst ja nicht an denen, der dich sowieso nicht haben will,
weil er eh die bessere Technologie hat.
Du verkaufst ja an jemanden, der ganz genau das, was du hast,
braucht und zwar sehr dringend, sodass er sehr, sehr viel Geld dafür ausgibt.
Ja, ich glaube, dass Cursor eigentlich für alle sehr wertvoll ist.
Ja, ist es das?
Ja, na klar, weil Cursor natürlich so eine totale Einstiegsebene ist,
so ein User-Interface für AI, für Programmierer.
Also ich meine, das ist schon gut, man kann jetzt klagen über das eine oder
andere und dass es irgendwie langsam ist oder was weiß ich, aber es ist wirklich,
es wird seit, wir besprechen das jetzt hier seit einem Jahr oder so oder anderthalb Jahr,
zwei Jahre arbeite ich jetzt damit und das wird einfach jede Woche, besser, immer besser.
Naja, ich benutze halt Cloud Code, direkt auf der Kommandozeile.
Ja.
Und das tut halt Dinge.
Ja, hast du aber auch nur eben die Cloud-Modelle. Also was ich wirklich doch
gerne mache, ist einfach Modelle
wechseln und gucken, so wie verhalten die sich auch so als Experiment.
Und ich meine das halt auch nicht nur für Coding, sondern eben auch für alle
anderen möglichen Experimente, wo es darum geht, so jetzt arbeite mal auf diesen zehn Dateien.
Und das jetzt mal auch über einen längeren Zeitraum und schreib mal ein neues Markdown dazu und so.
Und das möchte ich dann eben auch mit unterschiedlichen Modellen können.
Da suche ich jetzt auch wirklich ernsthaft Open-Source-Alternativen zu Cursor.
Und das eine oder andere ist ja
schon hochgepoppt, wo ich dann auch lokale Engines reinhängen kann, LMS.
Also nicht zu Cursor, sondern zu den Modellen.
Auf der anderen Seite bezahlt halt die Firma Rechner. Nee, auch zu Cursor selber.
Weil wenn Musklas kauft, dann will ich da nicht mehr meine Griffe dran haben.
Noch sind wir ja nicht so weit.
Aber da will ich vorbereitet sein.
Wenn, dann ist es zu spät, wenn die Panik um sich bringt.
Ja, vielleicht kauft es auch kein anderer, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Vielleicht wollen die die Besitzer aussteigen mit einem dicken,
dicken, sehr goldenen, großen Falscher.
Zu einem besseren Zeitpunkt habt ihr auch schon alle eure Allbirds Schuhe verbrannt,
rituell. Habt ihr das mitgekriegt?
Ich weiß nicht, wer Allbirds ist.
Halte jetzt mal meine Schuhe auf die Meta-Ebene. Ihr kennt diese Schuhe hier?
Nein, nein.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Gut, dann sucht, macht doch mal Allbirds, eine Websuche.
Ist das jetzt relevant oder wollen wir bei diesem Thema bleiben?
Das ist das Thema. Believe me.
Ach, ist das die Firma, die von Schuhen jetzt auf AI umsteigt?
Genau.
Weil, keine Ahnung.
Weil, keine Ahnung. Also, was sind Allbirds? Allbirds sind so die Silicon Valley Schuhe.
Ach so, echt? Allbirds.
Und deswegen hast du dir die gekauft?
Natürlich, ne? Prenzlauer Berg, da muss man sowas schon haben.
So, das ist aber ehrlich gesagt, kannst du die eigentlich nur noch ironisch tragen?
Also, irgendwie angesagt waren die so vor acht Jahren. So, da fing das an im Silicon Valley.
Okay, ich habe nichts mitbekommen, aber das hat nichts zu sagen.
Das ist das wichtige IT-Light, die anhatten und die sind schon insofern ganz
cool, weil dieses Grundmodell ist einfach mal so aus Wolle,
das heißt sie sind irre leicht und sind so schöne Übergangs,
ja das sind jetzt alles schon so mit,
was er hier durchscrollt, das sind alles jetzt schon so Ableger-Modelle,
also der ganz klassische All-Birds-Shoe ist genau der, den ich hier trage, graue.
Also Filzpantoffel im Sneaker-Style.
Genau, im Sneaker-Style.
Filzpantoffel im Sneaker-Style.
Das sieht doch so aus, oder nicht?
Hat ein schönes Flussklima, ist gut für den Übergang.
So, und sie sind jetzt schon seit Jahren so ein bisschen auf dem Absteigenden,
haben irre viel diversifiziert, so machen ganz viele verschiedene Modelle halt
mittlerweile auch nicht mehr nur mit Wolle.
und sind jetzt verkauft worden für ein paar Dutzend Millionen und hatten aber
vor zwei Jahren noch irgendwie einen Börsenwert von ein paar Milliarden, glaube ich sogar.
Und das gilt als so der größte Drop in Sachen Börsenwert, Firmenwert,
den man seit sehr langer Zeit gesehen hat.
Und die Gründer, die also Öko-Börsen,
Wollschuhe gemacht haben, machen jetzt als neues Feld so, ach das mit den Schuhen
lassen wir jetzt übrigens bleiben, wir machen jetzt AI.
So weil because we can.
Okay, na gut, dann macht halt jetzt mal AI.
Also die Schuhe sind jetzt verkauft worden an irgendeine andere Schuhbude und
werden jetzt also mit Sicherheit den Weg der Entgertification gehen und dann wird man sehen.
An wen sind sie denn verkauft worden?
Ja, ich guck mal eben, wer das war.
Na gut, ist vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig.
Also interessant ist, sich den Börsengraphen anzugucken, das ist wirklich fein.
Ah, Schuh und AI ist doch quasi das Gleiche.
Eben. Das schon.
Oh Mann. Irgendwie droppen die Leute hier Gießwein in den Chat. Hat das was damit zu tun?
So, also Allbirds war mal auf 560 Dollar pro Aktie und verkauft worden sind sie für 5,14 Dollar.
Ja, nun, also Faktor 100.
Mal eben so in den Sand gesetzt. Minus 99,01 Prozent Börsenwert.
Das muss man auch echt mal schaffen.
Ich werfe mal den Graphen hier rein.
Was nur wieder beweist, dass der Börsenwert eigentlich nicht so richtig viel aussagt.
Nein, das sagt er auch nicht.
Also solange du die Aktie nicht zu dem Preisverkauf bekommen hast,
hast du nichts gewonnen.
Genau, in ihrem Peak waren sie vier Milliarden wert.
Überdefiniere überbewertet.
Also vier Milliarden und wurden verkauft für 40 Millionen.
Du weißt, was ich jetzt für einen Kapitelmarken-Stress habe mit dieser D-Tour.
Bleiben wir nochmal kurz beim Code. Also hier wird ja auch im Chat zu Recht
auf OpenCode hingewiesen.
Das ist ja so ein Frontend für
alle möglichen Modelle, was du dann eben benutzen kannst wie CloudCode.
Also das ist jetzt quasi nicht mit User-Interface, aber halt als Cloud-Code-Alternative
oder Codex-Alternative.
Ja.
Ist Open-Source. Habe ich nicht benutzt. Ich bin halt noch voll im Cursor-Modus,
weil ich halt das praktisch finde.
Ja, ja, nun.
Haben wir noch Nennenswertes beizutragen zu diesem AI-Thema gerade?
Also ich kann nur sagen, dass ich mich inzwischen zu alt fühle,
um den ganzen Trends hinterher zu hecheln, aber dafür haben wir ja Ralf, insofern ist das okay.
Ich hechle den Trends ja auch noch hinterher.
Gut, dann mach dir das mal.
Ich versuche zumindest auf...
Augenhöhe zu bleiben. Es ist schwierig. Man muss da auch schon viel Zeit und
Experiment reinstecken und bisweilen eben auch Geld.
Aber noch lohnt sich es für mich halt alles sehr, weil die Ergebnisse sind halt da.
Also ich kann halt wirklich endlich mal wieder meine eigene Software machen.
Ich mache noch viel zu wenig.
Ich habe noch ein paar Sachen vor. Mal gucken, ob ich da im Sommer dazu komme.
Ja, meine Pile of Shame ist auch groß.
Damit wir dann hier auch mal die Freakshow mal ein bisschen besser automatisiert
bekommen haben in verschiedenen Bereichen.
Ich bitte darum.
Also wenn im Sommer nichts mehr funktioniert, dann...
Ich war vor drei Wochen bei Max Planck eingeladen, Max Planck Gesellschaft und
hab da eine launige Keynote gehalten.
Das ist so ein bisschen so State of the AI Union ausgeartet.
Die hab ich aber noch nicht fertig geschrieben, wo ich mal so einen Grundaufriss
mache, so wie ich jetzt so die aktuellen Trends, die jetzt eben aber seit zwei
Jahren schon eigentlich immer dieselben sind, einschätze.
Hast du da auch ein MacBook aus dem Briefumschlag rausgezogen?
Da habe ich keinen MacBook aus dem Briefumschlag gewollt. Das nicht.
Aber wenn ich das mal fertiggestellt habe, dann kann ich das hier nochmal mitbringen in die Sendung.
Okay.
Gut. Ralf, du hast ja noch andere Themen am Start.
Ich habe noch Themen. Genau. Wir hatten ja vorhin diese Motorräder.
Und besser, man fährt auch gleich Fahrrad. Und es gibt wieder neue Entwicklungen Ist.
Dir wieder eins geklaut worden?
Im Fahrradbusiness. Ich habe ja zwei Kids und der Größe wird natürlich immer
größer und braucht ein neues Fahrrad und dann verkauft man das.
Der Kleine wird nicht immer größer?
Der Kleine wird zum Glück auch immer größer, aber der übernimmt dann ja immer
die abgelegten Fahrräder des Großen.
Das kleine Bruderproblem.
Ja, er freut sich trotzdem und macht da gar keinen Stress und so.
Da haben wir im Moment noch Glück, dass sie das mit zweieinhalb Jahren Abstand
noch ganz gut auseinanderziseliert kriegen. So, ich dann aber dann das quasi kleinste...
Dann von dem Kleinen abgelegte dann verkauft und netter Mensch und so ein bisschen
irgendwie ins Reden gekommen,
was ihm dann noch so alles ins Haus steht, wenn dann seiner mal größer ist und
dann wollte ich dann stolz das neue Fahrrad vom Großen ihm kurz zeigen,
worauf er sich dann schon mal freuen kann, sowas kommt dann auch irgendwann
und dann war das dann nicht mehr im Innenhof.
Da dachte ich so, wo ist denn das neu gekaufte Fahrrad eigentlich hin?
Das war mal gerade irgendwie so vier Wochen alt. Also.
Du hast dir tatsächlich mal wieder ein Fahrrad.
Klauen lassen Also natürlich mal wieder Where is my Find my angeworfen,
Und dann stellt sich fest das Fahrrad ist irgendwo in Neukölln Da gehört es aber nicht so hin,
Alter Und natürlich wieder Samstagabend Es war ein recht teures Schloss dran
Das war jetzt also kein Billo-Schloss-Fahrrad.
10% des Fahrradwertes hat man früher mal gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch gilt.
Das würde ich sagen, gilt immer noch. Und das war so knapp erreicht.
Knapp, aber war erreicht. Also die Größenordnung stimmte schon.
Aber, und das mag jetzt einfach ein Konstruktionsprinzip sein,
von dem ich jetzt mal weg muss, das ist das Zahlenschloss.
Weil auch der Große mit Schlüsseln irgendwie immer schlecht hantiert.
Und es gibt noch wertige Zahlenschlösser, aber nicht mehr sonderlich viele.
und offensichtlich Zahlenschluss.
Ja, mit Zahlenkombinationen, so zum Drehen.
Da kriege ich ja direkt. Aber gut.
So, also in den Tests schneiden die nicht unbedingt signifikant schlechter ab,
aber so in der Preisklasse ähm,
Und zeselierte sich dann doch irgendwann mal so ein bisschen aus.
Naja und dann klassischer Ablauf, es war natürlich jetzt irgendwie dann schon
wieder Samstagabend, aber ich dachte okay, wenn, dann musst du jetzt halt direkt hinfahren.
Es gab eine sehr saubere Punktorto, das heißt also nicht so ein diffuses ja
irgendwo hier im Umkreis von zwei Kilometern, sondern es war schon sehr konkret
wieder ein Gebäudekomplex.
Und dann habe ich mich halt wieder ins Auto gesetzt und bin dem Fahrrad hinterher gefahren.
Hast du vielleicht überlegt, mal ein Zahlenschloss zu nehmen mit einem babylonischen
Zahlensystem? Dann bringt die vielleicht durch Erinnerung.
Ne, wir haben jetzt auch Reste von dem Schloss dann im Hinterhof gefunden.
Das war so richtig auseinandergesetzt.
Es sah nicht aufgeflext aus, sondern
das war, glaube ich, mit Brute Force auseinandergebrochen. So an den...
Wagenheber.
Irgendso was in der Richtung.
Für ein Kinderfahrrad.
Ein Kinderfahrrad. Naja, wobei, das war jetzt schon nicht mehr wirklich ein
Kinderfahrrad, sondern das ist jetzt schon ein kleines Erwachsenenfahrrad eigentlich.
Das war glaube ich sogar schon 28 Zoll Reifen.
Das ist kein Kinderfahrrad mehr.
Also der Rahmen ist dann noch relativ klein von der Geometrie her,
aber die Reifen relativ groß.
Alter.
So und mittlerweile bin ich ja Profi. Du musst halt gucken, okay,
wie sehen denn da die Häuser vor Ort aus?
Dafür hast du natürlich dann in Google Maps Berlin 3D-Ansicht.
Kannst gleich gucken, wie viele Stockwerke, wie viele Parteien,
wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Wenn es nicht ausgegraut ist.
In Berlin ist eigentlich nichts ausgegraut.
Oder? Das ist klar, hier logisch, in dieser Straße.
Echt?
Ja, ja.
Ja, Street View, aber nicht hier die 3D-Overfall.
Ach so, das meinst du.
Das reicht ja, um schon mal zu sehen, so wie es... So, und erst habe ich mich
gefreut, weil das eine relativ dünn besiedelte Ecke zu sein schien,
aber dann war es dann eben doch ein achtstöckiges, relativ hohes,
weit jenseits der Berliner Traufhöhe sich befindendes Vielparteien-Ding-Sie.
Aber ich dachte, gut, jeden Fall muss da jetzt.
Muss ja gucken, was da los ist. Naja, und das war dann auch schon so eine,
Ein bisschen Rough Neighborhood. Also sicherlich noch nicht die wildeste Ecke
von Neukölln, aber da war mir jetzt nicht dran gelegen, da jetzt Großtherz und
Theater zu machen, sondern verhalten sich eher unauffällig.
Da gingen also schon so etliche Gangs so rum.
Und ich hatte dann aber sehr schnell eine wirklich sehr, sehr saubere Ortung. Im Sinne von, dass...
Mit Höhe? Mit Höhe?
Mit Höhe nicht, aber... mit, so Achtung, sie sind noch weit weg,
verändern sie ihren Standpunkt, so Achtung, sie sind 8 Meter dran.
Achso, du hast das, war das ein neues Airtag?
Ne, das war in Alter noch, weil ich hab dann die durchrotiert,
also ich hab neue mir gekauft und an unsere teuren Fahrräder sind die neuen
dran und an die Kinderfahrräder hab ich dann abgelegt und durchrotiert,
hat aber gereicht, also es war ein altes,
aber der wurde gut gefunden und die Ortung war dann so gut, dass er dann sogar
schon in diesem grünen Nahfeldbereich, so, Achtung, noch vier Meter reingekommen ist.
Stand direkt hinter der Tür sozusagen.
Und da dachte ich, okay, das ist jetzt schon mal gut, jetzt rufen wir mal die
Polizei an, dass die doch mal wen vorbeischicken.
Da willst du dann nicht selber an der Tür klingeln und sagen,
hallo, ich hab hier so ein iPhone, lassen Sie mich mal in Ihre Wohnung rein.
Ich also wieder Polizei angerufen und die kennen sich da mittlerweile auch aus
und sind auch nicht überrascht.
Also zum ersten Mal vor ein paar Jahren Musste man da erstmal viel erklären
und was haben sie da für Technik und so und ist das überhaupt legal und mittlerweile
wissen die, was Phase ist und auch schon gesagt, ich habe eine Nahfeldordnung,
es ist hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie Erfolg haben, das lohnt sich die Fahrt.
Und da habe ich noch ein bisschen geguckt, weil ich das schon fast auffällig
fand, dass das so durch irgendwie Stahlbeton so eine Ortung hatte.
Also dahinter war, ich habe dann schon gesehen, noch so ein Kellerbereich.
Dann habe ich gesehen, okay, da ist im ersten OG auch wirklich ein Balkon und
auf diesem Balkon stehen zwei Fahrräder drauf.
Das war ganz schön duster, aber moderne Technik.
Ich also iPhone so hoch gehalten wie irgendwie möglich, Langzeitbelichtung gemacht
und dann kriegst du ein Bild grau in grau.
Aber wenn du dann in der Apple-Foto-App mal wirklich den Kontrast hochziehst
und die Helligkeit auf Maximum boostest, hast du dann gesehen,
okay, es ist exakt die grüne Farbe von dem Fahrrad. Wie ist denn wohl wahr?
Dieses Ding steht einfach mal auf dem Balkon drauf.
Wie konntest du den Balkon sehen? Also wie muss man sich jetzt deine Position in diesem Gebäude...
Naja, es war halt Erdgeschoss so und der Balkon zeigte quasi nach vorne zur
Eingangstür dieses Hochhauskomplexes.
Das war so quasi an der Vorderseite.
Also war es gar nicht im Haus, jetzt im Flur oder so? Nee, vorm Haus.
Also ich bin mal ins Haus rein, weil die Tür auch gar nicht abgeschlossen war, sondern so angelehnt.
Weil erster Weg wäre so in den Keller gewesen, um zu gucken,
ob es da halt irgendwo im Verschlag steht oder sowas. Aber da kann man alles nicht rein.
Und dann dachte ich, okay, das nochmal drüber.
In anderen Worten, es sah jetzt so aus, als ob das Fahrrad, was dir geklaut
wurde, tatsächlich da auf dem Balkon.
Dort auf dem Balkon steht.
Im Erdgeschoss stand und du warst nur drei, vier Meter davon entfernt.
Genau, aber jetzt irgendwie Balkon hochklettern und so, nee.
Alles nicht meins so, sondern da warten wir dann mal schön auf die Polizei.
Die kamen auch?
Die kamen dann auch. Die meinten dann schon am Telefonar, Samstagabend schon
ein bisschen was los, kann ein bisschen dauern.
Ungefähr 50 Minuten.
Das fand ich jetzt okay, weil er hatte auch gesagt, das Fahrrad wird ja jetzt
nicht wegrennen, wenn es da erstmal auf dem Balkon steht.
Wenn dort Bewegung ist, dann rufen sie einfach nochmal die Nummer an.
Wir haben sie hier mit Adresse und Vorgang, dann können wir das hoch priorisieren.
Bis dahin landen sie halt quasi in der normalen Kö.
Das fand ich jetzt auch okay. Ich war jetzt mal ersichtlich kein Notfall da für die.
Okay, das Fahrrad hat sich auch nicht bewegt.
Das Fahrrad hat sich nicht bewegt. Es waren offensichtlich Leute da, das ist schon mal gut,
weil ich erinnere an eines der Fahrräder, die wir nicht gekriegt hatten,
wo Claudia mit einer Nahfeldortung vor einer verschlossenen Tür stand,
aber dann das Chirpen nicht zu hören war durch die verschlossenen Türen und
dann Polizeibeamte gesagt haben, ist keiner da, macht keiner auf.
Aber du hast jetzt nicht probiert, ob es Töne macht.
Ich habe überlegt, ob ich es schirpen lasse und dachte, ah, dann hören die das
dann vielleicht doch drin und kommen auf Gedanken und.
Okay, die Option bestand sozusagen.
Die Option hätte bestanden, so. Aber da habe ich gesagt, jetzt ohne Not jetzt
nicht weiter eskalieren die Situation.
Naja, und dann kamen dann Polizeibeamten und wieder mal großes Glück.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die immer nur die wirklich netten Leute irgendwie auf dieser
Mission rausschicken, keine Ahnung. Aber es ist jetzt auch schon irgendwie die
vierte Truppe, die ich da kennengelernt habe.
Wieder sehr korrekt, sehr motiviert, total verständig.
Also da hatte ich auch echt immer Glück.
Und mit denen habe ich es dann chirpen lassen und hat in der Tat dann auch gechirpt.
Das war also auch durch. Ich habe die ja immer in den Klingeln drin.
Das ist nach wie vor, glaube ich, so der beste Spot.
Und dann war für die also auch die Lage klar. Dann holen die sich also dann
einen ad hoc Durchsuchungsbefehl über Telefon.
Das dauert dann irgendwie so Vorgang fünf Minuten.
Und mit Chirpen ist das dann also auch für die völlig safe. Dann kann denen
auch nichts passieren. und dann sind sie dann da rein und haben so,
sie warten aber mal schön hier unten.
Da war ich dann auch schon mal ganz dankbar drum.
Wichtig ist halt, du musst dann dein ganzes Paperwork schon dabei haben,
aber ich mittlerweile Vollprofi, da hat es ja natürlich in die Rechnung hier
schon, Rahmennummer, hier, da ist das Bild.
Kaufvertrag.
So sieht es aus.
Du machst Geocaching mit Fahrrädern.
Oder? Wo ich auch glaubte, so ein leichtes Augenbrauenzucken bei denen zu sehen.
Sagt im Motto, der ist aber ziemlich abgezockt hier mittlerweile.
Könnte er vielleicht seine Fahrräder einfach mal in den Keller stellen,
dann statt er sich im Wochentakt klauen und wieder herholen zu lassen.
Ja, aber wirklich, es wirkt so, als würdest du Fahrräder eigentlich nur noch
klauen, um irgendwie so Safari zu machen. mit. Oh Mann.
Naja, und ich dann halt unten gestanden und dann also danach verfolgt,
es dauerte noch alles relativ lange, aber irgendwann ging also dann die Debatte los.
Was heißt relativ lange?
Ich würde sagen so mindestens fünf Minuten wurde irgendwie eine anfangs...
Die fünf Minuten, ab dem sie da reingegangen sind.
Ja, bis sie offensichtlich in die Wohnung irgendwie reinkam oder sich jemand gemeldet hat oder so.
Achso.
Passierte also relativ lange nichts, bis dann also dann wirklich dann auch irgendwann
Stimmen zu hören waren und eine offensichtlich Frau dann in sehr gebrochenem
Englisch dann irgendwie anfing sich zu verteidigen so.
Nee, sie hatte keine Ahnung, was auf dem Balkon steht, da wird sie ja nie hingehen,
da wird nur ihr Mann hingehen auf dem Balkon.
Du konntest das alles hören.
Ich konnte das hören.
Weil die waren dann halt, die Tür stand halt auf und sie standen quasi schon
so halb auf dem Balkon und ich stand da halt unten so und konnte das Spektakel
also dann irgendwie mitverfolgen.
Ja und was ihr Mann da auf dem Balkon macht, das wüsste sie nicht.
So, der würde so viel ankaufen und verkaufen, das würde ihm alles nach Kenia
gehen, da hätte sie gar keine Ahnung. Das mag sogar stimmen.
Nach Kenia, alles klar.
Nach Kenia würde das immer alles gehen, was da auf dem Balkon ist.
Und da nie würde sie auf den Balkon gehen. Sie hätte keine Ahnung, was da stünde.
Naja, und richtig skurril war dann aber.
Hat dann doch ganz, ganz ordentlich gedauert, weil die halt auch dann ihre Standardprozedere
haben und Personalien aufnehmen und sowas.
Kann man sich ja vorstellen, das ist also nicht so komplett trivial, so ein Vorgang.
Am Ende habe ich dann da also da mein Fahrrad und durfte es dann nochmal schirpen lassen.
Da hat der Honk seinen Namen in schwarzem Edding oben quer auf das Fahrrad geschrieben.
Jetzt sagt ihr mir bitte, warum. So, ich zeige euch jetzt also das Bild,
damit ihr das wirklich einordnen könnt.
Das werde ich jetzt natürlich nicht posten hier, aber warum tut man sowas?
So, wir sehen also ein grünes Cube.
Aha, wir sehen...
Ja, mit schwarzem Edding auf einen Das war sein Name.
Ja.
Das war der Name.
Neon-gelben Rahmen, oder ist der Neon-Grün?
Vielleicht wollte er damit belegen, dass es seins ist.
Ja, ist ihm so mäßig gelungen, würde ich sagen. So, und an zwei Stellen auch.
Ja, aber so verschickt man das doch nicht nach Kenia, oder?
Ja, eben. Also, tja, also wenn irgendjemand da draußen Hinweise hat,
warum das nun genau passiert ist, weil das also irgendwie in den Kreisen der
Fahrradschieber irgendwie jetzt...
Vielleicht wollte er nicht, dass man es ihm klaut. Weiß ja, wie leicht das passieren kann.
So, und wie lange hat es dann gedauert, bis das Fahrrad dann wieder in deinen
Besitz gebracht wurde? Das wurde doch sicherlich erstmal erfasst.
Nee, nee, wenn du das Paperwork hast, geht das zackig.
Also vor Ort.
So, also die waren halt mit einer kleinen Wanne da und da haben sie dann hinten
auch irgendwie ihre Computersysteme, mit denen sie das alles vor Ort aufnehmen.
Da sind die also schon auf zack, was das angeht.
Also sie haben es nicht erstmal gewahrsam?
Nein, nein, nein. Du kriegst dann so einen Überlassungsvertrag, Urkunde,
was auch immer, die du unterschreiben musst, wo das dann alles nochmal irgendwie
zusammengefasst ist und deine Vorgangsnummer für Versicherung,
weil ich kann jetzt beispielsweise das kaputte Schloss halt jetzt bei der Versicherung
noch geltend machen, Fahrradversicherung habe ich natürlich.
Das dauert dann nochmal so eine Viertelstunde. Also von daher von festgestellt
Fahrrad ist geklaut bis ich hab's quasi wieder oben auf dem Dachgepäckträger zwei Stunden.
die ganze Aktion.
Geil.
Im Chat schreibt jemand, vielleicht damit man zuordnen kann,
wer das Geld erhält beim Verkauf in Afrika.
Tja, who knows.
Who knows. Wenn das alles zusammen in einen Container kommt.
Naja, und ich war eigentlich schon, hatte mich schon gefreut,
weil wir so lange keins mehr geklaut bekommen haben.
Aber so die Quote quasi Airtag versus Verbrecher ist es mittlerweile 3 zu 2.
So 3 Fahrräder zurückgekriegt, 2 nicht zurückgekriegt.
Du hast 5 Fünf Fahrräder dir klauen, ne? Fünf Blockchains, nein fünf Fahrräder.
Ich überlege gerade, wie viele Fahrräder wurden mir geklaut?
Wurde mir überhaupt schon mal eins geklaut?
Mir wurde noch nie ein Fahrrad klaut.
Also ich bin noch weit weg von der Göttingenquote, da wurden mir insgesamt sieben Fahrräder geklaut.
Wahnsinn, wie machst du das? Also das einzige, was mir je geklaut wurde,
war der Halter vom Fahrradschloss.
Ich hatte da so ein Plastikteil, was so ja nicht super stabil ist und als das
dann weg war und ich mal beim Hersteller nachgeguckt habe, ob man das nachkaufen
kann, weiß ich jetzt, warum Leute das klauen. Kann man nämlich nicht.
Aber gut, das Schloss habe ich auch nicht mehr, ist egal.
Das waren noch die alten Kryptonite-Zeiten, wo alle gesagt haben,
Kryptonite ist das einzige Fahrradschloss, das hilft.
Ich kann dem nicht widersprechen, weil bei mir hat es immer geholfen.
Habe ich an den großen dran, das New York, mit diesem gelben,
wirklich sehr, sehr wuchtige, sehr abschreckende.
Ist glaube ich jetzt nicht mehr so state of the art, also es gibt bessere,
aber die kosten auch gleich irgendwie 200, 300 Euro, dann ist das auch irgendwie alles wieder absurd.
Also ich muss jetzt wieder mein Schlossgame offensichtlich wieder eine Umdrehung
hochdrehen und jetzt doch so in die 80, 90 Euro.
Oder ihr seid schon fest eingeplant bei den Routen.
Ja, das mag leider auch sein, dass sie sich sagen, da in dem Hof,
da ist doch immer was zu holen, irgendjemand.
Tja, naja und du kriegst natürlich dann nie die dran, die es dann wirklich halt geklaut haben.
Also der wird das wirklich natürlich irgendwo geshoppt haben.
Wir können auch gar nicht mal genau sagen, wann, weil wir sind irgendwie anderthalb
Wochen einfach gar nicht gefahren damit.
Das heißt also auch jetzt irgendwie eine Engführung, wie lange das jetzt wo
irgendwie war oder stand.
Wir haben halt weder auf die Ortung geguckt, noch irgendwie in den Hof rein.
Also ich würde jetzt auf jeden Fall auf das neue Airtag umschalten.
Nicht, dass du es jetzt gebraucht hättest, aber bei der Klauquote.
Ja, was können die von der reinen Ortung her besser?
Höhere Reichweite, deutlich höhere Reichweite.
Ja, die sind besser zu orten und ich glaube, die funken auch weiter.
Sie können halt auch von diesem Netzwerk besser gefunden werden.
Ja, also du hast nachweislich höhere...
Die reine Ortung, sagst du, ist besser.
Ja, ich habe mir so einen, in was für Packen werden die immer verkauft?
Vierer Pack. Oder einzeln.
Ich habe jetzt zwei neue, zwei alte in den Rädern. So die Erwachsenenräder, die beiden neuen.
Kinderräder, die zwei alten. Da müssten überall die neuen rein.
Also ich wohne ja direkt neben einem Restaurant.
In Antons wahrscheinlich schon. Das Kleine ist nicht viel wert,
das Pukeso, das Letzte jetzt, aber das Neue, das ist schon ja.
Und, also das war mal ein Italiener, jetzt ist es ein Vietnameser,
aber das ist ja auch egal.
Die Leute, die da ins Restaurant gehen, die orten immer alle meine Sachen.
Ob die noch zu Hause sind, kann ich immer relativ zeitnah nachgucken.
Ach so.
Ja, weil die Leute mit ihren iPhones da ins Restaurant gehen und alle eigentlich
fast alle in Reichweite meiner AirTags sind.
Ja, aber die Frage, ich hatte es gerade eben gesagt, wie macht Ralf das Fest
am Rad, das ist in diesen Klingeln drin, in diesen Standard-Mini-Klingeln.
Da gibt es verschiedenste mittlerweile.
Ich fand bloß immer die Klingeln nicht so toll.
Das ist ja egal.
Wieso ist das egal?
Was hat noch eine richtige Klingel?
Naja, ich will nicht so eine Bing-Bing-Bing-Klingel haben, sondern es muss so
eine Kratching-Klingel sein.
Ja, geil sind eigentlich die Kuhglocken.
Ding Dong. Die finde ich ein bisschen aufträglich.
Nee, nicht Ding Dong, sondern okay, muss ich raussuchen.
Richtige Kuhglocke oder was?
So, also das Modell, was ich habe, ist von Airbell. Die kosten irgendwie so, ich glaube, 20 Euro.
Die Bärbel von Airbell hat gesagt.
Airbell Pro.
Neu, jetzt auch für Android.
Keine Airbell Air.
Ja, das ist so eine Ping-Klinge.
Obwohl die Ping-Klingeln eigentlich auch relativ gut.
Ich meine, das einzig Wahre sind natürlich Laufklingeln, die ja eigentlich nicht
erlaubt sind, aber sie helfen.
Also das sind diese Dynamo-mäßigen Klingeln, wo du ziehst und dann wird so ein
Rad mitsamt Klingel ans Vorderrad geklappt und dann klingelt die so lange,
wie sich das Vorderrad bewegt oder du halt gedrückt hältst.
Ja, also der Vorteil bei diesen Modellen hier, da gibt es jetzt auch nicht die einzigen Anbieter.
Ach, warte mal, hier ist gar kein, aber hä, warte mal, ist das jetzt nur eine Halterung?
Das ist nur die Hülle, also Hülle plus Klingel. So, und du kannst halt...
Klingt ja so, als ob das Ding selber Elektro-Klingel hat.
Genau, da siehst du den Aufbau. Da kommt einfach nur der und von außen siehst
du aber wirklich keinen Unterschied, weil es genau die Maße und Funktionen und
auch Klingelmechanismen von so einer klassischen kleinen Mini-Klingel halt hat.
Ach Gott, das ist Amazon. Ah, hier.
Gibt es noch in zwei Radien, je nachdem wie dick dein Lenker ist.
Also das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Da kann man nicht meckern. Durch diese Enclosure, also durch die Hülle ist das Chirpen halt leiser.
Das ist ja das, was dann Claudia auch so mit zum Verhängnis geworden ist.
Es ist schon, würde ich sagen, noch halb so laut, wenn es da drin ist.
Aber zumindest diese Nahfeldortung schien mir nicht beeinträchtigt,
weil die hat jetzt einfach dreimal super funktioniert.
Mit den alten wohlbemerkt. Neues haben sie mir noch nicht geklaut.
Hier, ich meinte eigentlich diese Klingel mit Q-Glocke.
Ein Freund von mir kam mit der an und da dachte ich so, die muss ich eigentlich auch haben.
Habe sie bei mir auf die Wunschliste gestellt und als sie irgendjemand mir mal
kaufen wollte, war die gerade nicht im Angebot.
Das ist natürlich schade. Jetzt fragen Alex, Q und Schmo alle drei dasselbe und alle drei richtig.
Durch einen Firmware-Update ist es seit einem Jahr so, dass die AirTags anfangen
rumzumeckern, wenn sie lange irgendwo standen, beispielsweise an dem Fahrrad
eben und dann bewegt werden.
Das war schon immer so.
Ganz am Anfang war das nicht so.
Ja, doch. Das war schon immer so.
Das war schon immer so.
Richtig?
Okay. So, das scheint sich bei den Dieben noch nicht rumgesprochen zu haben,
schlicht und ergreifend.
Ich habe das auch einem Polizeibeamten gefragt, bei meinem zweiten Wiederbekommenen,
das war im Nachbarhof, habe ich das ja plötzlich wieder gefunden,
so, wie kann man so blöd sein, das ist quasi irgendwie nur ein paar mehr.
Da meinte er, ja, das sind dann halt doch nicht so die Hellsten.
Hier, mach mal meinen Link auf. Das ist das, was ich mit Kuglocke meinte.
Nee, einen weiter, einen weiter oben.
Ja, die ist nicht allzu groß.
Das sieht aus wie eine echte, normale Kuhglocke.
Ja, bimmelt. Also sie ist nicht so groß wie eine Kuhglocke. Sieht man, dass man hier montiert?
Die bimmelt die ganze Zeit, wie eine Kuhglocke oder was?
Nee, du kannst die irgendwie,
diesen Klettverschluss so um die Glocke drum wickeln, dass sie dann nicht bimmelt.
Und wie bimmelst du dann mit der Glocke?
Nein, indem du den Klettverschluss abmachst. Aber du hast dann quasi ein ständiger,
ist dann mehr ein Beacon, dass du immer zu hören bist.
Ach, so wirklich die ganze Zeit so?
Ja, ja, Bimmel, Bimmel.
Moorcaubel.
Genau, Moorcaubel. Auch am Fahrrad.
Okay, gut. Schöne Ablenkung. Tatsächlich gibt es von diesem Airbell,
wo wir gerade da sind, eine Pro-Variante,
wo das AirTag quasi mit, also wo kein AirTag drin ist, sondern wo das Ding selber
ein Find-My-Device ist.
Ah, okay.
Das heißt, da ist dann auch die Frage, wie sich das verhält.
weil es ist ja dann kein airtag das heißt es könnte ganz andere ganz anderes
verhalten haben logik haben ja.
Ja nichts dazu aber die nicht er täglichen find my devices ich weiß nicht da
habe ich nicht so unglaublich gute erfahrungen mitgemacht wie.
Lange dann die akkus auch so halten oder.
Die Batterien. Und wie gut die zu orten sind, etc.
Also ich finde auch dieses Standardmodell ist so simpel und funktionsmächtig,
warum ich jetzt da auf...
Ja gut, aber wenn es zum Beispiel nicht diese automatische Klingelfunktion hat,
das andere ist ja, wo ich mich auch wundere, wenn die mit dem Fahrrad dann durch
die Stadt fahren, dann müsste es ja auch die Warnung auf ihrem Telefon geben,
dass da ein AirTag mit ihnen mitreißt.
Wenn sie denn ein Apple-Gerät haben.
Aber erst nach zwei Tagen oder so.
Ich glaube, das hat Apple immer verschärft. Oder 24 Stunden oder so.
Ich meine, das wäre früher jetzt. Gut, die fahren natürlich nicht da drauf,
sondern die haben das im Lieferwagen hinten reingeworfen.
Also die pflücken halt mehrere Fahrräder bei einer Tour ab.
Das kann schon sein.
Und haben möglicherweise einfach ein Android-Phone dabei.
Genau. Das sind dann keine Apple-Nutzungen.
Das geht aber auch mittlerweile mit Android-Fones, theoretisch zumindest.
Praktisch weiß ich nicht, welcher Support da erforderlich ist,
aber die haben das ja auch.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Hinweis. Ich glaube, so eine Bimmel brauche ich auch mal.
Ja, ich tue auf jeden Fall was für die Kriminalstatistik.
Okay, also hier wird ein Nordic-Chipset verwendet, das auch Apple für die Bluetooth-Ortung verwendet.
Okay.
Achso, es gibt eine, die tatsächlich kein AirTag enthält.
Genau, die Klingel hat selber die Elektro- Also es gibt ja mittlerweile auch
so Third-Party-Sachen.
Ich habe zum Beispiel so eine kleine Kreditkartengroßen Tracker,
den man so Wireless auflädt, den man hier so reintun kann.
Ja, habe ich auch, aber der Akku ist ständig durch.
Ja, das ist nicht optimal, aber hier ist halt eine normale Batterie am Start,
die eigentlich genauso gut funktionieren könnte.
und dann hast du da halt auch kein AirTag drin und wenn das Ding dann anders sich verhält.
Dazu steht hier nichts. Warte mal hier.
Wie ist denn das? Meine ganz andere Frage. Gibt es diese Beschränkung von 16
AirTags noch für einen Apple-Account?
Das sind mehr jetzt.
Sind mehr jetzt?
Ich glaube 64 oder sowas haben sie hochgesetzt. Ja, dazu sagen sie jetzt hier
nichts. müsste man mal gucken, ob es hier einen Test gibt.
Da steht ein Lautsprecher, Piezoelement.
Ja, dass sie einen haben, okay. Zum Anpingen ist es ja in Ordnung.
Die Frage ist nur, verrät sich das Ding selbst, wenn man es bewegt?
Und hier steht dazu erstmal nix.
Slotter.
Da müsste man halt mal die Tests befragen.
Also da ist eine tauschbare CR2032 Knopfzelle drin, hält ein Jahr, sagen sie.
Ja, also genauso wie ein normales AirTag auch.
Da ist jetzt nichts besonders Tolles mit drin. Die Frage ist nur,
verloren Modus geht auch.
Sie haben auch ein Gurt, ein Kameragurt mit AirTag-Halter eingebautem.
Ist interessant, was sie so alles haben.
Na gut.
Guter Hinweis hier in dem Artikel, dass sie leider auch mit normalen Kreuzschließschrauben arbeiten.
Das wäre natürlich auch nochmal so ein Feature, dass man da so,
keine Ahnung, 5-Stern-Schraube oder sowas hat.
Aber das kann ja wieder kann keiner.
Ja, aber das ist am Ende das halt als Plastik, also das dann irgendwie,
wenn du das als Dieb weißt, einmal mit der Zange bei.
Dann ist das durch. Wenn du eine Zange hast, um ein Schloss zu öffnen,
dann kriegst du auch diese Bimmel relativ schnell ab.
Da würde ich auch von ausgehen.
Ja, du hast hier keine Nahdistanz- Auto, das steht hier dabei.
Das ist schon mal scheiße.
Das ist natürlich ein Feature von den...
Und ob da ein Lautsprecher drin ist zum Chirpen, steht nämlich auch nicht drin.
Doch, das steht drin. Das steht so.
Über 60 dB stand, glaube ich, drin.
Okay.
Du kannst auch noch mal den den,
Den anderen Link klicken. Glocke Radlaufchrom.
Ja.
Das ist die Laufklingel, von der ich sprach.
Die man so wie Dynamo...
Genau. Da hast du diesen Baudenzug und diese Mechanik und wenn du jetzt an dem
Ding, das ist so mit Daumen oder einem Finger, kannst du da ziehen.
Kannst aber nicht im Stehen klingeln.
Du kannst nicht im Stehen klingeln. Was du in der Regel aber auch nicht brauchst.
Also wenn du stehst, kannst du Leute auch anschreien. Das ist jetzt normalerweise
nicht so schwierig oder mit denen auch vernünftig reden.
Du möchtest, dass die dich durchlassen und die stehen vor dir und du möchtest...
Nee, aber die Dinger sind normalerweise, also sagen wir mal...
Zeig mal, wie das montiert ist. Kannst du mal dann Bilder weiter blättern?
Ist das schon eine rausgefuchste...
Nee, normalerweise machst du das einfach vorne an die...
Wie so ein Dynamo.
An die Gabel von dem, von der...
Und der hält sich, geht dann an den Reifen an die Seite.
Ja, ja, genau. Wie so ein Dynamo auch.
Okay.
Nur, dass du den halt bei Bedarf ziehen kannst. Die Dinger werden halt umso
lauter, je schneller du fährst. Und die werden richtig laut.
Deswegen sind sie auch eigentlich nicht erlaubt.
Aber man hört sie ja.
So, so oder nicht, sondern ist schon ein Klingeln.
Ja, ich dachte auch mal, man müsste vielleicht auch hinten so eine größere Druckflasche
auf den Gepäckträger und dann so eine Stadionsirene oder gleich sowas,
was LKW-Fahrer am LKW haben.
So ein bisschen Respekt verschaffen im Stadtverkehr.
Wenn nichts mehr hilft, dann einfach mal den Kompressor zünden.
Oh mei. Ja, so war das.
Das ist, wenn man zu lange in Berlin Fahrrad fährt, dann kommt man auf solche Ideen.
Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, Ralf, du machst Sachen. Spannend.
Da macht noch jemand einen guten Hinweis. Man kann wohl bei den AirTags den
Lautsprecher ausbauen.
Habe ich auch schon gemacht. Also genau genommen musst du nicht den Lautsprecher aufbauen.
Wenn du die richtig aufmachst, dann kannst du den Magneten rausziehen,
der tatsächlich dafür sorgt, dass da irgendwas schwingt.
Weil das nämlich nicht wirklich Piezo ist, was die machen.
Ja, aber dann kannst du ja nicht...
Nee, dann kannst du nicht schirpen lassen. Aber dann sind sie tatsächlich wirklich
ruhig und machen auch keinen Lärm mehr, wenn sie bewegt werden.
Ist dann aber vielleicht wieder schwierig, wenn die Polizei kein Schirpen hört.
Aber das kommt auf den Use Case an. In anderen Szenarien mag das dann funktionieren.
Ja, es ist eigentlich schade, dass die Stalker-Problematik und die Klau-Problematik
sich so ein bisschen widersprechen an der Stelle.
Ich kenne übrigens einen Fall von jemandem,
wo ihr vom Ex tatsächlich ein Airtag in die Tasche reingeworfen wurde.
Das findet statt. Das ist ein reales Problem.
Das ist nicht nur Potential, sondern es passiert.
Aber es ist so praktisch. Ich habe auch AirTags wirklich an allem dran und es
schafft einfach auch so eine, also mal abgesehen von dieser Klau-Problematik,
es ist manchmal einfach auch so dieses, habe ich alles dabei?
So, gucke ich auf mein Telefon und dann so bei dir, bei dir,
bei dir, bei dir, bei dir. So, ja okay, ich habe alles dabei.
Ich weiß zwar jetzt gerade nicht, wo ich meinen Schlüssel, in welche Tasche
ich den reingesteckt habe, aber er ist irgendwie da.
Habe ich den Probenraumschlüssel mit? Ja, habe ich.
Ich fahre ja wirklich wenig Auto und ich vergesse mal, wo ich das hinstelle.
Das ist auch so eine Anwendung.
Da habe ich jetzt halt auch einfach von den alten eins reingelegt.
Ja gut, aber wenn man jetzt ein Auto hat, das Bluetooth an Bord hat,
dann bekommst du ja in der Karte angezeigt, wo dein Auto steht,
weil er ja diesen automatischen Auto-Pin setzt, wenn er Verbindung zum Auto verliert.
Wenn wer Verbindung zum Auto verliert?
Das iPhone.
Ach so.
Also wenn du das per Bluetooth mit dem Autoradio koppelst, das muss gar nicht
Carplay sein, aber eben auch Carplay.
Aber nur wenn man dann so eine Bluetooth-Verbindung im Auto hat, macht er das?
Richtig, wenn das Telefon sich mit dem Auto per Bluetooth verbindet,
dann nimmt es den Pin weg und wenn es den Pin wieder verliert,
dann bleibt er da, wo das letzte Mal den Bluetooth-Pin verloren hat.
also das funktioniert in der Regel ganz gut und dann kannst du auf Maps sagen,
ja leite mich mal zu meinem Auto,
ja genau so.
Nächstes Thema ja also eins hätte ich noch 3D ich hab jetzt einen 3D Drucker.
Was haschst du denn?
Nach all den Jahren na und?
Dann bin ich also wirklich der Letzte dann.
Bist du der Letzte, ja Also ich habe mich ja wirklich, wirklich lange gesträubt,
weil ich die Technologie schon immer cool fand, aber irgendwie nie so richtig
so einen Anwendungsfall hatte.
Und jetzt begab sich einfach die Gelegenheit, dass ein Nachbar bei uns im Haus,
der auch wirklich voll Nerd ist und den ich in seiner Nerdigkeit noch gar nicht
genug angezapft habe, glaube ich.
der wollte sein Bamboo Lab A1 Mini,
loswerden, weil er sich nämlich da die nächstgrößere Version von geholt hat
und dann hat er da einen sehr fairen Nachbarschaftspreis gemacht und habe ich
mir das einmal angeguckt und hatte die aber auch schon vorher auf dem Schirm,
also weil dieses Bamboo Lab die haben ja schon so ein bisschen so das Versprechen
so das Apple der 3D Drucker zu sein,
wo das alles schön weg abstrahiert ist und eine fluffig zu bedienende App.
Das ist eine sehr closed Plattform.
In Bezug auf?
Alles.
Mit Auswirkungen von oder auf?
Naja, es ist schwer zu reparieren. Die Software ist closed source,
beziehungsweise die haben irgendwann
mal ein Open Source geforkt und dann geclosed oder so. Das ist, das ist.
Musst du beim nächsten Di-Day dann gleich wieder verkaufen.
Also das ist, sagen wir mal so, wenn man plötzlich Linux entdeckt hat,
dann ist Bambu Lab Nicht der richtige Drucker.
Ist das total untrue?
Dann ist es sehr untrue.
Ich wollte es jetzt aber erstmal gemütlich haben.
Die sind aber tatsächlich relativ gut und sie sind relativ günstig.
Ja, also der, den ich jetzt habe, der kostet jetzt neu, frisch von der Palette.
Richtig.
Gerade eben gesagt, Bambolab A1 Mini kostet frisch und neu 189.
Oh, das ist ja nichts.
So, man kann sich jetzt denken, wie viel ich jetzt noch für meinen Gebrauchten bezahlt habe.
Und wenn man sich dann, wenn man das Viecht dann mal so vor sich hat und sieht,
was da aber an Feinmechanik irgendwie verbaut ist, finde ich den Preis total absurd.
Sondern ist halt noch ein Farbdisplay drin mit Touch und macht.
Dinge und Kram und ich halte diese Grundtechnologie jetzt, wenn man sich ein
bisschen damit beschäftigt, schon für ein Wunder.
Wie das, also mit was für einem Tempo, der dann also wirklich nicht Milli,
sondern was ist das, Nanometer, Mikro Millimeter?
Nanometer, nicht Mikro. Submillimeter, nennen wir es mal so.
Dort die Dinge irgendwie printet, das ist schon wirklich klassische,
wenn Technologie nur weit genug fortschrittlich ist, ist sie nicht mehr von
Magie zu unterscheiden.
Das finde ich da schon einschlägig.
Und dieses Bamboo Lab mit dieser ganzen Softwareumgebung,
du kannst da SD-Karten reinstecken, das tut aber glaube ich keiner mehr,
sondern der hängt halt bei mir im WLAN und du hast auf dem iPhone deine App
und hast auch gleich deinen ganzen Store und in diesem Store kannst du also
Millionen und Abermillionen von 3D-Druckrezepten dir holen und kannst es dann
direkt übers Handy an den Drucker schicken und dann druckt der los.
Das ist also schon, wenn es funktioniert, ist es wirklich betörend,
so lange bis es nicht mehr funktioniert.
Und dann ist es so scheiße.
Also ich habe selten eine Technologie erlebt, wo dieser Wechsel von Genie zu
totalem Wahnsinn und völlig fuck up.
Also gibt es eine Technologie, mit der du das direkt vergleichen kannst? Tintenstrahldrucker.
Die haben doch aber im Großen und Ganzen irgendwie funktioniert.
Und wenn sie nicht funktioniert hat, hat man einmal den Kopf gereinigt und wenn
das auch nicht gereicht hat.
Hat man einen neuen...
Ja, aber es war einmal messy.
Also ich meine, die Technologie ist mittlerweile so weit fortgeschritten,
dass sie glaube ich nicht mehr so sehr viel Ärger macht, aber...
Aber es gibt Unterschiede, Tim.
Kann verdrecken und kann verstopfen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, aber die eigentlichen...
Warte mal, bevor du fortfährst, was war dein Use Case? Was war die Ausrede?
Kram für Kinder drucken.
Hm, steh rumchen.
Und kleine Helferlein für den eigenen Alltag. Da habe ich jetzt aber noch nicht so viele.
Aber man findet dann, wenn man es erstmal hat, findet man dann doch Anwendungen,
dass man irgendwie doch einen speziellen Halter für XY und da ist mal was kaputt
gegangen und da möchte man sich dann doch was wieder hindrucken und so.
Ich habe beispielsweise, das war ein ganz toller Moment, ein guter Freund von
Anton beim größeren, hatte von irgendeinem seiner größeren Geschwister einen
alten Gameboy Advanced irgendwas geschenkt bekommen.
Und da war hinten, die Batterieabdeckung fehlte.
Er hatte also dann dort ein irgendwie so ein Tape halt irgendwie drüber,
die habe ich gesagt so, ha!
So, wir haben doch jetzt einen 3D-Drucker geguckt, irgendwie Modell eingegeben,
da ist die Klappe, zehn Minuten später, glückliches Kind, denkt,
ich bin Gott, ja, hat einen reparierten Gameboy mit Das ist eigentlich das.
Worauf er hier aus ist. Ich bin Gott.
Mission accomplished. Großer hat ein Referat über, das ist ja absurd,
dass sie in der Grundschule dritte Klasse jetzt schon Referate halten.
Ich finde das überhaupt nicht absurd.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich finde das auch super, aber es ist schon weird.
Weil er gerade wirklich auf diesem Römerding unterwegs ist, hat er über Wohnen
in Rom ein Referat gehalten.
Und da haben wir ihm jetzt also eine römische Villa zum Aufheben gedruckt.
Was er dann also für sein Referat in die Schule mitnehmen konnte. So ein Kram halt.
Der Kleine wollte unbedingt eine Pyramide haben, die ein Geheimfach hat,
wenn man sie so umdreht und dann kann er da seine Schätze reintun und dann die
Pyramide wieder zudrehen und keiner weiß, dass da ein Schatz drin ist außer er und.
Alle anderen, die googeln können.
Also Dinge. Ich habe jetzt noch keine Killer-App, aber wenn man es erstmal hat,
ist es schon ganz praktisch.
Aber wenn du das mit einem Tinten-Strahldrucker vergleichst,
wie kaputt der auch ist, am Ende kommt ein Blatt Papier raus und da kannst du
wahrscheinlich Sachen lesen.
Es sind vielleicht Dinge verschmiert und es sind vielleicht Dinge irgendwie uncool.
Und Zeilen fehlen.
Aber der Range von dem, was da schief gehen kann, ist übersichtlich.
Und oh boy, was kann beim 3D-Drucker alles kaputt gehen.
Und dann, wenn der halt einmal aus dem Tritt ist, ist es komplett unrettbar
und alles, was bis dahin passiert ist, kannst du einfach schlicht nur noch direkt wegwerfen.
Ja, stoppen und wegwerfen.
Das ist richtig. Und zum Glück ist eine Kamera dran, also wie gesagt für dieses
Geld, ja da ist eine Kamera dran und ein Licht.
Ich habe den also im Schrank mal stehen gehabt, abgeschlossen,
damit er auch nicht so zustaubt, weil du musst ja auch ständig warten und nachölen und so.
Nachölen?
Ja, schon. Der hat einen Timer, wann er seine ganzen Schienen alle wieder geölt
haben möchte, damit das auch alles...
Das ist ja ein Tamagotchi und kein Drucker.
Ja, schon so ein bisschen. Aber dadurch, dass er halt eine Lampe hat und eine
Kamera, kannst du dann auch, wenn er im geschlossenen Schrank steht,
kannst du gucken, wie weit ist der Druck und ist dann noch alles schick und so.
Der hat am Anfang so eine Rüttel-Einmessung, um zu gucken, wie stabil steht er.
Weil dadurch so schnell, wie der sich bewegt, kommt das ganze Ding irre in Schwingung.
Und das kompensiert da auch alles softwaretechnisch.
Ja, die Bambu Labs machen das. Meiner macht das nicht.
Der ist dann von sich aus stabil genug.
Welches Modell hattest du noch mal?
Den Mark IV, den ich auf den Mark IV S aufgerüstet habe. Von Prusa.
Prusa.
Oder Prusa, wie man ihn wahrscheinlich eigentlich aussprechen müsste. Okay.
Genau, die hat da, das ist ja quasi die Linux-Variante des 3D-Druckers,
weil tatsächlich viele Teile auch Open-Source sind. Man die nachdrucken kann.
Die gesamte Software ist Open-Source.
Und du kriegst halt auch alle Ersatzteile für relativ wenig Geld.
Und was halt wirklich cool ist, es gibt diese Aufrüstsätze.
Sie bringen ein neues Modell raus und dann bringen sie für die alten Modelle
das Hardware-Diff und eine lange Anleitung. Gut, das hat zwei Stunden,
glaube ich, gedauert, bis ich den aufgebrüstet hatte.
Aber es ist halt auch geil, sowas selber schrauben zu können.
Und ja, kostet aber halt auch ein bisschen mehr. Also die Prusa-Drucker,
die sind nicht ganz billig.
Also auf jeden Fall gibt es jetzt irgendwie so zwei Faktoren,
die mich also echt in die totale Verzweiflung treiben.
Das eine ist, wie ultrasensibel diese Platte ist.
Also du lernst sofort, auf gar keinen Fall darfst du diese Platte,
auf der das Ganze hochgedruckt wird, mit den Händen irgendwie anfassen,
sondern immer nur seitlich an den Kanten und abwischen.
Bevor du druckst.
Und bloß nicht irgendwie, dass dort halt Fett von deinen Fingern,
weil sofort ist diese Arterins im Eimer.
Fett und dann haftet es nicht mehr richtig, das ist aber bei jedem Drucker so.
Und dann muss die Temperatur exakt richtig sein, dass du dann also die Platte
auf 64 Grad vorgeheizt hast.
Das macht das Gerät alles, da muss man sich im Prinzip nicht drum kümmern.
Aber es gab wohl auch mal eine Zeit, wo die immer zu kalt war und da muss man da hoch.
So und glaube aber auch mal nicht,
dass du zwei Modelle hintereinander auf dieser Platte drucken kannst.
Da musst du also wirklich, wie Roddy gerade sagt, die Platte erstmal wieder abmontieren.
Das geht einfach, da die hier mit so einem schönen Magnetmechanismus,
so ist schon alles ganz gut durchdacht. So, aber dann musst du die halt wieder
erstmal mit Spülmittel oder was anderem erstmal wieder von den letzten Mikrodingen entfernen.
Das muss ich nicht machen.
Ansonsten ist die erste Lage, die du druckst, sofort im Eimer.
Und ich habe jetzt das unanspruchsvollste Filament überhaupt,
so dieses Basic PLA, womit man also normalerweise irgendwie keinen Stress haben sollte.
Ich benutze immer Waschbenzin, weil Waschbenzin halt Fett gut löst und habe
damit eigentlich auch kein Problem.
Also Küchenrolle, bisschen Waschbenzin, einmal drüber.
Ja, also Bambu sagt, nehm normales Spülmittel, so reicht.
Spülmittel?
Ja, das ist auch fettlösend. Also zwar Bannik.
Ja schon, aber es ist ja nass hinterher.
Naja, kannst du ja trocken reiben.
Und so die ersten drei Drücke liefen halt perfekt durch. Und dann denkst du
ja, oh ja, ist ja wirklich wie bei Apple hier. Wunderbar, ich habe es verstanden.
Was haben die Leute denn?
Und dann aber halt irgendwie zwei Wochen nicht genutzt, im Schrank gestanden,
zugestaubt, obwohl im Schrank.
Und von da ab ging die Sache radikal abwärts.
Und dann merkst du dann halt auch, okay, das gibt dann echt so ultra viele Feinheiten,
die du dann plötzlich dann doch konfigurieren kannst.
Ob der erste Layer irgendwie mit einer anderen Temperatur aufgetragen wird,
ob der erste Layer, damit er besser hält, dicker aufgetragen wird als danach.
Ob du das Slicing, Das heißt also, wie diese ganzen Zwischenschnitte irgendwie
berechnet werden, nochmal modifizierst.
Ob das ursprüngliche Modell zu komplex ist von der Anzahl der Polygone her,
ob das runterrechnende ist, das kannst du auch alles in dem Lab machen.
Aber du hast plötzlich dann ein User-Interface vor dir.
Wenn du dann eben doch mal zwei Klicks nach links oder rechts machst,
kannst du bei dem Bamboo-Lab mindestens 200 Parameter einstellen.
Ja, das ist bei dem Prusa aber auch so.
Und dir wird nur so semi-gut erklärt, was das nun eigentlich gerade so für Auswirkungen hat.
Also das Einzige, was bei den Prusa ein bisschen merkwürdig ist,
sind die ganzen Methoden, Infill zu machen.
Also alles, was drinnen ist irgendwie. Aber ich habe festgestellt,
dass es sei denn, die Teile müssen
wirklich viel aushalten, braucht man da eigentlich nichts zu machen.
Weil auch das Standard-Infill auch das Schnellste ist. Also du kannst schnell
mal deine Druckzeit verdoppeln durchs falsche Infill, obwohl gar nicht so viel
mehr geinfillt wird, aber es legt dann komische Wege zurück.
Und nee, also diese ganzen Probleme habe ich nicht. Eine Frage,
wie lagerst du dein Filament?
Das ist auch im Schrank quasi am Drucker.
Eingezogen?
In einer Plastiktüte mit dem Entfeuchterpäckchen drin oder lässt du es einfach so rumstehen?
Das gerade Aktive lasse ich einfach so rumstehen, aber ich sehe worauf du hinaus willst.
Bei PLA ist es nicht so kritisch, aber auch das zieht Feuchtigkeit.
Und wenn es Feuchtigkeit zieht, dann hat das Filament die Eigenschaft,
dass diese Feuchtigkeit, wenn das Filament heiß gemacht wird,
natürlich auch heiß wird und dann zu Blasen bildet, weil sich ja Wasserdampf bildet.
und also gerade wenn du was anderes benutzt als PLA, kann das dazu führen,
dass du gar nicht mehr drucken kannst, wenn das Filament feucht geworden ist und mein Tipp ist,
räum das Filament, wenn du es benutzt hast, wieder zurück in die Plastiktüte
zusammen mit dem mit diesem Päckchen, was auch bei Arzneimittel ist.
Es sind noch wieder mehr Schritte.
Ja, da muss man wieder ausfädeln, wieder einfädeln und so weiter.
Ich würde eine voll klimagesteuerte Trockenkammer bauen.
Nee, aber das ist sowas, also nicht, dass ich viel Probleme damit hatte bisher,
aber die zwei oder drei Mal, wo bei mir wirklich Drucke schief gegangen sind,
war ziemlich sicher auch das Flament nicht mehr so fit.
Also es staubt natürlich auch altvoll, wobei ich sagen würde,
durch diesen Weg durch den Schlauch sollte das doch vermutlich dann wieder irgendwie
abgerieben werden, dass da Verschmutzungen und sowas eigentlich nicht am Kopf ankommen, oder?
Keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, ich packe das immer wieder weg. In der neuesten Software
von Prusa ist es so, dass nach dem Drucken das Filament auch wieder so weit
rausfährt, dass man eigentlich es nur noch wegpacken muss und das nicht mehr eingezogen ist.
Das könnte ich glaube ich auch aktivieren, wenn ich das wollte.
Das Feature gibt es auch. Das ist so das, worüber du mal nachdenken solltest.
Ansonsten kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel tun.
Keine Ahnung. Also ich kenne mich jetzt mit Bambu Lab auch nicht so aus.
Kann man Filament, das einmal Feuchtigkeit gezogen hat, wieder trocknen? Fragt jemand.
Jein, nicht so richtig gut. Also ich sammle diese Päckchen, wie heißt das Zeug?
Ja, diese Trockenpäckchen. Die zum Beispiel kann man tatsächlich im Backofen
oder im Airfryer bei der richtigen Temperatur wieder trocken machen.
Und wenn man dann so ein leicht feucht gewordenes Filament mit ganz vielen von
diesen gerade trocken gemachten Päckchen zusammen in eine Plastiktüte tut,
dann zieht das auch wieder die Feuchtigkeit weitestgehend aus dem Filament raus.
Silikagel.
Silikagel, genau. Das kann man auch in größeren Mengen. einfach so in Dingern kaufen.
Allerdings ist es eigentlich schlauer, darauf zu achten, dass man es gar nicht
erst feucht macht, das Filament.
Okay, Gott, da hast du jetzt ja wieder hier die Sache kompliziert gemacht.
Was erwartest du?
Du bist hier nicht in die Welt ist einfach. Ja, verdammt.
Ich dachte, ich hätte da jetzt mal was gekauft, was so einfach funktioniert.
Nee, also Ich habe auch schon den Kopf auseinander montiert und so,
weil ich hatte wirklich diese Phase, wo da gar nichts mehr lief.
Wie gesagt, PLA ist nicht umsonst das Anfängerfilament, weil das auch dieses
Feuchtigkeitsproblem eigentlich nicht so stark hat.
Wenn du mit PETG anfängst oder mit diesem, wie heißt das, MTU glaube ich,
TMU, keine Ahnung, es gibt so ein Gummizeug.
Das ist wohl so richtig fies, um damit zu drucken und es zieht sofort Feuchtigkeit.
Ich habe zu Hause auch noch ein Holzfilament, das habe ich allerdings noch nicht
ausprobiert, da kann ich noch nichts zu sagen.
Also das hat so einen gewissen Anteil an Holzmehl drin.
Und sieht holzig aus und riecht auch fürchterlich wie angebranntes Holz,
wenn man es druckt, habe ich mir sagen lassen, habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, wie gesagt.
Weiß ich aber nicht, ob man auch einen bestimmten besonderen Extruder haben
muss, der härter ist oder so, deswegen.
Es gibt bei dem Bamboo, falls ihn da draußen jemand hat, ich habe auch echt
so ein paar Fragen, die mir auch das Internet noch nicht beantworten konnte.
Der hat beispielsweise am Anfang
vor jedem Druck sinnvollerweise so eine automatische Flusskontrolle,
wo er erstmal ordentlich Filament durchschiebt mit unterschiedlicher Geschwindigkeit,
um zu gucken, wie verhält sich jetzt diese spezielle Mischung und packt dann
das, was er dann so in seine kleine Testklammer reinfließen lässt.
Das gibt dann so Kackhaufen quasi, die sich so selber aufdrüsseln.
Aber es kommt dann gar nicht so selten vor. Es gibt auch ein Mechanismus,
womit er das dann so zur Seite schiebt, so wegschiebt, damit quasi die Kammer wieder leer wird.
Es passiert aber gar nicht so selten, dass einfach durch Zufall,
Fraktal, Mathematik, keine Ahnung,
er sich selber dann während dieses Prozesses den Druckkopf zusuppt.
Weil einfach mal durch einen doofen Zufall diese Kackwurst direkt nach oben
wandert, anstatt zur Seite wegzukippen, wie es wahrscheinlich gedacht ist.
Und dann verstopft er sich selber und dann musst du erstmal wieder gucken,
dass du erstmal wieder die verstopfst.
Also ich kenne es von meinem Drucker, dass wenn du ein Filament einlegst,
er erst mal ein ganzes Stück durchjagt und hinterher fragt, stimmt die Farbe jetzt?
Weil der Druckkopf natürlich nie sauber ist, selbst wenn du das Filament ausgenommst.
Ich habe überhaupt nur weiß.
Ja, aber wenn du weiß hattest und willst dann schwarz drucken,
dann hast du so einen schönen Regenbogen. Wie haben wir es genannt?
Monochromverlauf. Von weiß nach schwarz, bis es dann tatsächlich die Schmerze hat, die es haben soll.
und das ist normal, dass nach einem Filamentwechsel halt du einfach ein Stück
Filament verlierst, weil er es dann halt durchdrückt.
Ja.
Aber gut, mit der Dingskammer, der Prusa hat das nicht.
Der kackt den Kram einfach so aufs Bett und irgendwo hin.
Und verlässt sich dann drauf, dass du das dann wegräumst.
Ja. Und dann macht er am Anfang immer so zwei Teststriche und die sind schon
immer halb kaputt, wo ich mir auch denke, das sollte doch eigentlich jetzt auch nicht sein.
Die Teststriche, die macht er bei meinem auch...
Ich glaube, es geht da drum, dass er tatsächlich auch den Fluss irgendwie da kalibriert oder so.
Also ich meine, er macht ja am Anfang, macht er ja überhaupt erst mal das Bett-Leveling.
Ob das Bett gerade ist, genau.
Naja, nicht ob, sondern er misst, wie es ist und stellt dann die erste Schicht so ein, dass es passt.
ja, dieses erste, ich weiß auch nicht, warum er das macht, aber normalerweise
ist das halt so ein Streifen, der entsteht halt am Anfang vom Druck und fertig.
Also auf jeden Fall so die ersten ein, zwei Layer sind immer sehr,
sehr aufregend. Zum Glück muss man aber sagen, sind es dann auch die ersten ein oder zwei.
Also wenn er über Layer 5 weg ist, so danach.
Die ersten zwei Layer sind immer die schwersten.
Ja, Layer 0 und dann Layer 1.
Aber es ist wirklich eine schlechte Idee, die dann einfach mal so eine Stunde
unbeaufsichtigt irgendwas drucken zu lassen.
Aber die Sache mit dem noch einen Rand dran drucken, damit es sich nicht verschiebt,
und Stützen und so weiter.
Also Stützen für überhängende Konstruktionen ist klar.
Aber... Normalerweise, wenn du, gerade wenn du was sehr Kleines von der Grundfläche
hast, was sehr hoch ist, so eine Art Turm,
Dann haben die die Tendenz, dass die, wenn du weiter oben bist beim Drucken,
sich dann irgendwann vom Bett lösen.
Und um das zu verhindern, kannst du im Slicer sagen, mach mir noch einen Rand dran.
Dann macht der auf der ersten Lage noch einen Rand und der hält es dann auch besser fest.
Und den macht man dann hinterher einfach ab.
Ja, genau.
Ach, verstehe.
Die eigentliche Frage ist ja, mit welcher hochqualifizierten Open-Source-Freiheitssoftware
erstellst du deine eigenen Modelle, wenn du jetzt nicht einfach nur aus dem Internet absackst,
was andere Leute in dem Schweiß ihres Angesichts schon nicht moduliert haben.
Ist das jetzt eine Prüfungsfrage?
Naja, ich meine, jetzt bist du an der selben Stelle, wo ich war,
als ich neulich mal so ein spezielles Teil brauchte und mir dachte,
geile Idee. und dann halt bei dieser Open-Source-Software gelandet bin und mir
dachte, das kann nicht euer Ernst sein.
Sprichst du von FreeCut?
Ja.
So, ich habe mir das noch gar nicht angeguckt. Ich bin bisher noch rein,
also hier dieses Bamboo-Lab selber hat einen Editor eingebaut,
aber auch selbst den habe ich mir noch nicht angeschaut.
Und ob ich in dieses Rabbit Hole nochmal reinsteige in meinem Leben,
habe ich noch nicht entschieden für mich.
Also du willst erstmal nur einen Replikator haben.
Ich will erstmal nur so einen Star Trek Replikator haben, genau.
Aber der Tag mag kommen, wo ich dann mal eine Woche Bock drauf habe und dann
spiele ich das auch mal durch.
Mein Tipp wäre, schau dir erstmal Shaper 3D an,
weil das ist von der Benutzung her noch am ehesten intuitiv für einen Mac-User
und du kannst damit lernen, wie man grundsätzlich erstmal was in 3D konstruiert.
Das ist leider so, dass du im Free-Tier,
nichts Sinnvolles tun kannst Also es ist eigentlich mehr so ein Lerntool um
hinterher zu sagen, okay jetzt habe ich es verstanden jetzt kann ich mich an
ein anderes Tool ranwagen Ich persönlich benutze Fusion 360 von Autodesk,
was,
ja
Es gibt einen Free-Tier, du kannst irgendwie zehn Modelle oder so bearbeiten.
Du kannst aber mehr machen, du musst dann nur immer umschalten zwischen,
das ist jetzt ein Modell, das ist nur Read-Only und das will ich jetzt bearbeiten und so weiter.
Leider ist Fusion schon echt hakelig von der Benutzung, weil sie nämlich die
normale gewohnte Benutzung umdrehen.
Das ist etwas, was ich vorhin bei der ganzen Diskussion von wo kommt Apple und
UI her eigentlich noch sagen wollte, ist nämlich, dass sie dieses Prinzip, ich markiere,
ich selektiere ein Objekt und führe auf dieses Objekt einen Befehl aus.
Das ist nämlich das, was der Mac eigentlich mal eingeführt hat.
Gut, vielleicht gab es das schon vorher, aber niemand hat das so konsequent
durchgezogen wie der Mac, wo du selektierst was und führst einen Befehl drauf aus.
Bei Fusion ist es genau andersrum. Du machst,
Drückst erst den Befehl, bekommst dann so ein Ding und dann kannst du dann anfangen,
Sachen zu markieren, auf die du dann den Befehl ausführen willst.
Und das ist am Anfang extrem nervig, weil es so unglaublich intuitiv ist.
Wenn man sich einmal dran gewöhnt hat, beziehungsweise es verstanden hat und
sich immer wieder sagt, erst den Befehl, dann selektieren, dann geht es auch irgendwann.
Also ich habe ja mal Maya gelernt. 3D-Modellierung. Das ist jetzt allerdings auch 22 Jahre her.
Und keine CAD-Software.
Und ich fand es damals schon mal kotzer aus der Hölle.
Ich habe noch zwei Tipps für dich. Also das eine habe ich nur gehört,
dass dieses Onshape wohl ganz benutzbar sein soll.
Und es ist halt browserbasiert, aber kostet wohl auch Geld.
Onshape ist irgendwo zwischen Fusion und Shaper 3D, in meiner Meinung nach.
Und dann gäbe es noch Blender und OpenS-Cut.
OpenS-Cut empfehle ich, es ist halt, OpenS-Cut ist eigentlich mehr so eine Programmiersprache.
Ja, C.
Deswegen empfehle ich das jetzt auch gerade, weil du kannst dir halt natürlich mit einer AI,
einfach OpenS-Cut-Files erzeugen lassen und ich habe da gehört,
dass das ganz gut funktioniert.
Das habe ich auch schon gehört, ja.
Damit könnte man also zumindest bestimmte gut beschreibbare Objekte,
vor allem so Objekte, die jetzt aber mal keine besondere Asymmetrie haben,
vermutlich gut starten.
Ähnliches Das gilt auch für Blender, da gibt es ja mittlerweile richtig so MCP-Integrationen
und du kannst dann irgendwie auch einen erzählen, wobei ich auch Blender,
also diese ganze CAD-Welt ist sehr...
Also, da ist… Altbacken? Naja, sagen wir mal, ich verstehe ja,
das ist komplex, was man da macht.
Also das ist komplex, das ist gelehrt, dreidimensional, mit allen möglichen
Properties und ich sag mal so,
ich hab so den Eindruck, dass dieser Softwarebereich sowohl sehr disruptionswürdig
als auch disruptionsfähig ist.
Also wenn da mal jemand mit einem wirklich guten Ansatz kommt und vor allem
das User-Interface ordentlich hinbekommt,
bei diesem FreeCut bin ich halt wahnsinnig geworden, weil das ist halt diese
typische Linux-Buckelei im User-Interface, wo dann immer nicht weiß,
musst du jetzt hier nochmal irgendwas drücken, damit es abgespeichert ist und
wo ist jetzt hier mein Fokus und weißt du,
einfach, ich weiß, es ist schwierig.
und so eine Software muss halt sowohl in seinem Backend und im Rendering sehr
gut sein, als auch im User Interface sehr gut sein und das sind meistens so
zwei Disziplinen, die selten gut zusammen gehen.
Ja und vor allen Dingen muss es halt hinterher passen.
Also bei BMW im Werk, wenn da die Schraube nicht sitzt und der Motor auseinanderfällt, ist halt blöd.
Ja, aber das sind die Anforderungen von einer professionellen CAD-Software.
Also deswegen, man handelt da Kaliber, die ja...
Du kriegst das schon hin, Ralf. Du muckelst dich da rein.
Also ich persönlich habe ja den 3D-Drucker mir selbst als Challenge erst gekauft,
als ich gesagt habe, okay, ich lerne jetzt ein CAD-Programm.
Ich moduliere da was mit etwas relativ erfolgreich.
Und wenn ich das Gefühl habe, okay, ich traue mir das zu, dann darf ich mir
auch einen 3D-Drucker kaufen. Und ich glaube, das war auch ganz gut,
sich da so zu challengen, weil sonst druckst du nur Stehrumchen.
Das 25. Banshee und weiß ich nicht was.
Wobei diese Fidgettoys schon auch sehr geil sind, die es da so gibt.
Ja, auch der Hochgeschwindigkeitspropellerwerfer, den kann ich empfehlen.
Ich google kurz.
Das ist ein fertiges Modell.
Das ist ein fertiges Modell, das ist großartig. Von so einem Propeller,
den man so wegschießen kann.
Ich glaube, ich ahne, ich glaube, ich habe das schon mal gesehen.
Such mal raus. Ich glaube, ich kenne das.
Wo man dann so an dem Teil reißt und dann… Nee.
Du drehst wie an so einer Pfeffermühle.
Ja, bist du am Recherchieren noch?
Ja, ich muss dieses Wort Hochgeschwindigkeitspropellerwerfer,
ich muss das jetzt hier mal eingeben.
Heißt das auch so?
Der Mensch, der das konstruiert hat, hat das Hochgeschwindigkeitspropellerwerfer genannt. Okay.
Deswegen, jetzt ich habe den Link, der Link folgt im Slack.
das lustige ist auf irgendeiner maker world hat tatsächlich jemand das mal in
einem völlig unklaren maßstab sprich so etwa ein meter hoch vom boden aus gedruckt.
Der link geht jetzt aber.
High speed propeller launcher nicht irgendwo hin zum maker world.
Ja, Maker World wird aufgerufen, aber das scheint hier kein richtiger Deep Link
zu sein. Boah, das ist ja wild.
Doch, das Ding ist es.
Okay, nee, das kenne ich doch nicht, aber das sieht ja geil aus.
Das sieht geil aus, das ist auch geil. Also das einzige Problem an dem Teil, du druckst es.
So ein Planetengetriebe drin? Nee.
Da sind mehrere Planetengetriebe drin.
Ah.
Drei, um genau zu sein.
Oh mein Gott.
Ein dreistufiges Planetengetriebe.
Aber aus wie vielen Teilen besteht das?
Ja.
Ja, das sind viele Teile und die soweit leichtgängig zu kriegen,
dass das Teil tatsächlich funktioniert, ist ein bisschen eine Aufgabe,
aber wenn es dann mal funktioniert, ist es wirklich geil. Also das kann ich echt empfehlen.
Also man bringt den erst auf Speed und dann releast man ihn quasi.
Nein, der hat vorne so eine Art Countergewinde.
Das heißt, solange du Speed gibst,
zieht das Countergewinde den Propeller nach unten und sobald du loslässt,
durch den Schwung entfernt er sich dann von dem Gewinde oben.
Das ist relativ geschickt gemacht.
18.300 Umdrehungen pro Minute.
Und das Ding fliegt wie Sau.
19 Stunden Druckzeit.
Hat man nicht das Problem, dass man den Propeller gar nicht wiederfindet?
Es gibt oranges Filament.
Ich würde da schon eher auf UV gehen. Oder auf phosphorisierend.
Phosphorisierendes Filament gibt es auch?
Ja, genau. Damit du das doch wiederfindest.
Also meine Kinder behaupten, dass sie noch alle Propeller haben,
die ich ihnen ausgedruckt habe. Ob das so stimmt, kann ich nicht sagen.
Haben die noch alle Propeller im Schrank?
Das sieht schon geil aus.
Aber wie gesagt, der ist schon geil.
Den habe ich das erste Mal gesehen in Hamburg auf der Easter Egg.
Da war ja so eine Halle, so eine relativ hohe Halle. Und man konnte locker den
Propeller bis an die Decke schießen.
Ohne jetzt groß ins Schwitzen zu geraten.
Das ist schon irgendwie.
So, ich gucke mal, ob das denn für mein Gerät überhaupt gehen würde.
Ja, das kriegst du schon hin. Es sind halt relativ viele Teile,
die muss man dann in mehreren Lagen und so weiter drucken. aber das kriegst
du hin. Ich glaube an dich.
Und ich sage es dir, deine Jungs werden es lieben.
Ja, den gibt es auch in ein paar Varianten. Natürlich.
Das ist dann halt auch so eine Sache, zu jedem Rezept, was man hier so findet,
gibt es dann noch fünf Variationen, die versprechen, irgendwelche Detailprobleme noch gut zu lösen.
Ja, ich habe den ja einfach als SDL runtergeladen.
Und ihn dann halt in dem Slicer von Prusa aufs Bett geräumt und slicen lassen.
Also hier ist einer, glaube ich, ein bisschen simpler noch von der Konstruktion her.
Aber genau dieser hier, den kann ich empfehlen. Der macht Spaß.
Der Hochgeschwindigkeitspropellerwerfer. Ich meine, allein der Ausdruck ist schon geil.
Das stimmt.
Und sehr deutsch. Aber gut.
Das stimmt. Jetzt habe ich hier den ersten Layer.
Gucken wir mal. Das ist auch schon, meine Druckplatte ist schon gut gefüllt,
hier alleine mit dem Propeller. So viel größer darf es noch nicht werden.
Das ist halt eine Einschränkung von dem A1 Mini, der ist dann halt nicht so groß.
Du meinst, er heißt Mini for a reason?
Ja, genau.
Ja.
So, dann kommen wir langsam zum Ende dieser Sendung, aber ich kann noch einen
Zukunftsausblick für deine 3D-Drucker-Aktivitäten mal projizieren.
Ich bitte darum.
Und zwar, wie wäre es denn, wenn so ein 3D-Drucker, so ein Modell beliebiger
Komplexität innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden vollständig auf einen Streich komplett drucken würde?
Das wäre sehr schön.
Egal wie sehr es sozusagen, wie detailliert es ist, wie filigran es ist.
Klingt nicht nach näherer Zukunft, aber gut, führen sie aus.
Gibt es schon und passenderweise habe ich jetzt gerade meinen Link dazu verhagelt. Wieso eigentlich?
Jetzt habe ich hier irgendwie was falsches Fenster. Warte mal, was ist denn hier los?
und zwar volumetrisches 3D-Drucken basiert, also das Ganze ist aus der Uni und
zwar Berkeley CAL Printing Group hat das gerade rausgehauen,
und das Ganze basiert auf so einem flüssigen Harz, also Resin,
transparent und was sie machen ist, sie nehmen das Modell, was du in diesem
Volumen sozusagen, also du hast quasi dieses flüssige Harz, wie nennt man das? Resin?
Harz.
In so einem Zylinder drin und dieses Harz hat die Eigenschaft,
dass es hart wird ab einer bestimmten Menge an Licht, was auf eine bestimmte Stelle aufdrückt.
Dann ballern sie da mit Lasern drauf.
Ja, das gibt es ja auch schon Drucker für,
Für diese Harz-Dinge.
Ja. Und die drucken, du meinst Drucker, die alles auf einmal drucken.
Nee, die drucken nicht alles auf einmal, die drucken auch schichtweise.
Genau.
Die haben nämlich irgendwie, also du hast so ein Becken, da ist das Harz drin,
von unten wird das UV-Licht reingestrahlt.
Das hast du schon mal gesehen.
Mit so einem LCD-Display, wo halt Pixel an- und ausgemacht werden,
wo das Harz aushärten soll und dann zieht der langsam das Modell nach um.
Aber die Flüssigkeit ist die ganze Zeit so drumrum.
Ja, genau.
Aber ich spreche nicht davon, sondern ich spreche halt wirklich von alles wird
auf einmal gedruckt und was sie halt machen ist,
dass sie quasi wie so ein Hologramm das
Modell von sozusagen einmal um das ganze Ding herum rotieren oder beziehungsweise
der Laser ist dann irgendwie gerade und dieser Zylinder mit dem Harz dreht sich
und sie beleuchten sozusagen immer von einer Stelle,
während sich der Zylinder dreht, in dieses Harz rein.
Und wie viel Licht sie dann jeweils auf welcher Ebene abgeben,
das wird halt vorher per Software ausgerechnet, sodass nur die Stellen,
wo was hart werden sollen, in der Summe so viel Licht bekommen.
Also sie fokussieren dann auf einen Punkt quasi?
Sie ja, also.
Müssen sie ja, ja, obwohl.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, der Effekt ist wirklich der, das Ding dreht sich quasi
einmal rum und danach hast du irgendwie ein fertiges Modell.
Und das finde ich ziemlich bemerkenswert.
Das ist die Frage, wie sehr diese Technologie, also wie lange das noch braucht
und ob das überhaupt sozusagen wirklich jetzt massenfähig ist.
Das hat natürlich auch Einschränkungen, aber in diesem Video,
was ich verlinke, sieht man,
dass auch super kleine, komplexe Modelle damit gedruckt werden können,
die so fast schon mikroskopisch daherkommen.
Und das Ganze geht halt sozusagen alles in einem Ratz.
Ja, das Problem an dem Harz ist halt, dass es giftig ist.
Also das ist ein unangenehmes Material, um damit tatsächlich… Harz generell
oder jetzt das transparente? Also dieses transparente Druckharz.
Deswegen, du kannst damit natürlich Sachen drucken und was du normalerweise
auch tust, wenn du gedruckt hast, ist, dass du es nochmal in eine UV-Kammer
legst, um es ordentlich auszuhärten oder tatsächlich in den Ofen.
Und dann musst du natürlich auch grundsätzlich, also gut auch die restlichen
Harzreste abwaschen und so weiter, wenn du es tatsächlich benutzen willst.
Deswegen hat sich das so zumindest in der Maker-Szene nicht so richtig durchgesetzt, dieses Harz.
Das ist halt auch einfach eine Sauerei.
Was macht denn das so toxisch?
Naja, also super toxisch ist es nicht, aber gesundheitsfördernd ist es glaube ich auch nicht.
Es ist halt einfach unangenehmes Material, so um damit zu arbeiten.
Und dann hast du halt das Ding, dann hast du fertig gedruckt,
dann musst du das restliche Harz wieder zurückkippen, dann musst du es alles
sauber machen und so weiter.
Das ist halt was anderes als so ein Drucker, wo du einfach nur eine Rolle Plastik einlegst.
Aber man kann damit wahrscheinlich keine Binnenstrukturen drucken also jetzt
beispielsweise so eine Rauten Struktur von innen, die halt irgendwie Stabilität
herstellt, weil der Laser halt immer nur es.
Muss nur rausfließen können weil alles was nicht hart ist.
Aber kannst du quasi zwei Schichten mehrere Schichten hintereinander damit aushärten
aus einem und demselben mehrere.
Schichten hintereinander also wenn.
Weil das sind jetzt halt alles Objekte, die eine klare Außenhülle haben.
Aber was ist mit der Struktur innen drin?
Da müsste ja der Laser quasi erst das Innen aushärten und dann auch mal nach draußen justieren.
Nee, du bestrahlst ja alle Punkte gleichzeitig.
Also du strahlst ja immer komplett durch und durch diese relativ schnelle Drehung
akkumuliert sich quasi das Licht für jeden Punkt und für jeden Querschnitt,
das wird nicht schwierig zu beschreiben,
also du guckst halt immer so den Querschnitt und wie hell muss es da sein und
das Licht, was du reinschickst, wird halt heller, umso mehr Punkte auf dieser
Achse sind, die beleuchtet werden. sollen.
Und es ist halt so getimt, dass dann am Ende die Summe des Lichtes an einem
jeweiligen Punkt bei der ganzen Umdrehung diesen Threshold übersteigt, wo es fest wird.
Sodass du im Prinzip jeden Pixel, jeden Punkt härten kannst.
Und wenn du danach eine Struktur hast, wo es nicht raus laufen kann,
dann hast du ein Problem.
Das ist die klassische Technik.
Wo du das rausziehst, glaube ich. Also, keine Ahnung, mich,
triggert der Typ so ein bisschen mit seiner Fokuhila und seinem Olibar.
Ja, ja, ist mir egal. Wo das jetzt beschrieben wird, wahrscheinlich gibt es
noch was anderes. Das habe ich aber jetzt nicht gefunden. Passt nur gerade zum Thema.
Ja, ja, das ist auf jeden Fall interessant. Also ich meine, das ist ganz offensichtlich
noch im Forschungsstadium.
Das Video ist jetzt auch schon von August letzten Jahres. Also von daher nichts.
Ja, aber cool, es geht voran. Daumen hoch.
Nee, 3D-Druck ist schon ein Rabbit Hole, in das man ganz schön tief reinfallen kann.
Und dann macht man eine Weile nichts. Ach, ich brauche noch das und das und
das. Und plötzlich, ich könnte auch noch das drücken. Ich könnte auch noch das drücken und so weiter.
So, haben wir unsere vier Stunden voll gemacht.
Aber sowas.
For your listening pleasure, liebe Leute. Genau. Die Freak Show.
Werbe- und Bullshit-frei für euch.
Ein Juwel.
Naja, werbefrei, bullshitfrei, keine Ahnung, das sollen andere beurteilen.
Bullshit gibt es hier keinen.
Wir wurden als Shopping-Kanal bezeichnet.
Was? Wir? Wieso denn? Weil die Leute dann immer was kaufen müssen.
R-Tags kaufen sie jetzt.
Aber uns ist das am Ende egal, weil da haben wir ja nichts mit zu tun.
Das könnt ihr machen, das könnt ihr auch sein lassen.
Wir verkaufen jetzt nur noch Linux-Distributionen.
Wir haben die Macht der freien Entscheidung.
Genau. Anthony Burgers. Genau. Jo, dann würde ich sagen, leiten wir doch mal
die Sendung ganz elegant hier aus mit Olle Steve und freuen uns.
Wir haben auch schon einen nächsten Termin, aber noch keinen übernächsten.
Da müssen wir noch dran arbeiten, aber wir kommen wieder.
Ihr wisst es und dann bitte uns wieder zuhören.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage. Wir kommen wieder. Keine Frage.
Alles klar. Macht's gut.
Bis dann.
Bis dann. Tschüss.